BILLS ON THE AGENDA THREE BILLS
ARE ON CONSENT ITEM NUMBER SIX
BY CENTER JACKSON.
ITEM NUMBER EIGHT SB THREE SIXTY
SIX BY SENATOR CHIANG AND ITEM
NINETEEN SB FIVE EIGHTY SIX BY
SENATOR ROBB ITEM SIXTEEN HAS
BEEN -- SB FIFTY FIVE FORTY ONE
BY SENATOR BATES HAS BEEN PULLED
FROM CONSENT.
SO THAT WILL NOT BE.
ON CONSENT.
SENATOR ALLEN IF YOU ARE READY
WE'RE GOING TO START WTH YOU.
SB THREE AND THEN YOU HAVE TO
BILLS WILL THEN GO TO SB TWO
NINETY SIX WE DO THANK YOU SO
MUCH EXCELLENT HOW JEREMY'S
RECEDE WHEN YOU'RE READY.
AND OBVIOUSLY WANT.
TO START BY TAKING SUGGESTED
AMENDMENTS THAT ARE IN THE
ANALYSIS THANK YOU -- IN THE WAR
AND WE TAKE THEM IN GEO
[inaudible]
BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE TIME TODAY
BUT I ALSO WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR WORKING SO
HARD ON THIS ISSUE BOTH.
LAST YEAR AND THIS YEAR.
SO MEMBERS -- THIS BILL.
IS IS IS SORT OF A FOLLOW ON TO
SEE PACK WHICH IS AN INSTITUTION
THAT WE HAD.
THE CALIFORNIA POSTSECONDARY
EDUCATION COMMISSION.
BOB THIS BILL ESTABLISHES THE
OFFICE OF HIGHER EDUCATION.
COORDINATION ACCOUNTABILITY
PERFORMANCE.
WHICH WILL ARTICULATE STATE
GOALS COORDINATE BETWEEN HIGHER
EDUCATION INSTITUTIONS.
PROVIDE OVERSIGHT AND ASSIST THE
STATE ESTABLISHING CLEAR HIGHER
EDUCATION GENDER SERVE STUDENTS
AND MEETS ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
WORKFORCE DEMANDS.
PEPSI BACK WAS FOUNDED IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY FOUR AND CUT
COMES OUT OF THE MASTER PLAN.
AND IT WAS TO SET OUT TO BE THE
STATE'S COORDINATION AND
PLANNING BY FOR HIGHER ED.
AND YOU KNOW I ACTUALLY THINK IT
WORKED DECENTLY OVER THIRTY
YEARS AND PROVIDE A FISCAL
POLICY VICE THE GOVERNOR AND
LEGISLATURE.
ON POST SECONDARY ISSUES A
MONTOR PUBLIC INSTITUTIONS
PROVIDE STATEWIDE PLANNING.
BUT THERE IS A MEMBER OF YOUR
ISSUES BEGIN TO EMERGE IN THE
EARLY. TWO THOUSANDS ABOT --
THE FUNCTIONING OF C. PACK.
AND AS FOLKS REMEMBER.
IN TWENTY TEN ALEJO ISSUED A
REPORT CALLING FOR ITS REFORM OR
REPLACEMENT.
THE GOVERNOR BROWN HOUSE.
AND IN -- TWENTY ELEVEN TO
TWENTY TWELVE HE VETOED FUNDING
FOR A FOR C. PACK.
ANY CITED THE AGENCY'S
INEFFECTIVENESS IN HIGHER
EDUCATION OVERSIGHT SO THE ONLY --
CAME BACK RE IMMEDIATELY
AFTERWARDS AND SAID OKAY GREAT.
WE GOT TO SEE TECH HAD PROBLEMS
WE NEED TO HAVE SOMETHING IN
THERE TO REPLACE IT.
AND THEY TALK ABOUT
REESTABLISHING INDEPENDENT
OVERSIGHT BODY.
AND THEY ALSO SAID THAT IN THE
ABSENCE OF OF ANYBODY LEXI PACK
THERE'S NO CLEAR ARTICULATION
AROUND SPECIFIC STATE GOALS IN A
SPECIFIC ENTITY.
CHARGED WITH LEADING THE
CONVERSATION AND DURING A PUBLIC
AGENDA.
AND SO BUT THERE WERE SEVERAL
TIMES TO TRY TO ADDRESS THE
GOVERNOR'S CONCERNS NONE OF THEM.
PER SUCCESSFUL ARE WE'RE REALLY
HOPING THAT THIS IS THE THIS IS
THE MAGIC BULLET THAT WILL SOLVE.
THE PROBLEM THIS BILL ESTABLISH
AN INDEPENDENT OFFICE WILL FOCUS
ON QUALITY PROGRAM OVERSIGHT
REVIEW AND ANALYZE.
A VARIETY VARIETY DID INCLUDE
GRADUATION RATES AFFORDABILITY
FINANCIAL AID O GREEN
CERTIFICATION COMPLETION
TRANSFER.
AND WORK FORCE COORDINATION.
IN CONTRAST TO SEE PACK.
THE BOARD WILL MAINTAIN
INDEPENDENCE FROM THE HIGHER
EDUCATION INSTITUTIONS IS AN
IMPORTANT ISSUE I THINK OF THE
GOVERNOR HAD.
HAS COMMITTEE COMPOSED OF FIVE
MEMBERS THE PUBLIC APPOINTED BY.
THE GOVERNOR AND THE LEGISLATURE
AND THEN WE'LL HAVE AN ADVISORY
BOARD IT'S MADE UP OF OF OF YOU
SEE CSU CC PRIVATE NONPROFIT
PUBLIC POST.
INSTITUTION STUDENTS AND FACULTY
AS WELL.
AND THEY WILL GIVE
RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE BOARD.
SO I THINK THESE CHANGES WILL
ADDRESS SOME OF THE WEAKNESSES
THAT EXISTED C. PACK.
OUR WALL ALSO CARRYING ON WITH
THE IMPORTANT CORDONING WORKED
AT C. PACK USED.
TO I USED TO ENGAGE IN THAT WE
REALLY DESPERATELY NEED IN
THERE'S BEEN SEVERAL REPORTS ARE
OUTLINED ANALYSIS.
THAT TALK ABOUT THIS SO WITH ME
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL IS
TAYLOR MYERS REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA COMPETES.
AND ALSO SERRA ARE SO USERS IN
THE CAMPAIGN FOR COLLEGE
OPPORTUNITY NOW ALSO WANT TO
WELCOME.
MY JOIN AUTHOR ON THIS VERY
IMPORTANT BILL YOUR COLLEAGUE
SENATOR LASER YEAH.
CENTER GLAZER BEFORE WE BEGIN
THANK YOU SENATOR ALLEN I'D LIKE
TO ESTABLISH A QUORUM.
LEYVA HERE LEYVA HERE WILK.
PRESIDENT WILL CARRY CHIANG
RUSSELL.
RUSSELL HERE GLAZER.
GLAZER HERE MCGUIRE PAN.
WE HAVE A QUORUM AND BEFORE WE
GET TO YOU CENTER GLAZER AND OUR
WITNESSES WE DO HAVE A VERY LONG
AGENDA SIMON ASK EAST WITH EACH
WITNESS. TO ONLY SPEAK FOR TWO
MINUTES.
PLEASE PROCEED YOUR LEYVA JUST A
IN BRIEF THAT FIRST TO THANK
MICHAEL AUTHORED BY JOINT
AUTHORS SENATOR ALLEN FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP.
AND A COUPLE POINTS OF
PERSPECTIVE -- I DID WORK WITH
C. PACK BACK IN THE SEVENTIES
AND I'VE SEEN THE COURSE IN
WHICH THEY HAVE RUN OVER MANY
DECADES NOW AND AND IT IT WAS IT
WAS A GREAT ORGANIZATION DID
PROVIDE A LOT OF GREAT WORK I
DID CATCH A CALCIFIED OVER TIME --
AND I WOULD SAY BECAUSE I WAS
AROUND THAT THAT THAT THE
GOVERNOR BROWN'S ACTION TO
ELIMINATE IT.
HAD LESS TO DO WITH POLICY AND
MORE TO DO WITH THE FISCAL
CRISIS STATE WAS FACING WE MAKE
CUTS ALL ACROSS THE BOARD -- IN
OUR STATE AND AND AND AND C.
PACK WHILE THE BUDGET WAS MODEST
THAT NOTHING WAS SPARED AT THE
EXTENT THAT THAT TWENTY EIGHT
BILLION HAD TO BE FOUND -- I
WOULD SAY TO THE CREDIT OF THE
INSTITUTIONS.
THAT THEY HAVE CONTINUED TO MEET
ON AN INFORMAL BASIS THEY I
THINK THEY GET TOGETHER EVERY
MONTH.
AT TO THEIR CREDIT THEY KNOW THE
VALUE OF OF CONSULTATION AND
COORDINATION AND COMMUNICATION --
BUT IT'S IT'S ON AN INFORMAL
BASIS AND WHAT'S BEFORE YOU IS A
MUCH MORE FORMALIZATION OF OF
THIS KIND OF COORDINATION WHICH
IS SO IMPORTANT AND WITH THAT TO
JOINT CENTER ALLEN ASKING FOR
YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU CENTER CLEAR THE
GLAZER WITNESSES AND SUPPORT
PLEASE PROCEED.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING CHARLIEBY MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
TAYLOR MYERS AND THE POLICY AND
RESEARCH ANALYST FOR CALIFORNIA
COMPETES HIGHER EDUCATION FOR A
STRONG ECONOMY.
AN INDEPENDENT NONPROFIT PROJECT
THAT HAS LONG SUPPORTED GREATER
OVERSIGHT AND COORDINATION IN
HIGHER DUCATION TO PROMOTE
STUDENT SUCCESS.
I'M HERE TODAY IN SUPPORT OF
SENATE BILL THREE INTRODUCED BY
SENATORS ALLEN ENCLOSURE WHICH
WOULD ESTABLISH THE OFFICE OF
HIGHER EDUCATION COORDINATION
ACCOUNTABILITY AND PERFORMANCE.
THE STATEFACES CRITICAL
POSTSECONDARY.
CHALLENGES INCLUDING RISING
COSTS CAPACITY CONSTRAINTS AN
INEQUITABLE OUTCOMES NO SEGMENT
OR GOVERNING BODY IS CHARGED
WITH ADDRESSING THE CHALLENGES
AND WHOLE.
NOW MORE THAN AT ANY OTHER TIME
SINCE THE MASTER PLAN FOR HIGHER
EDUCATION WAS CHARTERED IN.
NINETEEN SIXTY THE STATE NEEDS
EXPERT LEADERSHIP TO SUPPORT
EQUITABLE COLLEGE ACCESS AND
COMPLETION FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS.
WELL THE SEGMENTS OF MADE
IMPORTANT EFFORTS TO ADDRESS
CHALLENGES AND HIGHER EDUCATION
SUCH AS AFFORDABILITY ACCESS AND
TIME TO DEGREE FUNDAMENTALLY
THESE ARE SYSTEMIC PROBLEMSTHAT
TRANSCEND ANY ONE INSTITUTION OR
SEGMENT.
AND THEY REQUIRE SYSTEMIC
SOLUTIONS THE OFFICE ESTABLISHED
BY SB THREE COULD TAKE A STATE
WIDE APPROACH TO ADDRESSING
ISSUES SUCH AS INSTITUTIONAL
CAPACITY AND SUPPORTING CROSS
SECTOR INITIATIVES SUCH AS DUAL
ENROLLMENT AND TRANSFER PROGRAMS.
SPECIFICALLY SB THREE CREATES
THE INFRASTRUCTURE TO DEVELOP
STATEWIDE HIGHER EDUCATION GOALS
OVERSEE INTER AGENCY EFFORTS AND
TO PROMOTE EVIDENCE BASED POLICY
MAKING BY USING DATA ACROSS
EDUCATION AND WORKFORCE SECTORS.
FURTHER SB THREE CAREFULLY
THINKS THROUGH THE APPROPRIATE
ROLES OF KEY STAKEHOLDERS
CREATING AN ADVISORY BOARD WITH
STUDENT AND SEGMENT
REPRESENTATIVES.
THESE FUNCTIONS WILL IMPROVE
OUTCOMES ACROSS DIVERSE REGIONS
AND STUDENT POPULATIONS IN
CALIFORNIA.
OUR HIGHER EDUCATION SYSTEM
REQUIRES COORDINATED LEADERSHIP
AND DATA DRIVEN DECISION MAKING
THAT CENTERS THE NEEDS OF
STUDENTS. FOR THESE REASONS WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT SB THREE AND WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU PLEASE PROCEED.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR ELEVEN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THERE
ARE SEE ON BEHALF OF THE
CAMPAIGN FOR COLLEGE OPPORTUNITY.
WHERE AN ORGANIZATION THAT'S
COMMITTED TO INCREASING COLLEGE
ACCESS AND SUCCESS IN THE STATE
FIRST LIKE TO THANK SENATOR
ALLEN AND GLAZIER FOR THEIR
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE AND
EXPRESSED OUR SUPPORT OF AB ARE
I'M SORRY SB?
THREE WE KNOW THAT IN THE COMING
YEARS THE STATE MONEY TO GROWING
SUPPLY OF EDUCATED WORKERS TO
MEET THE DEMANDS OF THIS DYNAMIC
STATE ECONOMY AND THAT KEY TO
FILLING THIS NEED.
WILL BE ENSURING THE ACCESS AND
SUCCESS OF THOSE POPULATIONS
THAT HAVE HISTORICALLY BEEN
UNDERREPRESENTED IN HIGHER
EDUCATION.
YEAH CALIFORNIA CURRENTLY STANDS
OUT AS ONE OF ONLY TWO STATES
WITHOUT A STATEWIDE COORDINATING
BODY FOR HIGHER EDUCATION.
MEANING WE LET THE STATE LEVEL
LEADERSHIP RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
PLANNING OVERSIGHT AND
COORDINATION THE POSITION THE
STATE TO MEET THESE CHALLENGES.
A BODY THAT IS NOT
REPRESENTATIVE OF ANY ONE SECTOR
SEGMENT BUT RATHER UNDERSTANDS
THE BROADER NEEDS O THE STATE.
I CAN FACILITATE THE NECESSARY.
HE'S ME CONVERSATIONS AND
ALICE'S AN EXPERTISE TOWARDS
THOSE GOALS.
WELL IN PERFECT THE CALIFORNIA
POSTSECONDARY EDUCATION
COMMISSION WAS ABLE TO OFFER
ENROLLMENT PROJECTIONS AND
ASSESS REGIONAL DEMANDS CRITICAL
INFORMATION NECESSARY TO
INFORMING POLICY IN BUDGETARY
DECISIONS.
IN ITS ABSENCE THE CAMPAIGN FOR
COLLEGE OPPORTUNITY AS HAVE
OTHERS ARE OFTEN ASKED TO HELP
FILL THE VOID IN VARIOUS WAYS
THAT IS NEITHER SUSTAINABLE MORE
IDEAL IN A STATE WAS SYSTEMS.
AS LARGE AND COMPLEX AS
CALIFORNIA.
SB THREE RECOGNIZES THIS
CRITICAL VOID AND ESTABLISH A
STATE LEVEL LEADERSHIP POSITION
TO CONFRONT THESE CHALLENGES.
IMPORTANTLY IT ALSO REPRESENTS
AN OPPORTUNITY AND MEANS FOR THE
STATE TO ARTICULATE A LONG RANGE
VISION FOR HIGHER EDUCATION WITH
CLEAR ACTIONABLE GOALS FOR
ENSURING COLLEGE ACCESS STUDENT
SUCCESS.
IN CLOSING RACIAL AND EGIONAL
EQUITY GAPS THAT ARE NECESSARY
TO MEETING FUTURE WORK FORCE
NEEDS.
THANK YOU AND WE RESPECTFULLY AT
ARCHER I ABOUT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
PLEASE GO TO THE MICROPHONE
STATE YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION AND
YOUR SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MANY RODRIGUEZ ON
BEHALF OF THE EDUCATION TRUST
WEST HERE IN SUPPORT.
Q. VERY WASHINGTON CAL STATE
SOONER SO STATION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
IN THEIR SIZING HIM STUDENT UCLA
WITH THE UC SINISTER STATION IN
SUPPORT.
OUR MODEL L. UNDERGRADUATE
STUDENT AT UCLA AND IM SUPPORT.
COMAIR PHASE UNDERGRAD SOON AYE
UCLA AS WELL AND ALSO IN SUPPORT.
ADAM HARVEY UNDERGRADUATE
STUDENT AT UC DAVIS ALSO SUPPORT --
PUSH ON WITH THE UC SINICIZATION
THE WE ARE IN SUPPORT AND WE
SPECIALLY THANK TO SENATORS FOR
INCLUDING STUDENTS IN THE IN THE
COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE OF IT TO
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
DOES ANYONE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS CONCERNS.
THE BILL BILL HAS BEEN MOVED
CENTER ALLEN WHICH LIKE TO CLOSE
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE ALL THE
HARD WORK IT'S KIND OF THING
FROM ARE A FANTASTIC SENATE
COMMITTEE STAFF.
AND THAT WITHOUT I RESEARCH HAS
RIVALS VERY GOOD THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHTS TO DO PALS TO G. O..
MA'AM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
I AM TOO SB THREE THE MOTION IS
DUE PASSED A GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATION LEYVA AYE LEYVA AYE
WELL.
WILK I CHIANG GLASSELL.
WRESTLE AYE GLAZER.
GLAZER AYE MCGUIRE PAN.
PAN HI.
BUT WE HAVE A A LITTLE BIT OF
OUT F ORDER HERE WE'RE GOING TO
GO BACK UP -- TO ITEM NUMBER TWO
SO CENTER ALLEN I KNOW THAT YOU
HAVE A COMMITTEE CHAIR.
CAN SENATOR GLAZER PRESENT OR DO
YOU WANT TO GO DOWN TO YOUR TO
NINETY SIX OF WHAT I'M TO DO IS
BE HERE WITH SIDES IN A GLAZER
FOR SB TWO WERE JOINT AUTHORS OF
THIS -- ONE IF THIS DOES GO
QUICKLY I'LL TRY THE OTHER BILL
IF OTHERWISE I'LL COME BACK --
VERY GOOD WE'RE HAPPY TO
ACCOMMODATE YOU HEAR ON THE
EDUCATION COMMITTEE.
SENATOR GLAZER OF PRESENTING SB
TO PLEASE PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE
READY.
MADAM CHAIR WANTED THANK -- YOUR
COMMITTEE STAFF AND YOU FOR
WORKING WITH US ON THIS
LEGISLATION HAPPY TO ACCEPT THE
AMENDMENTS THAT ARE DISCUSSED IN
THE ANALYSIS.
THIS BILL WOULD CREATE A
STATEWIDE DATA SYSTEM TO TRACK
INDIVIDUAL STUDENT PROGRESS FROM
PRESCHOOL THROUGH COLLEGE AND
INTO THE WRK FORCE.
SPECIFICALLY THE BILL WOULD
REQUIRE AN ACCOUNTABILITY OFFICE --
THAT WOULD CONVENE A COMMITTEE
REVIEW COMMITTEE MADE UP OF
VARIOUS EDUCATION STAKEHOLDERS --
TO ADVISE THAT OFFICE THE
LEGISLATURE ANY ADMINISTRATION
ON THE CREATE EXPIRATION OF THIS
DATABASE.
AS YOU ALL KNOW CALIFORNIA
COLLECTS A MASSIVE AMOUNT OF
DATA ABOUT STUDENTS HOWEVER THE
DATA COLLECTED.
IS MAINTAINING SYSTEMS THAT ARE
NOT AT ALL CONNECTED.
AS A RESULT OF THESE DISCONNECTS
IMPORTANT INFORMATION ABOUT
STUDENT PROGRESS IS OFTEN
IMPOSSIBLE TO ACCESS.
A STARK EXAMPLE OF WHY THIS IS
NEEDED. THIRTY TWO THOUSAND
STUDENTS WHO QUALIFIED FOR CSU
ADMISSION LAST FALL WERE DENIED.
BUT WITHOUT A LONGITUDINAL DATA
SYSTEM WE HAVE NO IDEA WHAT
BECAME OF THEM DID THEY GO TO
COMMUNITY COLLEGE TO THEY GO TO
A PRIVATE UNIVERSITY DID THEY
MOVE OUT OF STATE.
THEY JUST ENTER THE WORK FORCE
WITHOUT A COLLEGE EDUCATION.
THESE INFORMATION GAPS ARE SICK
ARE SIGNIFICANT WEAKNESS IN
CALIFORNIA'S CURRENT APPROACH
WE'RE UNABLE TO ANSWER IMPORTANT
QUESTIONS ABOUT STUDENT PROGRESS
AND OUTCOMES -- AND AT THAT
THERE'S MANY EXAMPLES OF THAT
THAT UP.
OF THESE TYPES OF QUESTIONS THAT
WE CAN ANSWER WITH DATA AND MY
WITH THIS IS WILL PROVIDE SOME
OF THAT BACKGROUND.
OUR STUDENTS AND THEIR FAMILIES
ARE BETTER OFF IF THEY KNOW WHAT
HAPPENED IN THE PAST -- WITH
PREVIOUS STUDENTS THEY'LL BE
BETTER OFF THE DATA IS AVAILABLE
TO THEM PUTTING THEM IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION.
AND WE AS POLICY MAKERS WILL BE
BETTER OFF CRAFTING POLICY
INFORMED BY DATA.
WITHOUT I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION AND PLEASED
TO HAVE SOME -- WITNESSES WITH
WITH ME TO TESTIFY BUT I WANT TO
INVITE MY JOINT AUTHORED A
SENATOR ALLEN TO SAY SOME THINGS.
THE PERCENT A GLAZER CENTER
ALLEN THANK YOU MY MANAGER ME
THIS THIS -- MERRY'S VERY NICELY
WITH THAT SB THREE NINETY
PROJECT THE COMMITTEE SUPPORT OF
THAT BILL HI AS YOU'LL NOTICE ON
PAGE FIVE I'VE THIS BILL THIS
BIZ FOLDED INTO WELL WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO WITH THE OFFICE OF
HIGHER EDUCATION CORONATION.
ACCOUNTABILITY PERFORMANCE IS
ALL ABOUT DATA COLLECTION SO WE
CAN BETTER UNDERSTAND HOW TO
SERVE OUR STUDENTS.
THANK YOU CENTER ALLEN WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT PLEASE PROCEDURE TWO
MINUTES.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR LEYVA AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR HAVING ME --
MY NAME IS RAY YES AND UP TO
FIVE AND I'M THE INTERIM
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF CALIFORNIA
CAN.
PETE'S HIGHER EDUCATION FOR A
STRONG ECONOMY I'M HERE TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF SENATE BILL TWO
INTRODUCED BY SENATORS GLAZIER
AN ALLEN WHICH WOULD CONVENE A
REVIEW COMMITTEE TO ADVISE ON
THE STRAPLESS MEN OF THE STATE
ONE LONGITUDINAL STUDENT
DATABASE.
TODAY THE NEED TO IMPROVE
EDUCATIONAL OPPORTUNITIES AND
OUTCOMES HAS NEVER BEEN MORE
URGENT THE DEMAND FOR A HIGHLY
SKILLED WORKFORCE GROWS WHILE
MOST CALIFORNIANS STRUGGLE WITH
BURGEONING INCOME INEQUALITY.
OF OPTIONS LAY BEFORE
POLICYMAKERS TO BETTER SUIT IF
STUDENTS AND FAMILIES BUT
CALIFORNIA'S DECISION MAKERS ARE
ACTING IN AN INFORMATION VACUUM.
THE STATE HAS A VERY LIMITED
ABILITY TO DIAGNOSE ITS
CHALLENGES IN EDUCATION --
INVEST WISELY IN SOLUTIONS AND
THEN COMPREHENSIVELY ASSESS THE
IMPACTS OF THOSE INVESTMENTS
WITHOUT IN FULLY INTEGRATED TOP
TO BOTTOM DATA INFRASTRUCTURE
CALIFORNIA'S LEADERS LACKED THE
INFORMATION THEY NEED TO BEST.
SERVE STUDENTS WORKERS AND THE
ECONOMY -- WE SUPPORT SB TWO
BECAUSE SYSTEMATICALLY
INTEGRATING DATA FROM PRESCHOOL
TO WORKFORCE IS A KEY STEP FOR
CALIFORNIA TO MODERNIZE.
THE EDUCATION SECTOR OF THE LACK
OF A COMPREHENSIVE DATA SYSTEM
PREVENTS POLICYMAKERS FROM
PINPOINTING WHERE CALIFORNIANS
FALL THROUGH THE CRACKS OF THE
EDUCATION TO EMPLOYMENT PIPELINE.
HOW THAT VARIES BY RACE GENDER
REGION AND INCOME AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY WHY IT HAPPENED IT'S
MIND BOGGLING THAT OUR STATE
CAN'T ANSWER SEEMINGLY
FUNDAMENTAL QUESTIONS LIKE?
IN A GIVEN YEAR HOW MANY KIND OF
CALIFORNIA HIGH SCHOOL GRADUATES
ENROLLED IN COLLEGE IN THE NEXT
FALL BECAUSE K. TWELVE AND
COLLEGE DATA SYSTEMS DON'T SPEAK.
FULLY TO ONE ANOTHER -- THE
SEGMENTS ARE ARE YOU.
INDEPENDENTLY HOLD RICH DATA BUT
THE SEGMENTED APPROACH LIMITS
UNDERSTANDING OF HOW THE
EDUCATION WORK FOR SYSTEMS
COMPLEMENT ONE ANOTHER SB TO
CREATE AN INFRASTRUCTURE TO MAKE
THESE DATA ACTIONABLE FOR
PURPOSES OF IMPROVING OUTCOMES
AND REDUCING DISPARITIES -- IT
CAREFULLY THINK THROUGH THE
INCLUSION OF APPROPRIATE ROLES
OF KEY STAKEHOLDERS LIKE THE
SEGMENTS SOCIAL SERVICES
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT STUDENT
ASSOCIATIONS AND IT ALSO
ADDRESSES ISSUES THAT OFTEN
ARISE IN CONVERSATIONS ABOUT
DATA LIKE PRIVACY AND PUBLIC
ACCESS -- SO FOR CALIFORNIA
PROGRESS IN THIS AREA IS LONG
OVERDUE AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME AND ATTENTION TO THIS
IMPORTANT ISSUE THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
THE MORNING CERRILLOS WITH EACH
PLUS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
THERE ARE SEE CAMPAIGN FOR
COLLEGE OPPORTUNITY IN SUPPORT.
TWENTY MANY RODRIGUEZ WITH THE
EDUCATION TRUST WEST IN SUPPORT.
GABRIEL GARCIA WITH THE
SOUTHEAST ASIA RESOURCE ACTION
CENTER ALSO IN SUPPORT.
MAY WASHINGTON WITH CAL STATE
STUDENTS ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING WITH ALL THE OTHER
METALLIC IN KATE WITH PUBLIC
ADVOCATES IN SUPPORT -- HI ADAM
HOW TO BE A UC DAVIS
UNDERGRADUATE STUDENT WITH YOU
SEE SOME ASSOCIATION ALSO IN
SUPPORT OF LIKE THAT AS A
CURRENT STUDENT -- CREATING SUCH
DATABASES WOULD BE IMMENSELY
HELPFUL AT ALL LEVELS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THE WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION.
SEEING AND HEARING THAT IS
BROUGHT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
ANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS YES
DOCTOR PAN.
I THANK YOU AND CERTAINLY --
APPRECIATE -- THE OPPORTUNITY
PRESENTED BY HAVING ACTUALLY A
MORE COMPLETE DATABASE WHERE WE
WOULD BE ABLE TO BETTER TRACK --
OUTCOMES AND OTHER TYPES OF
MEASURES.
BECAUSE ONE QUESTIONS I JUST HAD
WAS IS THAT IN TERMS OF THE DATA
SAID IT SAYS THE DATA RESIDES
WITH THE OWNERSHIP FOR STILL
RESIDES WITH EACH SEGMENT.
SO -- IN TERMS OF FOOTBALL I
GUESS ONE QUESTION WOULD BE IS
IS THAT -- IT IS THIS DATA GOING
TO BE AVAILABLE.
YOU MENTION ANALYSIS AND I'M NOT
SURE WHICH KNOW WHETHER THE BODY
THAT'S CLOSER TO ITS OWN BY EACH
SEGMENT AND THE BODY TO SOAR
ACCORDING TO DATA AT THIS OFFICE
THE OFFICE WHICH YOU JUST TALKED
ABOUT THE PREVIOUS BILL -- AGAIN
HAVE THE ANALYTICAL CAPACITY OR
GOING TO MAKE THE DATA AVAILABLE
YOU KNOW WHAT'S APPROPRIATE
PRIVACY PROTECTIONS AVAILABLE TO
LET'S SAY RESEARCHERS ACCURACY
CAN DO MORE DEEP DIVES INTO THE
DATA.
AND IF IT'S QUOTE OWNED BY EACH
SEGMENT IS IS ARE WE GOING TO
RUN INTO SOME CHALLENGES WITH
SOMEONE'S GONNA GET PERMISSION
FROM EACH SEGMENT NORTH ACTUALLY
LOOK AT THE COMPILED DATA.
SITES I JUST WANT TO CLARIFY
SOME OF THOSE ISSUES.
THROUGH THROUGH THE CHAIR THANK
YOU SENATOR PAT I THINK THE HOPE
WOULD BE THAT THIS COMMITTEE
THAT'S GOING TO BE CREATED TO TO
DIG DOWN AND AND FIGURE ALL
THESE THINGS OUT WILL
INCORPORATE THE QUESTION IF YOU
JUST RAISED IN THAT.
IN THAT REVIEW AND THAT WOULD BE
MY EXPECTATION GOOD QUESTION AND
DON'T KNOW EXACTLY HOW THE IT'S
ALL GOING TO FIT TOGETHER BUT
THAT'S THEIR ASSIGNMENT IS TO DO
THAT UNDER THE AUSPICES OF THIS
HIGHER EDUCATION OFFICE.
OKAY SIDE EIGHT SO I THINK THAT
THE APPRECIATE THAT -- CERTAINLY
I UNDERSTAND THE ROLE IN TERMS
OWNERSHIP Y EACH SEGMENT -- BUT
OUT SO I'M SURE THAT DOESN'T
BECOME A BARRIER SO I MEAN WE
WANT TO HAVE A POSITIVE
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE SEGMENT TO
SEGMENT SHOULD BE ABLE TO HAVE
ACCESS TO THE DATA TO INFORM
THEIR OWN ACTIVITIES -- SO WHY
BE SURE WE'RE NOT STRUCTURING IT
IN A WAY IN THE ACTUAL BILL THAT
MAKES IT MORE DIFFICULT FOR
PEOPLE TO ACTUALLY ACHIEVE THE
AIMS THAT YOU DESIRE FOR THE
BILL AND I THINK MANY OF US WHO.
WOULD LIKE TO SUPPORT THE BILL
WOULD LIKE TO SEE AS WELL THANK
YOU.
THEY'RE GETTING CENTER PAN ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS VERY
GOOD WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
WELL I I BY HERE YOU AND I Y.
PLOT.
AS WELL AS WE WORK TOGETHER AND
AS BETWEEN THREE LET'S WE WILL
MAKE SURE -- TO TO TO ADDRESS
THAT AYE AYE DEALS WITH THE
CHANCE TO SEE PACK -- THAT THE
GOVERNOR HAD AND SO AM I IT'S
THE POINT VERY WELL TAKEN WILL
WILL WORK WITH YOU TO ADDRESS
THAT ISSUE.
THANK YOU THANK CENTER ALISON
AGREES WITH JUDGE CLOSE WAS A
GREAT CLOSE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PERFECT I LIKE IT I DO HAVE A
MOTION.
MOTION BY SENATOR PAN MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ITEM ONE SB TO THE MOTION IS DO
PASSES AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
LEYVA.
LEYVA AYE WELL HI WILK I CHANGE
CHIANG EITHER WOULD ASAL.
WRESTLE AYE GLAZER GLAZER AYE
MCGUIRE PAN.
PAN I BELIEVE THAT BILL ON CALL
ALRIGHT SIR ALAN IT IS YOUR DATE
YOU THIS IS ONE OF THE IT.
DON'T TRY THIS AT HOME FOLKS BUT
I'M GOING TO I'M GOING TO GO
AHEAD AND PRESENT SB TWO NINETY
SIX MAINLY BECAUSE IT DOES HAVE
A SUPPORT SUPPORT RECOMMENDATION
FROM BOTH CAUCUSES.
I THINK IT'S A VERY WORTHWHILE
BUILD SELECT ALL RIGHT SB TWO
NINETY SIX SENATOR ALLEN PLEASE
PROCEED I THINK THE COMMITTEE
STAFF ONCE AGAIN THIS BILL IN
NAPLES STATUS STUDENTS RESIDING
CALIFORNIA WHO APPLIED FOR
ASYLUM TO BE ELIGIBLE FOR STATE
FUNDED.
FINANCIAL AID THROUGH THE CAL
GRANT PROGRAM WHILE THERE I SENT
A SILENT CASE IS PENDING AS WE
KNOW WE HAVE -- NUMBER OF
IMMIGRANTS COMING INTO THE STATE
WERE FLEEING PERSECUTION THEY
ARE FILING FOR ASYLUM IN CURRENT
INDICATE ESTIMATES INDICATE THAT
THE THAT THERE'S A QUITE ABOUT
WHAT BACKLOG MY DUE TO THE LACK
OF ASYLUM OFFICERS.
NOW -- MANY OF THE SOUNDS OCCURS
IN OUR STATE OUR PERSPECTIVE A
CURRENT COLLEGE STUDENTS WISHING
TO ATTEND THE UNIVERSITY BUT
THEY FACE.
HURDLES BECAUSE OF SIGNIFICANT
COSTS ARE RIGHT NOWTHE FACTS --
IS AVAILABLE FOR STUDENTS SUCH
AS US CITIZENS LEGAL PERMANENT
RESIDENTS THOSE WHO HAVE BEEN
ALREADY GRANTED ASYLUM IN THE U.
S. -- WE AS YOU KNOW HAVE
EXTENDED THE THE RIGHT TO ACCESS
CAL GRANT -- TO TO TO FOLKS
UNDER AB.
FIVE FORTY WHO -- ARE NOT ABLE
TO ACCESS FINANCIALLY THE
FEDERAL LEVEL -- BUT WE GOT THIS
SPECIAL CATEGORY OF PEOPLE WHO
ARE APPLYING FOR ASYLUM -- THEY
HAVE THEIR SOCIAL SECURITY
NUMBER THEY HAVE THEIR
EMPLOYMENT AUTHORIZATION
DOCUMENTS YOU BE WITH YOU DON'T
HAVE THOSE YOU WILL BE ELIGIBLE
UNDER THIS BILL BUT BUT THE YOU
KNOW WE'RE TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
A WAY TO SOLVE FOR THIS.
SMALL PROBLEM BUT IT'S A
SIGNIFICANT PROBLEM FOR THOSE
WHO ARE STUCK IN THIS IN THIS
SITUATION SO -- WITH ME HERE
TODAY WE HAVE ASH A FISHEYE
WHO'S FROM THE CALF YOU SEE
STUDENTS ASSOCIATION TESTIFIED
SUPPORT.
AND I WANT ALSO JUST GIVE A
SPECIAL SHOUT TO MY SENATE
FOLLOW ME NOW -- GUY WHOSE WHOSE --
FROM EGYPT HIMSELF AND AS GOD
DEALT WITH THIS PROBLEM HIMSELF --
AND WITH SOME FOLKS THAT HE
KNOWS AND I'M I WANT TO SIGNAL
AS HIS LEADERSHIP ROLE HELPING
TO BRING THIS ISSUE TO MY
ATTENTION.
THANK CENTER ALLEN WELCOME
GENTLEMEN PLEASE PROCEED.
GOOD MORNING EVERYONE -- VERY
HAPPY TO BE HERE WITH YOU TODAY
TO EXPRESS MY ENTHUSIASTIC
SUPPORT FOR SENATE BILL TWO
NINETY SIX I WANT TO THANK
SENATOR BEN ALLEN FOR INVITING
ME HERE TODAY -- I'M A SENIOR AT
UCLA AND AN ASYLUM SEEKER FROM
EGYPT -- I CAME HERE IN --
TWENTY FOURTEEN ESCAPING SERIOUS
THREATS TO MY FAMILY THAT THEY
HAVE RECEIVED DUE TO WORK
RELATED COMPLICATIONS AND
UNFORTUNATE ANIMOSITY.
AS A STUDENT I HAVE PERSONALLY
LIVES THROUGH TOO MUCH PAIN TO
HAVE NOT TAKEN UP THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO FLY UP HERE FROM
LA. TO SHARE WITH YOU MY
EXPERIENCE ISN'T TO TESTIFY.
YOU SEE I APPLY FOR ASYLUM IN
JULY.
TWENTY FIFTEEN IT'S BEEN ALMOST
FOUR YEARS AND I HAVE YET TO
RECEIVE AN INTERVIEW
NOTIFICATION FOR MY CASE TO BE
ADJUDICATED.
AND THAT HAS LEFT ME WITH NO
FINANCIAL AID THROUGHOUT MY
ENTIRE COLLEGE CAREER.
ESPECIALLY DURING A GREAT A TIME
OF GREAT FINANCIAL STRUGGLE THAT
MY FAMILY HAS BEEN GOING THROUGH.
BECAUSE OF THE HIGH COST OF
TUITION I HAD TO BECOME A PART
TIME STUDENT AND WORKED TWO JOBS
I MEAN SIMULTANEOUSLY SUPPORT
MYSELF.
I SPENT OVER FIVE YEARS INSTEAD
OF FOUR THIRTEEN MY COLLEGE
DEGREE BECAUSE OF MY PART TIME
STATUS.
EVEN THEN I'VE HAD TO MAKE SOME
SEVERE SACRIFICES AS A STUDENT
I'VE HAD TO SKIP MEALS AND RELY
ON OUR CAMPUS FOOD CLOSET.
I'VE COUCH SERVED FOR THREE
MONTHS TO SAVE RENT OF AVOIDED
PURCHASING REQUIRED TEXTBOOKS
FOR SOME OF MY COURSES.
BECAUSE I COULDN'T AFFORD THEM.
AND IN EVERY WAY I HAVE DIMINISH
MY EXPENSES TO THE VERY BARE
MINIMUM NEEDED FOR SURVIVAL. FOR
TOO MANY NIGHTS I'VE GONE TO
SLEEP.
WONDERING HOW WHAT WITH THE NEXT
DAY WOULD HOLD. FOR ON TOO MANY
INSTANCES I'VE WONDERED.
WHETHER PURSUING A COLLEGE
DEGREE WAS WORTH THE PAIN THAT I
WAS CAUSING MY FAMILY.
AND MY EXTENDED FRIENDS.
BY CUT BY MAY HAVE COME THROUGH
THIS PROCESS WITH MY DEGREE BUT
I PERSONALLY KNOW OTHERS IN THE
CSU AND COMMUNITY COLLEGES WHAT
OUGHT TO OUT OF PURSUING HIGHER
EDUCATION. FOR THE SAKE OF
DELAYED INTERVIEWED TIMES FOR
ASYLUM CASE AND FOR THE LACK OF
FINANCIAL AID. TO BE ELIGIBLE
FOR CAL GRANTS WITH INCREDIBLY
HELP US TO STAY ENROLLED IN
COLLEGE TO BE ABLE TO AFFORD
BASIC NEEDS LIKE FOOD AND
HOUSING.
AND TO COME OUT OF THIS PROCESS
EDUCATED READY TO PURSUE A
FULFILLING CAREER.
JUST ONE LAST COMMENT AS ASYLUM
SEEKERS ARE COMMITTED TO STAYING
IN THIS COUNTRY WE'RE COMMITTED
TO GIVING BACK TO THE STATE.
BEING BARRED FROM ATTAINING A
COLLEGE DEGREE HURTS US AND THE
STATE EQUALITY.
TODAY I ASK YOU TO EXERCISE
COMPASSION SOME OF CALIFORNIA'S
MOST VULNERABLE MEMBERS.
YOUR VOTE CAN AND WILL MAKE THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN SOMEONE
GETTING A COLLEGE DEGREE AND
OPTING OUT OF HIGHER EDUCATION.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH BEFORE WE GO
TO OTHER SUPPORT CENTER ALEX AT
THE MOMENT YOU ABSOLUTELY
SEPARATE OKAY VERY GOOD OTHERS
IN SUPPORT.
PLEASE COME TO THE MICROPHONE.
NAME ORGANIZATION AND YOUR
SUPPORT.
A GOOD MORNING I MANY BE IS
REPRESENTS SAN JOSE EVERGREEN Q.
COMMITTEE BECAUSE THIS IS VERY
MUCH IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING ALEX GRAZE THE
ASSOCIATION INDEPENDENT
CALIFORNIA COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING A UC DAVIS IN
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT ALSO ON
A PERSONAL NOTE I AM ALSO A
FAIRLY SO THANK YOU SENATOR
ALLEN FOR THIS BILL.
A TINY SEARCH ENOUGH FROM THE
CALIFORNIA STUDENT AID
COMMISSION ALSO IN SUPPORT ALSO
ON A PERSONAL NOTE FORMER
ASSEMBLY SPEAKER SO I APPRECIATE
IT.
MORE SECONDS ALSO ON BEHALF OF
THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS IN STRONG SUPPORT.
MAY WASHINGTON CAL STATE STUDENT
ASSOCIATION -- AND WE HAVE A
SUPPORT CONCEPT.
MARIO GUERRERO ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT.
GOOD START MORNING PUSH ON TO
YOU SEE SINICIZATION WHEN
STRIKES.
THANK YOU ANY ONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING AND HEARING THEM BREAK
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ANY
QUESTIONS COMMENTS CONCERNS
CENTER DRAWS SO.
THANK YOU SENATOR ALAN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR -- I'M
SURE YOU WILL BE SURPRISED BY MY
ENTHUSIASTIC VERY STRONG SUPPORT --
AND I WANT TO THANK THE
GENTLEMAN FOR YOUR SHARING YOUR
TESTIMONY -- IT'S NEVER TOO MUCH
TO HEAR WHAT.
PEOPLE GO THROUGH.
US TO GET. TO THEIR DREAMS AND
WE HAVE TO BE REMINDED OF A EVEN
IF UP HERE WE REMAIN COMMITTED
ITSELF THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- I
ALSO THINK A EVEN.
I DIDN'T HAVE THE ISSUES OF NOT
BEING OF ELIGIBLE FOR LOANS BUT
I NEVER WOULD HAVE MADE IT
THROUGH COLLEGE WITHOUT A
COMBINATION OF WORKING.
AND GRANTS AND SCHOLARSHIPS AND
LOANS -- SO I KNOW EXACTLY IT'S
GOT TO BE THE COMBINATION OF
THAT PACKAGE AND I'M SURE A LOT
OF PEOPLE OF OF GONE THROUGHTHAT SO.
I'M REALLY GRATEFUL THAT YOU
BROUGHT THIS UP SO WE COULD
CLEAN THAT UP -- IN TERMS OF ALL
OF OURS A CALIFORNIA STUDENTS
BEING ABLE TO GET THEIR
EDUCATION -- DORADO ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS COMMENTS CONCERNS VERY
GOOD SEVERAL MEASURES CLOSE IF
YOU THINK YOU MEMBERS AND SENATE
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS WE
WOULD WELCOME YOUR
CONSIDERATIONS A CO AUTHOR OF
THE BILL.
I REALLY DO WHAT'S AGAIN I GIVE
A SPECIAL SHOUT OUTS IT TO MEAN
AND AND OTHER WONDERFUL SENATE
FOLLOWS TO BRING SUCH.
GREAT NEW IDEAS AND FRESH ENERGY
TO OUR INSTITUTION EVERY SINGLE
YEAR AND WHAT -- WITHOUT RESPECT
YESTERDAY ABOUT THANK YOU CENTER
ALLEN I THINK SENATOR WILKIE
MADE A MOTION TO MOVE THE BILL.
THANK YOU VERY GOOD MA'AM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ITEM FIVE SB TWO NINETY SIX THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS LEYVA.
LEYVA I WILL HI WILK AYE CHIANG
CHIANG I'D RUSSELL.
WRESTLE AYE GLAZER.
A MCGUIRE PAN.
CAN I WE BELIEVE THAT BILL ON
CALL I SAW A LITTLE HORSE
TRADING GOING ON DOWN IN THE
AUDIENCE I THINK SENATOR RUBIO
YOU ARE UP NEXT.
SEC CORRECT OKAY VERY GOOD WE
ARE GOING TO MOVE TO FILE ITEM
TEN SP FOUR FORTY THREE SENATOR
RUBIO PLEASE PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE
READY THANK YOU FIRST WANT TO
THANK MY COLLEAGUES FOR ALLOWING
ME TO IT TO GO BEFORE THEM SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AS A FORMER EDUCATOR
TODAY I AM PROUD TO PRESENT SB
FOUR FORTY THREE AN IMPORTANT
BILL THAT WILL EXPAND FUNDING TO
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN.
STUDENTS TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN WAS ESTABLISHED IN
TWENTY THIRTEEN AT THE WAITED
SERVE CHILDREN WHO WERE
OTHERWISE LEFT OUT OF THE SCHOOL.
WHEN THE ENTRY AGE FOR
KINDERGARTEN WAS CHANGED UNLIKE
OTHER PRE KINDERGARTEN PROGRAMS
THAT ARE AVAILABLE TIKI PROGRAMS
REQUIRE FULLY CREDENTIALED
CERTIFIED TEACHERS WHO HAVE
BACHELOR'S DEGREES?
STUDENTS ANTI K. ALSO BENEFIT
FROM AN EMPHASIS ON SOCIAL LIFE
STATION MENTAL MENTAL HEALTH
SKILLS AND PRINT ISSUES THAT ARE
ABSENT FROM OTHER PROGRAMS.
RESEARCH SHOWS THAT TAKING HAS A
POSITIVE ACADEMIC OUTCOMES. FOR
STUDENTS WHO PARTICIPATE TAKE IT
HAS ALSO BEEN PROVEN EFFECTIVE
FOR ALL STUDENTS WHO PARTICIPATE
WITH EVEN GREATER IMPACT.
ON LANGUAGE SKILLS FOR
INTERESTING WHICH LEARNERS AND
MATHEMATICAL SKILLS FOR LOW
INCOME STUDENTS.
THE STATE PROVIDES FUNDING FOR
T. CASE STUDENTS WHO ARE BORN
BETWEEN SEPTEMBER SECOND
DECEMBER SECOND JUST AS THE THEY
DO FOR KINDERGARTEN.
HOWEVER STUDENTS ANTI CARE ARE
ALSO I'M SORRY HOWEVER STUDENTS
TO TAKE A WHO ARE BORN DECEMBER
THIRD OR LATER ONLY GENERATE
FUNDING AFTER THE FIFTH BIRTHDAY.
WHILE SOME SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE
ABLE TO BACK FILL THE FUNDING
SHORTFALLS BUT THERE GENERAL
FUND THIS IS NOT REALISTIC FOR
ALL SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
THIS HAS CREATED A FUNDING
SHORTFALL ONCE AGAIN AND DESCENT
OF ISIS SCHOOL DISTRICTS FROM
AND FROM THE STUDENTS WHO HAVE
THEIR FIFTH BIRTHDAY.
IN THE LATER PART OF THE SCHOOL
YEAR SB FOUR FORTY THREE WOULD
ALLOW BUT NOT MANDATE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO EXPAND THEIR T. K.
PROGRAM.
THIS BILL WILL PROVIDE FUNDING
FOR STUDENTS WERE ENROLLED IN
TKD AND HAVE THEIR FIFTH
BIRTHDAY ONCE AGAIN AFTER
DECEMBER SECOND CUT OFF BY
ALLOWING SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO
COLLECT AVERAGE DAILY ATTENDANCE.
FOR STUDENTS WHO TURN FIVE AFTER
DECEMBER SECOND TICKET WOULD
EXPAND IN AREAS ARE NOT ABLE TO
AFFORD THIS RICH INSTRUCTIONAL
PROGRAM MADAM CHAIR.
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
TODAY I WOULD LIKE TO INTRODUCE
TWO WITNESSES WHO WOULD LIKE TO
OFFER THEIR TESTIMONY ON THIS
IMPORTANT ISSUE.
KAREN MAN SHIP PRINCIPAL
RESEARCHER AT THE AMERICAN
INSTITUTE FOR RESEARCH AND
DOCTOR CHARLES HIM MEN FROM WITH
CAMINO UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
THANK YOU.
BECAUSE AND A RUBIO PLEASE
PROCEDURE WHICH HAVE TWO MINUTES.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME'S CHUCK
CAM AND I'M IN MY FIFTH YEAR OF
SUPERINTENDENT THE WEST UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT -- I ASK FOR
YOUR UNDERSTANDING A LITTLE
UNDER THE WEATHER SO.
IF YOU'LL BEAR WITH ME ON THAT --
APPROXIMATELY FOUR YEARS AGO WE
HAD A NEIGHBORING SCHOOL
DISTRICT THAT WAS UNABLE TO
CONTINUE THEIR DAY CARE PROGRAM
IN OUR SCHOOL BOARD WANTED TO
OFFER UP.
OUR TIKI PROGRAM IS A SOLUTION
FOR SOME OF OUR COMMUNITY
MEMBERS.
SO THEY DECIDED HIM I WILL TAKE
THE TIME OUR BUDGET WAS WAS
HEALTHY FOR A SCHOOL DISTRICT SO
WE DECIDED TO ALLOW ALL COMERS.
WHO TURN FIVE IN THE PREVIOUS
SCHOOL YEAR TO COME INTO OUR T.
K.?
BUT WE DIDN'T REALIZE IS THAT
OUR T. K. WOULD GROW BY 60%.
SO WE TOOK AN ADDITIONAL 60% OF
STUDENTS AND THAT DIDN'T QUALIFY
FOR THE FULL YEAR FUNDING
OBVIOUSLY THIS BECAME A BURDEN
ON OUR SCHOOL DISTRICT WE WERE
ABLE TO CARRY IT FOR THREE YEARS.
GENTLY WE'VE HAD TO NOW BILL THE
WAITING LIST FOR THE FOLLOWING
YEAR WE WE CAN NO LONGER
SUPPLANT -- THAT THE YOUNGER
STUDENTS NOW IN OUR MIND.
I WILL TELL YOU I'VE I'VE SHARED
THE STORY WITH SUPERINTENDENTS
ACROSS THE STATE I THINK WE'RE
ALL ON THIS PRETTY MUCH ON THE
SAME FIELD.
IT DOESN'T MAKE SENSE TO US THAT
YOU HAVE HALF OF THE CLASS OF
STUDENTS.
IT'S GOING INTO KINDERGARTEN THE
FOLLOWING YEAR THAT'S ALLOWED TO
HAVE T. K. AND THE PREP WORK
GOING INTO KINDERGARTEN.
YET WE'RE DENYING THE OTHER HALF
OF THAT CLASS THIS GOING INTO
THE SAME CLASSROOM THE FOLLOWING
YEAR BUT IS THE NINETY K..
BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE THE
FUNDING FOR OUR OUR LIMITED
FUNDING -- I'M SURE YOU'RE GONNA
HEAR SOME RESULTS VERY SHORTLY
THE T. K. PROGRAM IS OF A
QUALITY PROGRAM IS CREDENTIALED
TEACHERS IT HAS A BASED
CURRICULUM.
I CAN TAKE FROM PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE -- OUR PARENTS OUR
COMMUNITY ARE THRILLED TO HAVE
THAT OPPORTUNITY AND I HOPE IN
THE FUTURE I WON'T HAVE TO BUILD
THAT WAITING LIST BECAUSE IT'S
IT'S VERY DESTRUCTIVE TO OUR
COMMUNITY -- I TAKE OUT THE LAST
SINGLE I WILL CLOSE WITH IS THE
OLD ADAGE NO AND I I UNDERSTAND.
HOW THIS HOW IT WORKED WITH THE
MARIN BOARD OUR OWN BUDGETS?
THERE'S AN OLD ADAGE BY
SUPERINTENDENTS AND SAY YOU KNOW
SCHOOL BOARD CAN DO ANYTHING
THEY WANT.
THEY JUST CAN'T DO EVERYTHING SO
I CAN SEE THAT TO THE COMMITTEE
I REALIZE THAT THERE ARE
CHALLENGING ENTITIES FOR FOR
FUNDING.
BUT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT -- AN
EFFECTIVE PROGRAM -- THAT SHOWS
SIGNIFICANT RESULTS IN SHOULD BE
OPEN TO THE ENTIRE CLASS OF FIVE
YEAR OLDS GOING INTO
KINDERGARTEN RATHER THAN JUST
HALF THANK YOU VERY GOOD THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS.
A GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS KAREN MENTIONED I'M A
PRINCIPAL RESEARCHER AT AMERICAN
INSTITUTES FOR RESEARCH.
WITH OUR A. I. R. TEAM I LET THE
STATEWIDE STUDY OF TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN FROM 200-014-32000.
SIXTEEN AND I'D LIKE TO SHARE
SOME OF WHAT WE FOUND TO INFORM
YOUR CONSIDERATION OF THIS FALL.
THE STUDY COMPARED OUTCOMES IN
KINDERGARTEN FOR KIDS YOUR AGE
ELIGIBLE FOR KINDERGARTEN SO
THOSE BORN BEFORE DECEMBER
SECOND. TWO KIDS WHO WERE
SIMILAR IN AGE BUT JUST MISSED
THE AGE CUTOFF FOR TKA MOST OF
WHOM ATTENDED ANOTHER CENTER
BASED BECAME PROGRAM.
THIS IS A VERY RIGOROUS DESIGN
FOR STUDY AND INCLUDED OVER SIX
THOUSAND STUDENTS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE.
WE FOUND UNDERSTANDING T. K.
GIVE STUDENTS A THREE MONTH
LEARNING ADVANTAGE OVER THEIR
NANTI K. PEERS AND MATH SKILLS A
KINDERGARTEN ENTRY.
T. K. ALSO SHOULDN'T IMPACT ON
STUDENTS LITERACY SKILLS PUTTING
THEM AHEAD OF THEIR NANTI K.
PAIRS BY SIX MONTHS I CAN -- AN
ENTRY AND SHOWING A PERSISTING
IN FACT AT THE END OF THE YEAR.
A RECENT STUDY BY CHRISTOS AT
RAND COMPARING THE TWO K.
PROGRAMS OTHER PRESCHOOL
PROGRAMS AND SAN FRANCISCO
UNIFIED.
CAME TO SIMILAR CONCLUSIONS.
WE ALSO FOUND THAT THERE IS NO
DIFFERENCE AND CHILDREN SOCIAL
SKILLS AS RATING RATED BY
TEACHERS BETWEEN TWO K. IN
COMPARISON CREEK STUDENTS. TWO
K. HAS A PARTICULARLY STRONG
IMPACT TO SENATOR MENTIONED ON
SOME STUDENTS TO MAKE UP A
REALLY LARGE PORTION OF OUR
STUDENT BODY IN CALIFORNIA.
WE SAW VERY POSITIVE EFFECTS ON
ENGLISH LANGUAGE SKILLS FOR
ENGLISH LEARNERS AND ALSO ON
MATH SKILLS FOR LOW INCOME
STUDENTS. ONE OF THE INTERESTING
THINGS THAT WE NOTED IN THE
STUDY WAS THAT VARIATIONS IN THE
SPECIFIC ELEMENTS CITY KAY.
SO SMALL CHANGES IN TEACHER
CHILD RATIOS CLASSROOM
OBSERVATION RATINGS FOR USE OF
PARTICULAR INSTRUCTIONAL
STRATEGIES SUCH A SMALL GROUPS
DID NOT CHANGE THE IMPACT THAT
T QUê HAD FOR STUDENTS.
SO WE THINK THIS MAY BE BECAUSE
THE ELEMENTS THAT TICKET
CLASSROOMS ALL HAVE IN COMMON.
FOR EXAMPLE LOCATION AND
ELEMENTARY SCHOOLS THAT MAY
FACILITATE TRANSITIONS AND
KINDERGARTEN -- CERTIFICATED AND
WELL EDUCATED TEACHERS THE
MAJORITY OF HIM TAUGHT
KINDERGARTEN BEFORE.
AND ALSO NINE MEANS TESTED
CLASSROOMS WHERE CHILDREN OF ALL
INCOME LEVELS CAN ATTEND
TOGETHER.
MAYBE THE MAIN DRIVERS OF THE
PROGRAM'S IMPACT.
THE STUDY FOCUSED ON CHILDREN IN
THE CURRENT T. K. H. WINDOW NOT
YOUNGER CHILDREN SUCH AS THIS
RESURGENT ET QUEPROGRAMS.
BUT BECAUSE WE SEE STRONG AND
CONSISTENT IMPACTS OF T. K. FOR
CHILDREN WITH THESE WHEN OUR
BIRTHDAYS WE BELIEVE THAT THE
SUGGESTS THAT DEVELOPMENTALLY
APPROPRIATE AND RESPONSIVE ET
QUE PROGRAMS.
MAY ALSO HAVE A POSITIVE IMPACT
FOR YOUNGER CHILDREN AS WELL
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
JEFF AKA REPRESENTING THE
RIVERSIDE COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT
OF SCHOOLS AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
IN THE GARAGE WITH THE LOS
ANGELES UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
RON RAP ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS AND SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING JENNIFER BAKER WITH
THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
YES CENTER CHIANG.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIRWOMAN FIRST
OFF I WANT TO THANK SENATOR
RUBIO FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP ON
THIS.
I'VE ACTUALLY PREVIOUSLY ASKED
TO BE A CO AUTHOR AND HOPEFULLY
I CAN BE ADDED ON IN THE VERY
NEAR FUTURE -- I'VE TALKED TO A
QUITE A FEW PEOPLE ABOUT
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN AND IT.
IS INCREDIBLY BENEFICIAL -- FOR
FOR CLOSING THE ACHIEVEMENT GAP
AT A YOUNG AGE SO AGAIN I WANT
TO COMMEND.
YOU ON THIS BILL AND AND THANK
YOU SO MUCH.
THE SENATE CHIANG CENTER PAN.
I THANK YOU AND AND AT FIRST OF
ALL -- SIR RUBIO I'D APPRECIATE --
THAT -- YEAH YEARS -- THAT WHAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO DO IN TERMS OF
GETTING MORE -- FUNDING AND
SUPPORT FOR SCHOOL DISTRICTS --
FOR TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN I
GUESS THAT THE DID HAVE A
QUESTION -- WELL WE DON'T HAVE
SOMEONE COMING UP TO TESTIFY.
I KNOW THAT THERE'S SOME CONCERN
IN THE CHILD CARE COMMUNITY --
ABOUT THIS AND I CAN JUST SPEAK
PERHAPS.
TO CONVERSATIONS WITH THE CHILD
CARE COMMUNITY ABOUT.
BASICALLY I THINK THE CONCERN IS
THAT WE'RE MOVING TO QUE TO
YOUNGER YOUNGER AGES AND AND
DOES A PEDIATRICIAN AND I KNOW
YEARS AS A TEACHER YOU'D
UNDERSTAND THAT -- CHILDREN --
DEVELOPMENTAL CURVE RIGHT SO --
THE THE FOCUS OF THEIR
EXPERIENCE -- NATION SHIFT
DEPENDING ON WHAT AGE SO WE KNOW
HIGH QUALITY PRESCHOOL -- SHE
CERTAINLY HAS VERY STRONG
RESULTS -- AND SO FORTH -- BUY
ONE BE SURE TO AS WERE YOU KNOW
THIS INTERFACE BETWEEN -- SO
EARLY CHILDHOOD DEVELOPMENT AND
CHILD CARE AND THE AND NTK IS
SOMETHING THAT -- WE WILL BE
SURE WE'RE WE'RE TRYING TO GET
RIGHT SO I MUST THAT WE SUPPORT
WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO DO IN
TERMS OF FEATURES SCHOOL
DISTRICTS GET MORE MONEY. TO
HELP SUPPORT THIRTY K. PROGRAM
BUT ALSO -- JUST ONE TOUCH ON
THE SET THE INTERFACE AND
INTERACTION BETWEEN EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATION AND TJ.
SO CAN YOU SEE PERHAPS THAT CAN
YOU ADDRESS ANY CONVERSATIONS
YOU HAD ABOUT THAT.
THANK YOU DOCTOR PAN FOR YOUR
QUESTION AND WE DO HAVE
INFORMATION ABOUT THAT I'M GOING
TO DEFER TRY EXPERTS HERE TO
DISCUSS.
THEIR INTERACTION EFFECTS ON
DEVELOPMENTALLY READY CHILDREN.
PLEASE.
THANK YOU SENATOR -- I I'M JUST
A REFER BACK TO MY QUICK COMMENT
WHICH IS I AGREE WITH YOU ABOUT
DEVELOPMENTAL AGE AGES.
BUT I ALSO WANT TO REMIND THAT
THAT COHORT.
OF KINDERGARTNERS IT'S ALL GOING
TOGETHER SO YOU'RE WE ARE
SEPARATED HALF INTO A DIFFERENT
PROGRAMMERS THE TICKET AND WE
BELIEVE THE TICKET FOR STRONG
BUT I'M GONNA ASK ATTORNEYS CAN
IT'S A NEW OVERSEAS OUR TICKET
PROGRAM IN THE WEST UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT.
JUST TO BRIEFLY DISCUSS WHAT
TRAINING THE TICKET TEACHERS
HAVE TO HELP FACILITATE THAT
QUESTION.
PLEASE PROCEED THANK YOU SENATOR --
THAT'S A GOOD QUESTION -- I AND
I KNOW THAT THAT.
YOU'RE AWARE THAT ARE A T.
TEACHERS ARE REQUIRED TO HAVE
TWENTY FOUR UNITS OF EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATION.
AND WE DO USE THE PRESCHOOL --
CALIFORNIA FRAMEWORK A THEY ARE
TRAINED IN THAT AS WELL AS I DO
THE MANY MANY DEVELOPMENTAL --
ASPECTS OF THE PROGRAM.
SO THE READER -- DOESN'T REALLY
COME INTO MUCH LATER WHEN YOU
WALK INTO OUR T. K. CLASSROOMS
THEY LOOK VERY MUCH PLAY BASED
AND DEVELOPMENTAL.
A VERY DIFFERENT FROM WHAT MANY
OF OUR EVEN OUR KINDERGARTEN
CLASSROOMS LOOK LIKE.
AND AND AND JUST WANTED TO BE
CLEAR THAT -- I MEAN I
UNDERSTAND THAT THE TEACHERS ARE
INVOLVED IN TJ -- DO A
PARTICULAR FOCUS ON THESE ISSUES
SO THAT'S NOT SO MUCH THE DIRECT
CONCERN I THINK WE'RE LOOKING AT
HOW THIS INTERFACE HAPPENS.
AND SO THAT'S WHY I WANT TO BE
SURE THAT WE'RE HAVING
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATORS THE CHILD
CARE FOLKS ABOUT EXACTLY.
HOW WE'RE?
PUTTING THESE PIECES TOGETHER
AND RECOGNIZING THAT -- ACTUALLY
OFTENTIMES MANY OF THE STUDENTS
THAT -- YOU -- WORK WITH -- YOU
KNOW THIS IS THIS IS THE BEST
pSHOWS AND SO FORTH AND YOU'RE
NOT GETTING FUNDED FOR IT SO A
SO WE WON'T BE SURE THAT SCHOOL
DISTRICTS GET SUPPORT -- SAME
TIME -- IN THE IT OUT TO YOU
THAT -- IN SOME OF THE OTHER
ROLES I'VE HAD NO WE'VE HAD
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT WATER
STANDARDS FOR LIKE PHYSICAL
FACILITIES THAT WERE REQUIRING
AND ENTER AND AND AND
DIFFERENCES BETWEEN THAT WE'VE
HAD THE ELECTRICITY WE SAID
ABOUT EDUCATION.
SO JUST.
WANNA BE SURE THAT THAT
CONVERSATION IS HAPPENING IS
THIS BILLS ROLLING FORWARD
BECAUSE IT.
STILL -- A SUPPORT INTEND TO THE
BILL AND BUT I ALSO THINK THAT
THERE'S A CONVERSATION THAT.
NEEDS TO HAPPEN IN RELATION TO
BE SURE THIS BILL SUCCESSFUL
THAT I'M NOT QUITE.
SURE ABOUT YET SO IF YOU SEE ALL
OF YOU BEING HERE AND YOUR TO
REPRESENT THE ONE SIDE BUT I'M
NOT HEARING THE SOME HEARING
FROM SOME FOLKS IN THE ON THAT
IT WAS THE OTHER SITES ONLY.
KNOWS THE FIGHTS BUT THAT.
HOW THAT COMES TOGETHER SO I
THINK IS THE BILL RULES FOR A
THINK FOR TO BE WITH I'D LIKE TO
SEE THAT THAT TO TO SEE TO BE
SURE THAT CONVERSATIONS TO
TAKING PLACE NOW THEY'RE NOT
COMING TO THE TABLE THAT'S A
WHOLE NOTHER STORY BUT I MEAN
AND? ONE BE SURE THAT THAT DID
THAT SOME OF THESE ISSUES ARE.
ARE WORKED OUT AS A MISS FORD.
THANK YOU DOCTOR PAN AND I
COMPLETELY UNDERSTAND YOUR
CONCERN AND I YOU KNOW I
APPRECIATE YOU MAKING THOSE
COMMENTS.
BOB AND I WILL CONTINUE TO HAVE
CONVERSATIONS IT'S NOT LIKE WE
WANT TO LEAVE ANYBODY OUT OF THE
CAR AND AND AND AND I WANT TO
SAY THAT AND I KNOW THAT I I
HAVE A LOT OF FAITH IN YOU THAT
YOU WILL HAVE THIS CONVERSATION.
THANK YOU AND AND I CAN JUST
TELL YOU FROM PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE BEING IN THE
KINDERGARTEN CLASSROOM MYSELF AT
ONE POINT ASSISTANT PRINCIPAL AT
ANOTHER POINT.
JUST UNDERSTANDING THAT AT LEAST
IN OUR AREAS I COME FROM ALL
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT AS WELL.
A LOT OF PARENTS JUST DON'T TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THE EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION PROGRAMS THEY JUST
WILL NOT SEND IN A SCHOOL AND I
CAN TELL YOU WITH CERTAINTY THAT
I IS A TEACHER SAW THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE STUDENTS
THAT WARRANTY QUE.
VERSUS THE ONES THAT JUST
STARTED UP IN CANDOR SO BUT I
WILL DEFINITELY CONTINUE TO HAVE
THOSE CONVERSATIONS BUT THANK
YOU FOR YOUR CONCERN.
YOU SENATOR RUBIO WOULD YOU LIKE
THAT TO BE YOUR CLOTHES OR WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE AND THANK YOU.
THANK YOU TO THE PANEL. FOR
COMING OUT HERE TODAY AND THANK
YOU TO THE MEMBERS FOR HEAR ME
TODAY -- BUT JUST WANT TO CLOSE
WITH THE EXPAND ET QUE WILL HELP
ELIMINATE THE ACHIEVEMENT GAP IS
FASHION ARE LOWER INCOME
COMMUNITIES SB FOUR FORTY THREE
WOULD ENSURE THAT ALL STUDENTS
REGARDLESS OF THEIR BIRTHDAY
WILL BE TREATED EQUALLY FOR
PURPOSES OF FUNDING. FOR THESE
REASONS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR RIFLE THANK YOU THANK YOU
SENATOR RUBIO TO HAVE A MOTION.
SO MOVED BY SENATOR DRAWS --
MA'AM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ITEM TEN SB FOUR FOUR THREE
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS LEYVA.
AYE LEYVA AYE WILK.
CHEN THANK CHIANG I'M TO WRESTLE
GRESHAM AYE GLAZER.
MCGUIRE PAN.
CAN I BELIEVE THAT BELONG CALL
CALL CENTER RUBIO [inaudible]
CENTER SKINNER.
PLEASE JOIN US YOU'VE BEEN VERY
PATIENT.
WE'RE GOING TO HEAR SB.
TWO ZERO SIX PROCEED WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR ALSO HAVE
MY CO AUTHOR SENATOR BRADFORD.
WHO CENTER BRED FOR IF YOU WANNA
IT WHICHEVER TO WOULD BE AT THE
TABLE OR THE PODIUM IT'S UP TO
YOU [inaudible]
OKAY YEAH -- THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR COMMITTEE MEMBERS VERY
HAPPY TO BE PRESENTING SB TWO
ZERO SIX TO YOU TODAY AS WE WRAP
UP OR FACE THE LAST WEEK IN
MARCH MADNESS -- FIRST I WANT TO
START WITH I'M ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS ON HAD A
REQUIRING THAT THE AGENTS BE
LICENSED AND THAT THEY ABIDE BY
ETHICAL STANDARDS.
BUT IN LIEU OF AMENDMENT HEY
WHAT WE WILL DO IS REMOVE THE
REFERENCE TO THE COMPENSATION
CAP THE BILL THANK YOU.
AND THEN OUT TO PROCEED -- MANY
OF US MAY NOT REALIZE BUT
COLLEGE ATHLETES STRUGGLE TO
MAKE ENDS MEET.
IN THE SAME WAY THAT MOST
COLLEGE STUDENTS DO TODAY -- BUT
UNLIKE OTHER STUDENTS COLLEGE
ATHLETES OR DVI ONLY COLLEGE
ATHLETES THAT PARTICIPATE IN NC
TO A SPORTS ARE THE ONLY
CATEGORY OF STUDENTS THAT ARE
COMPLETELY BARRED FROM MAKING
ANY MONEY FROM THEIR TALENT.
SO FINE MUSIC STUDENT.
I CAN STILL GET EARNINGS FOR
PERFORMANCE IF I'M SO FORTUNATE
TO HAVE THAT ABILITY OR THAT
TALENT.
IF I'M A COMPUTER SCIENCE
STUDENT I DEVELOP AN APP I CAN
MARKET IT MAKE MONEY OFF OF IT.
I FIND THE DEBATE TEAM STUDENT
AND I'M SO FORTUNATE TO BE
ENTREPRENEURIAL ENOUGH TO GET --
TO ALLOW MYSELF TO GET PAID FOR
SPEAKING GIGS I CAN DO THAT.
AND YET I CAN ALSO COMPETE.
IN INTER COLUSA INTERCOLLEGIATE
ACTIVITIES RELATED TO THAT TOWN
I HAVE.
ONLY COLLEGE INCOME IS COLLEGE
ATHLETES ARE PROHIBITED AND THEY
ARE PROHIBITED BY AN ENTITY THAT
EARNED IN.
TWENTY SEVENTEEN OVER ONE POINT
ONE BILLION. FOR ITS
RELATIONSHIP TO COLLEGE ATHLETES
SO THE VERY TALENT THAT THE NC
TWO EIGHT AND OTHERS MAKE
BILLIONS OFF IS PROHIBITED FROM
EARNING ANY INCOME THEMSELVES.
WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS IT DOES
NOT REQUIRE?
OUR COLLEGES TO HIRE THE
ATHLETES ARE GIVEN THEM -- HEY
RATHER IT PUTS OUR COLLEGE
ATHLETES ON THE SAME LEVEL AS
OLYMPIC ATHLETES ARE ALLOWED
WHICH IS THAT THEY CAN PURSUE
SPONSORSHIPS ARE ENDORSEMENTS OR
GET AN AGENT -- IN WITHOUT A ONE
ALLOW MY WITNESSES TO SPEAK AND
THEN I CAN GIVE YOU MORE DETAILS
IN MY CLOSER IN QUESTIONS.
WHEN MY INNER AND PERHAPS ARMS
SENATOR BRADFORD BEFORE THE
WITNESSES HE MIGHT ADD AND THEN
WE'LL HAVE TO WITNESSES?
UNDER BRADFORD PLEASE PROCEED
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
AND ALSO WANT TO THANK SENATOR
SKINNER FOR HER LEADERSHIP ON
THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE.
I'M PROUD TO BE A CO AUTHOR OF
THE FAIR PAY.
PAY AND PLAYBACK WHICH IS MORE
THAN ABOUT SPORTS IT'S A CIVIL
RIGHTS ISSUE -- AND IT'S ISSUED
JUST BASIC FAIRNESS FOR DECADES
YOUNG ATHLETES HAVE BEEN
GENERATING BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
FOR COLLEGES UNIVERSITIES IN
CORPORATE SPONSORED BUT MANY.
ARE NOT ONLY IN DURING THE DAILY
CHALLENGES OF COLLEGIATE.
A COLLEGIATE ATHLETES THEY ARE
ARE STRUGGLING JUST TO GET DID
BY FINANCIALLY IT'S A TIME TO
WRITE THIS HISTORIC WRONG.
STUDENT ATHLETES OF COLOR
SUFFERED DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACT
OF THESE COMPENSATION
RESTRICTIONS AND OFTEN SUFFER
THE LOWEST GRADUATION RATES
BLACKMAIL COLLEGIATE.
ATHLETES MADE UP ONLY TWO POINT
4% OF UNDERGRADUATE STUDENTS
ROAD ACROSS THE SIXTY FIVE
INSTITUTIONS THAT COMPRISE THE
POWER.
FIVE BUT THEY COMPRISE OVER 50%
OF THE BASKETBALL AND FOOTBALL
TEAMS. FOR HEAVILY FINANCIAL
GAIN.
INSTITUTIONS ARE HIGHLY
PRIORITIZED SPORTS ARE MAKING A
GREAT EFFORT TO RECRUIT BLACK
MALE COLLEGIATE ATHLETES BUT ARE
NOT PROVIDING THEM WITH THE
SPORT I MEAN SUPPORT SORRY.
ONCE THE INTER COLLEGE OR EVEN
AFTER THEY LEAVE COLLEGE THEY
NEED BOTH FINANCIAL AND ACADEMIC
ASSISTANCE.
YOU HAVE WORKERS GENERATING
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS BUT BEING
DENIED THE OPPORTUNITY TO
RECEIVE JUST COMPENSATION.
AND AGAIN STUDENT ATHLETES ARE
ONLY GROUP OF STUDENTS WITH
RESTRICTIONS.
ON WHAT THEY'RE ABLE TO EARNED
BY USING THEIR TALENTS -- FOR
THIS IS NOT A EQUITABLE NOR FAIR
SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE.
HE SAID THE BRADFORD WITNESSES
OF IN SUPPORT YOU BOTH HAVE TWO
MINUTES.
GOOD MORNING AND THANK YOU FOR
HAVING ME HERE TODAY MY NAME IS
HALEY HANSSON AND I IN THE
FORMER STANFORD VOLLEYBALL
PLAYER I'M CURRENTLY STILL
ENROLLED AT STANFORD UNIVERSITY.
I HAD TO MEDICALLY RETIRED DUE
TO BRAIN INJURY -- BECAUSE TO
DURING MY TIME AS AN ATHLETE
THERE I A COMING OUT OF HIGH
SCHOOL I WAS A TOP BRING TO
CREATE IN THE NATION AND A
PLAYER ON THE USA WOMEN'S
NATIONAL TEAM.
I WENT ON TO EARN AMERICA ALL
AMERICAN THE NATIONAL FRESH FOR
THE OF THE YEAR HONORS DURING MY
FIRST YEAR AT STANFORD AND PLAN
TO GRADUATE EARLY IN ORDER TO
PURSUE A PROFESSIONAL VOLLEYBALL
CAREER OVERSEAS.
HOWEVER THAT CREER WAS CUT
SHORT BEFORE IT EVEN STARTED --
AT AGE TWENTY I HAD DOES BEGIN
TO THINK ABOUT WHAT TYPE OF
BRAIN INJURY ISSUES AND MEDICAL
EXPENSES ARE IN MY FUTURE AND
LOST MY ABILITY TO MONETIZE THE
FUTURE CAREER I HAD ONCE HOPED
OF HOPPING.
UNLIKE MOST COLLEGIATE ATHLETES
MY FAMILY HAS SPENT MANY MANY
MANY MANY MANY HOURS -- AND
DEDICATED TIME AND FINANCES OVER
THE YEARS IN ORDER TO HELP ME
PROGRESS BOTH AS A STUDENT AND
AN ATHLETE -- BUT NOW BUT IS
OVER IT IS CLEAR THAT EVEN BEING
ONE OF THE TOP PLAYERS IN A
SPORT WITH PROFESSIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES DOES NOT GUARANTEE
THAT THOSE INVESTMENT OF TIME
AND MONEY WILL PAY OFF.
MORE THAN 50% OF DIVISION ONE
COLLEGE ATHLETES SUFFER CHRONIC
COLLEGE SPORTS INJURIES THAT
WILL PLAY THEM FOR THE REST OF
THEIR LIVES.
THE TRADE OFF FOR PURSUIT OF
HIGHER EDUCATION IS ENORMOUS YET
WE'RE DEPRIVE BASIC RIGHTS AT
THIS MOMENT I HAVE TEAMMATES AND
FRIENDS ALL OVER THE WORLD -- I
ALL OVER AMERICA WHO COULD
BENEFIT FROM SB TWO OH SIX ON BY
GAINING THE RIGHT TO
SPONSORSHIPS ENDORSEMENTS AND
EVEN FUNDRAISING AND I WOULD
LIKE TO MENTION THAT THIS IS
SOMETHING IN PARTICULAR THAT
FEMALE ATHLETES WOULD BE ABLE TO
BENEFIT FROM WHERE WE HAVE FEWER
PROFESSIONAL OPPORTUNITIES ON
THE OTHER.
END AND HAVE A SMALL WINDOW OF
TIME WHERE WE ARE PHYSICALLY --
OUT OUR PRIME AND CAN MAKE MONEY
IN EVEN SMALL WAYS -- THROUGH
ENDORSEMENTS -- MANY ATHLETES OF
MANY OF MY PEERS FRIENDS I DON'T
HAVE THE FUNDS TO TRAVEL HOME ON
SCHOOL BREAKS HAVE PARENTS WILL
NEVER BE ABLE TO SEE THEM PLAN
CHAMPIONSHIP GAMES DUE TO
FINANCIAL RESTRICTIONS.
AND FEEL PRESSURE TO GO PRO
BEFORE FINISHING THEIR
EDUCATIONS IN ORDER TO PROVIDE
FOR THEIR FAMILIES.
SB TWO OH SIX TO IT'S AN CA
COMPETITION LIMITS THAT ARE SO
SEVERE THAT COLLEGE ATHLETES
CAN'T PROFIT OFF OF THEIR OWN
NAME IMAGE AND LIKENESS.
IT ONLY HURTS PLAYERS LIKE
MYSELF WHO LOST THE CHANCE TO
MONETIZE SOME OF THE MOST
VALUABLE YEARS OF MYLIFE.
BUT ALSO HURTS THE AVERAGE
COLLEGE ATHLETE WHO IS AN
ALLOWED TO THROW CAMP AT THEIR
OWN SHOOT OLD JUNIOR HIGH START
A SMALL BUSINESS IN THEIR OWN
NAME OR EVEN FUND RAISE TO PAY
FOR MEDICAL EXPENSES.
NO OTHER COLLEGE STUDENTS ARE
TREATED THIS WAY MUSICIANS
DANCERS ACTORS AND EVEN OTHER
ATHLETES THAT ARE NOT A PART OF
THE NCAA -- HAVE NO RESTRICTIONS
ON THEIR CAPACITIES TO ACCEPT
SPONSORSHIPS AND FINANCIAL
GUESTS ONLY AND CA ATHLETES ARE
PROHIBITED FROM EARNING INCOME
FROM THEIR TALENT HARD WORK IN
ATHLETICS SUCCESSES.
SB TWO OH SIX WOULD HAVE ALLOWED
ME TO MONETIZE MY TALENT AND
HARD WORK BEFORE I WAS INJURED.
CURRENT AND SAY RULES ARE
PATENTLY UNFAIR -- THESE THE
NCAA IN THEIR MEMBER
UNIVERSITIES MAKE MILLIONS OFF
OF TV AND CORPORATE SPONSORSHIP
DEALS WELL ATHLETES FREE RISK
SERIOUS INJURIES A LIFETIME OF
EXPENSES AND ARE DENIED
COMPENSATION AND OPPORTUNITIES
FOR SPONSORSHIP WHILE.
MAKING MONEY FOR THESE
UNIVERSITIES -- IT IS WORTH
MENTIONING THAT ATHLETIC
SCHOLARSHIPS ARE NOT ENOUGH FOR
MANY STUDENT ATHLETES AND ALSO
NOT ALL STUDENT ATHLETES ARE ON
SCHOLARSHIP -- SO YOU HAVE
PEOPLE THAT ARE PAYING TO GO TO
COLLEGE AND STILL INCURRING
THESE EXTRA COSTS -- SOME PEOPLE
LOOK PAST THE GRUELING YEARS OF
TRAINING HARD WORK IN INJURIES
AND ARGUE THAT COLLEGE ATHLETES
GET ENOUGH BUT IT IS NEVER
ENOUGH TO HELP LESSEN EQUAL
PUBLICITY RIGHTS OR BE DENIED
THE ECONOMIC AND CIVIL RIGHTS
PROTECTIONS AFFORDED DOLLARS
OTHER AMERICANS.
I ASKED THE COMMITTEE TO VOTE
YES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WITH THIS IN
SUPPORT YOU HAVE ABOUT THIRTY
SECONDS LEFT OF YOUR FOUR
MINUTES BETWEEN THE TWO OF YOU
SO.
MAKE IT QUICK PLEASE BUT WAS
EXCELLENT TESTIMONY VERY HELPFUL.
MY NAME'S ANDY SCHWARTZ THANK
YOU -- SENATOR LEYVA AND JUST
PLACE YOUR WILK -- AND TO
EVERYONE FOR ALLOWING ME TO
TESTIFY -- MY NAME'S ANDY
SCHWARTZ I'M AN ECONOMIST I
STUDY HOW COMPETITIVE MARKETS
WORK FOR BETTERING SOCIETY AND I
AM A SMALL BUSINESS OWNER IN
EMERYVILLE CALIFORNIA -- I WANT
TO TALK JUST BRIEFLY ABOUT.
WHY RIGHTS ARE IMPORTANT -- IT'S
TRUE THAT MOST OF THE ATHLETES
IN CALIFORNIA COLLEGES ARE
EITHER.
OF MINORITIES OR WOMEN BUT IT
DOESN'T REALLY MATTER WHETHER
YOU ARE POOR OR RICH IF YOU TO
NIGER RIGHTS.
YOUR TO NIGER RIGHTS AND THE
STANDARD SHOULDN'T BE DON'T
THESE ATHLETES GET ENOUGH NOW
THE STATE OR SHOULD BE WHY ARE
THEY GETTING THEIR FULL CIVIL
RIGHTS -- COVER COLLEGE ATHLETES
EACH OF US BENEFIT FROM THE
FUNDAMENTAL RIGHT TO ENGAGE IN
FREE ENTERPRISE AND BY DENYING
ATHLETES HESE DURING THEIR PEAK
FOR MOST OF THEM THEIR PEAK
EARNING YEARS.
ESSENTIALLY WERE WERE --
SQUASHING ENTREPRENEURIAL
CONDUCT AND WE'RE PUSHING PEOPLE
IN MANY CASES ON TO FEDERAL OR
STATE ASSISTANCE -- SB TO A SIX
TWO AND SOME OF THIS
DISCRIMINATION -- BY ESSENTIALLY
ENDING WHAT IS A A PRICE FIXING
CARTEL BY THE NCAA SETTING THE
PRICE OF ALL ATHLETES RIGHTS AT
ZERO AND SO WHETHER YOU ARE A
PERSON WHO BELIEVES IN EQUALITY
UNDER THE LAW.
OR BELIEVES IN THE THE BENEFITS
OF FREE ENTERPRISE I WOULD
ENCOURAGE YOU AS A SENATOR TO
VOTE YES FOR THIS BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT PLEASE GO
THE MICROPHONE NAME ORGANIZATION
AND SUPPORT AND CHAIR MAP BROAD
FOR THE TEAMSTERS WE DON'T HAVE
A LETTER AND THAT WE ARE
SUPPORTING THE BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE CAITLYN
DEAN WITH POLICY LINK AND THE
ALLIANCE FOR BOYS AND MEN OF
COLOR IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
BILL.
MARIO GUERRERO ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT.
KEVIN AS IN COALITION CALIFORNIA
WILL PROVIDE SERVICE
ORGANIZATION THIS BILL IS WAY
OVER DEAL WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
MAY WASHINGTON CAL STATE SOONER
SO STATION WE SPARTAN CONCEPT.
ALEX GOOD FOR UC'S TRANSITION --
WE SUPPORT THANK YOU.
IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL [inaudible]
COME FORWARD.
SHE HAS TO MAKE A LITTLE ROOM AT
THE TABLE FOR THEM PLEASE
[inaudible]
GREAT.
WELCOME.
IF TWO MINUTES EACH BUT WE DID
GO OVER A LITTLE BIT ON SUPPORTS
ALL LEGAL FOR A LITTLE BIT AS
WELL.
GREAT THANK YOU.
A GOOD MORNING ALEX GRAYS THE
ASSOCIATION INDEPENDENT
CALIFORNIA COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES WE REPRESENT OVER
EIGHTY INDEPENDENT NONPROFIT
INSTITUTIONS IN THE STATE -- I'D
LIKE TO START JUST BY --
RECOGNIZING AND THANKING THE
SENATOR AND HER STAFF -- FOR
TAKING MULTIPLE MEETINGS WITH
WITH OUR GROUP AND OTHERS I JUST
TO DISCUSS OUR CONCERNS WE
REALLY APPRECIATE THAT THE TENOR
OF THOSE CONVERSATIONS.
SO WE COLLECTIVELY -- HAVE
THIRTY ONE INSTITUTIONS THAT
COMPETE IN THE NC TWO EIGHT NINE
AT THE DIVISIO ONE LEVEL NINE
AT THE DIVISION TO LEVEL AND
LEVEL.
I WANT TO SAY UP FRONT THAT WERE
NOT UNIFORMLY OPPOSED TO POLICY
REFORMS THAT BENEFITS STUDENT
ATHLETES -- BUT LACKING CHANGES
AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL WE MUST
RESPECT THE OPPOSE THIS BILL OUT
OF CONCERN -- FOR THE POSITION
IT PLACES ARE MEMBER
INSTITUTIONS AND I'D LIKE TO
SPEND JUST A MOMENT TALKING
ABOUT -- DEPOSITION SO FOR PORT
AND A TEST WHETHER NOT THEY'VE
ACCEPTED FINANCIAL PAYMENTS AND
IF THIS BILL WERE TO BECOME LAW --
OUR SCHOOLS WITH AND HAVE ONE OF
TO PASS THEY COULD THEY COULD
PURSUE.
THEY COULD CHOOSE TO SELF REPORT
THESE VIOLATIONS AND DEAN OF
STUDENT ATHLETES AND ELIGIBLE TO
PARTICIPATE.
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
UNPAID STUDENT ATHLETES COULD
CONTINUE TO COMPETE WITHOUT RISK
OF FORFEITED GAMES.
THEY COULD ALSO CHOOSE NOT TO
REPORT THESE VIOLATIONS IN THE
HOPES THAT VIOLATIONS GO
UNNOTICED BY THE IN SITU WAY.
BUT THAT EXPOSES OUR
INSTITUTIONS TO EVEN MORE
SIGNIFICANT PENALTIES IF AND
WHEN DISCOVERED BY THE IN SITU
AND IN EITHER INSTANCE.
ATHLETIC TEAMS AND POTENTIALLY
ENTIRE ATHLETIC DEPARTMENTS
COULD VERY LIKELY BE FOUND TO BE
IN VIOLATION OF NCAA BYLAWS
CITING -- WHAT THEY WOULD REFER
TO AS A LACK OF INSTITUTIONAL
CONTROL I WHICH TEAM SCHOOLS ARE
COMMITTING MAJOR AND REPEATED
VIOLATIONS AND INSTITUTIONS HAVE
FAILED TO DISPLAY ADEQUATE
CONTROL MEASURES?
AND EXAMPLES OF THESE TYPES OF
PENALTIES AND SEVERITY CAN BE
FOUND IN LOOKING AT WHAT
HAPPENED TO USC -- IN THE LAST
DECADE IN REGARDS THEIR FOOTBALL
AND BASKETBALL PROGRAMS OUR
AMONG OTHER THINGS THEY LOST
THIRTY SCHOLARSHIPS.
SO THESE PENALTIES CAN INCLUDE
VACATED WINS POSTSEASON BANS
LOTS OF MEDIA REVENUE WHICH IS
REINVESTED TO THE BENEFIT OF ALL
STUDENT ATHLETES BROADLY.
AS WELL AS REDUCTIONS AS I
MENTIONED STUDENT ATHLETIC
SCHOLARSHIPS WHICH JEOPARDIZES
OPPORTUNITIES FOR FUTURE STUDENT
ATHLETES DOWN THE ROAD.
IN CLOSING I JUST AGAIN WANT TO
STRESS OUR INSTITUTIONS ARE NOT
OPPOSED REFORMS THAT POTENTIALLY
BENEFITS STUDENT ATHLETES THERE
ARE A NUMBER OF EXAMPLES OF OF
INITIATIVES AFTER THE IN SITU A
INTO THE PAC TWELVE OVER THE
LAST NUMBER OF YEARS THAT THAT
OUR INSTITUTIONS HAVE BEEN
SUPPORTIVE OF THAT.
HAVE ADDRESS THINGS -- LIKE THE
THE GAP AND FINANCIAL SUPPORT
FOR SOME STUDENT ATHLETES I
BELIEVE IS REFERENCED IN THE
ANALYSIS -- BUT AGAIN LACKING
OTHER CHANGED AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL AT THIS TIME WE REMAIN
VERY CONCERNED WITH THE IMPACT --
AND POSITION AT THIS PLACES ARE
INSTITUTIONS AND AND FOR THOSE
REASONS MR SACK WE OPPOSE.
THANK YOU.
ADDITIONAL POSITION I ENJOY
WORKING AS CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY -- WE TO OPPOSE BUT
WE ARE ALSO VERY RESPECTFUL AND
APPRECIATIVE OF THE TIME THAT
THE AUTHOR STAFF HAS PROVIDED US
TO EXPRESS OUR CONCERNS ABOUT
THE IMPACT OF THE BILL ON OUR
PROGRAMS OUR CAMPUSES.
AT THE CSU WE HAVE TWENTY THREE
CAMPUSES OF THAT.
EXIST ONLY TWENTY TWO OF THEM
OFFER ATHLETICS -- NINE OF THEM
WERE DIVISION ONE SCHOOLS TWELVE
OR DIVISION TO SCHOOLS WE HAVE
ONE AND A AYE A SCHOOL WHICH IS
MARITIME.
AND CHALLENGE DOES NOT OFFER
PART -- ATHLETICS AT THIS PART
IS PART TIME BECAUSE OF THE SIZE
OF THEIR PROGRAM.
WE ARE EQUALLY CONCERNED ABOUT
THE THE IMPACT OF SB TWO OH SIX
WILL HAVE WE KNOW THAT THE
ESTIMATE SENATOR IS TRY TO CRAFT
A BILL THAT IS INTENDED.
TO NOT HARM THE INSTITUTIONS BUT
TO HAVE A CONVERSATION WITH THE
NC A AND THE STUDENT ATHLETE
ABOUT WHAT IS ACCEPTABLE AND
WHAT IS NOT ACCEPTABLE INCOMES
COMPENSATION -- THERE HAVE BEEN
A NUMBER OF CHANGES THAT THE
NCAA HAS DONE IN THE LAST FIVE
YEARS AND WE HAVE THE COPTER TO
BRING OUR CAR AT ONE OF OUR
DOCTORS ME WITH THE SENATOR.
WE TALKED A LITTLE ABOUT THOSE
CHANGES AND FRANKLY I'M NOT HERE.
RESIDENT NCAA BUT WHAT I HAVE
HEARD FROM FROM OUR CAMPUSES OF
THE CHANGES THAT HAPPENED AT THE
NCAA HAVE BEEN SIGNIFICANT.
AND MONUMENTAL LAST FIVE YEARS.
AND THE THE THE THE BENEFITS ARE
ALLOWED TO STUDENT ATHLETES.
IT'S CHANGING AND CHANGING OVER
TIME AND MAKING POINT BACK TO
THE BALKANS LEGATION THAT JUST
HAPPENED.
THAT IS A CHANGE IN AND WHAT WE
CAN PROVIDE STERN ATHLETES AND
GOING FORWARD IT'S GOING TO GO
ON FOR THE CONDOLEEZZA RICE
REPORT THAT JUSTCAME OUT
RECENTLY IS GOING TO PROBABLY
CHANGE THE WAY WE CAN.
PROVIDE -- BUT WE WILL CALL YOU
UP TO MANDATE THAT WE WILL HAVE
TO GET REPLACEMENT TH	C WILL
HAVE TO GIVE.
COMPLETION DEGREE FOR POP
BASKETBALL PLAYERS SO IF YOU'RE
IN THE PROGRAM TWO YEARS AGO TO
PLAY IN THE NBA ARE EVERYONE AND
PROFESSIONALLY IN YOUR COME BACK
STREET.
IT'S GOING TO BE A REQUIREMENT --
CAMPUSES THAT THEY HAVE TO
ENSURE THEY HAVE A DEGREE IN THE
PATH OF THE COME BACK TO THE
PROGRAM.
THAT -- WHAT I UNDERSTAND IS
THAT IS PROBABLY THE FIRST STEP
TOWARD ENDS UP PRODUCT?
THANK YOU.
ADDITIONAL OPPOSITION NAME
ORGANIZATION.
TYLER REGULAR BE AT THE
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA -- WE ARE
OPPOSED TO THE BILL WE PUT I
THINK THE BILL PUTS THE STUDENT
ATHLETES AND REALLY --
VULNERABLE AND AWKWARD POSITION
THANK YOU.
NAME ORGANIZATION AND OPPOSITION
PLEASE BRIAN MACKLIN ANY ABOUT
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
ATHLETIC ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION.
AFFRONT AVAILABLE SUMMER HAVE A
STANFORD UNIVERSITY IN IN
OPPOSITION.
JANET LOPEZ REPRESENTING THE
UNIVERSITY OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ANYONE
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS
CONCERNS CENTER DRAWS ON THEN
SENATOR PAN -- WELL.
I THINK THIS IS A LONG TIME.
BUT NEEDED LEGISLATION -- IT'S
TOO BAD THAT HAS TO BE THROUGH
LEGISLATION BUT BECAUSE IT SEEMS
TO ME.
THAT THE COLLEGES SHOULD HAVE
MOVED IN THAT DIRECTION OR THE
NCAA SO.
MY QUESTION IS HOW DOES THIS FIT
IN AND HOW DO YOU ADDRESS THE
ISSUES OF HOW THE NCAA.
COULD TAKE RETALIATION -- THOSE
ARE MY WORDS COULD TAKE
RETALIATION AGAINST CALIFORNIA
SCHOOLS -- AND DEPRIVE US FROM
PARTICIPATING.
WHAT WE SAY?
ABOUT ABOUT THAT BECAUSE I AS I
UNDERSTAND IT THE REFORMS HAVE
TO COME TO THE NCAA OR FEDERAL
LAW.
BUT WE NEED THESE CHANGES THE
THE WAY OUR COLLEGE ATHLETES
HAVE BEEN TREATED IS JUST.
IT'S EMBARRASSING.
WHEN YOU CONSIDER ALL THE MONEY
AND I KNOW THE BIASES AND
DISCRIMINATION AGAINST WOMEN?
ATHLETES IN PARTICULAR.
IS VERY EMBARRASSING SO.
HOW DO WE ADDRESS THE FACT THAT
IS REFORMS REALLY NEED TO HAPPEN
AT THAT LEVEL?
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION AND I
WILL -- GIVE YOU A SOME ANSWER
AND THEN -- IT'S POSSIBLE THAT
THE ANTI SWARTS MAY WANT TO ADD
TO IT AS HE'S BEEN IN EXPERT
WITNESS AT VARIOUS -- LAWSUITS
AGAINST THE IN SITU A SO FIRST.
THIS IS NOT THE FIRST TIME THAT
THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE IS
CONSIDERED SUCH A BILL.
IF THIS WERE THE FIRST TIME WE
WERE HAVING A DISCUSSION -- I
THINK WOULD BE VERY LEGITIMATE
TO SAY HEY LET'S GIVE AND SEE TO
A SOME TIME TO REFORM.
NOW THAT WE'RE BRINGING
ATTENTION TO THIS ISSUE LET'S
GIVE HIM SOME TIME TO REFORM
WELL IF WE LOOK AT THE HISTORY
OF NANCY TO A YOU HAD THE BLACK
ATHLETES BACK AS LONG AGO AS THE
MEXICO OLYMPICS.
WERE PROTESTING THE FACT THAT
THEY WERE LITERALLY IMPOVERISHED.
AND MANY OF THEM.
QUIT.
THEIR THEIR SCHOOLING AND EVEN
QUIT PARTICIPATING AS OLYMPIC
ATHLETES BECAUSE OF THE
FINANCIAL IMPACT ON THEM SO HERE
EDWARDS -- IT WELL KNOWN THAT
SOCIOLOGIST IN FRONT IT HAS BEEN
TALKING ABOUT THIS FOR YEARS
ADDITIONALLY THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE HAS ENTERTAINED
BILLS HAD BILLS PRESENTED. FOR
OVER THE PAST TWENTY YEARS ON
THIS SUBJECT MATTER INCLUDING BY
SEVEN SENATOR KEVIN MURRAY BACK
IN TWO THOUSAND AND THREE AND AT
LEAST TWO OTHER LEGISLATORS.
SO THERE BEEN MANY ATTEMPTS NOT
ONLY BY CALIFORNIA BUT BY OTHER
STATES THAT SENDS A CLEAR
MESSAGE TO NC TWO EIGHT AS WELL
AS PROMINENT ATHLETES TALKING
ABOUT IT ALL THE TIME -- AND
THEY HAVE NOT YET CHANGED NOW
WHEN I MET WITH OUR FRIENDS FROM
THE DIFFERENT COLLEGES WHO ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT THIS THEY'RE ALL
LIKE YOU KNOW WILL THE IN SITU A
HAS MADE SOME REFORMS AND I'M
LIKE YEAH.
THEY HAVE MADE SOME BUT LET'S
GET HIM TO DO THE RIGHT THING
AND I INVITED OUR COLLEGES TO
JOIN WITH ME SO THAT CALIFORNIA
COULD BE A CATALYST IN A LEADER.
IN DEMANDING THE REFORMS BY IN
SITU WAY NOW THE BILLS TO BILLS
EXPLICITLY PROHIBITS THE AND SEE
TO WAY FROM RETALIATING ON
CALIFORNIA ATHLETES IN
CALIFORNIA COLLEGES.
NOW WHETHER THEY DO OR DON'T AND
WHETHER IF WE'RE SUCCESSFUL IN
GETTING THIS BILL PASSED THE
TAKE IT TO COURT.
THAT'S PART OF THE PROCESS OF
BEING THE CATALYST BUT THE BILL
DESIGN NOW.
PREVENTS THEM FROM OR PROHIBITS
THEM FROM THE RETALIATION.
AND I DON'T KNOW FIVE INDY WANTS
TO WRITE I JUST WANNA ADD ONE
THING REAL QUICKLY ARE ACTUALLY
TWO THINGS I WAS HERE IN TWO
THOUSAND AND THREE BY PUSHING
FOR THE STUFF SO I'M SIXTEEN
YEARS OLDER NOW WHEN AT WHERE
THIS BASICALLY THE SAME SPOT --
EARLIER THIS YEAR THERE WAS A
STATE LEGAL CASE DOWN IN LOS
ANGELES OVER A DIFFERENT NCAA
ROLL CALL THE SHOW BECAUSE RULE
WHICH ALLOWS THE NCAA SCHOOLS TO
BOOK TO BASICALLY OPPOSE A
COLLECTIVE BOYCOTT ON A COACH.
IF HE OR SHE IS FOUND TO HAVE
VIOLATED THE RULES.
THE HEAD OF THE PAC -- TWELVE
LARRY SCOTT WHEN TESTIFIED SAID
IF YOU IF YOU STRIKE DOWN THIS
RULE OF CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS WILL
BE.
KICKED OUT OF THE NCAA SO SAME
SORT OF THREAT.
THEY HAVE NOT BEEN KICKED OUT.
THANK YOU SENATE RAZA IS ONE AT
THAT I CONSULTED MY EXPERT WHICH
IS MY SON MICHAEL -- AND HE VERY
MUCH IS ON THE SIDE OF THE
COLLEGE ATHLETES.
THANK YOU CENTER PAN.
I THANK YOU ACTUALLY CAN WE HAVE
THE OPPOSITION APPEAR A QUESTION
FOR THEM THAT'S ALRIGHT YOU CAN
STATE YOU CAN SAY THEY CAN SIT
THERE THEY HAVE INTERESTS.
THEY'RE STILL TEACHER YET
THERE'S ROOM FOR EVERYONE.
THERE YOU CAN GO THERE.
OKAY CENTER PAN THANK YOU AND
AND IT JUST Y. CLARIFY -- YOU
KNOW I HAD A CONVERSATION WITH
THEIR SCHEDULE CLARIFIED THE
OPPOSITION IS YOUR OPPOSITION
SOLELY BECAUSE YOU'RE CONCERNED
ABOUT WHAT AND AND SEE DOUBLE IT
WILL DO TO YOU AND THE ATHLETES.
ARE DO YOU HAVE ANY FUNDAMENTAL
CONCERNS WITH ANY THE POLICY
THINGS IN THE BILL SIDE FROM NC
DOUBLE A POTENTIALLY SAYING SO.
THE IDEA THAT THE THINGS ARE IN
THE BILL SUCH AS ALLOWING YOU
STUDENT ATHLETES TO BE ABLE --
TO YOU KNOW REPRESENTS BASICALLY
REPRESENT THEMSELVES MARKET.
OTHER TYPES OF THINGS THINGS
THAT I MEAN OTHER STUDENTS CAN
DO AND OTHER FIELDS SO I I JUST
WANT TO BE CLEAR ABOUT YOUR
OPPOSITION IS IT JUST BECAUSE OF
NC DOUBLE A OR DO YOU HAVE ANY
FUN OTHER FUNDAMENTAL ISSUES
WITH.
WHAT THE BILL IS REQUESTING?
I THINK GENERALLY SPEAKING IT IS
THE NCAA RULES BUT THERE ARE
SOME SOME WORDING IN THE IN THE
MEASURE -- RELATED TO WHAT IS
NAME LIKE THIS AN IMAGE WHAT WHO
WHO CAN PROVIDE THAT OKAY WHAT
IS THAT WHAT IS A CUT OFF.
OKAY -- THEN THAT'S PROBABLY
BETTER AT THE KINDS FROM THE
NCAA TO TELL US WHAT I THINK
THAT'S AYE ALTHOUGH ALTHOUGH I
DON'T KNOW NOW THAT YOU KNOW
THEY'LL BRING IN NC DOUBLE A
AGAIN I'M SAYING WHAT IS THE
WHAT THE YOU UNIVERSITIES WHAT.
THEY'RE CONCERNED ABOUT SO I
SAID LET'S REMOVE NC DOUBLE A I
KNOW WE HAVE TO DEAL WITH THAT
EVENTUALLY RIGHT.
BUT I WANT YOU TO TELL ME -- NC
DOUBLE A SAID HAS THIS ROLE I
WANT YOU KNOW I ONE KNOWS WEARS
YOU SEE WHAT INDEPENDENT
COLLEGES WHERE THE LC IT'S ON ON
THE FUNDAMENTAL.
ISSUES IN THIS BILL THAT THAT'S
PUT FORTH ASIDE FROM YES I GOT
THE CONCERNED ABOUT I JUST WANT
TO CLARIFY WHICH IS THE NC
DOUBLE A PART AND WHICH IS THE
PART THAT.
YOU'RE CONCERNED ABOUT IN THE
BILL.
THE SOVIET UNION FINALLY SAY
JUST JUST AND SEE DELAY BUT
DON'T TELL ME NC DOUBLE A RULES
ARE MAKING US DO SOMETHING THAT
STEP THAT'S A SEPARATE
CONVERSATIONS I GOT THAT.
SIDES ONE NODE ANY DO YOU HAVE
ANY DISAGREEMENT OTHER THING
OTHERWISE WHAT THE BILL SAYS.
BOB AGAIN THE DEFINITION
COMPENSATION WHAT WHAT CORSICA
OFF LINE IN THAT.
OKAY SO COULD I MEAN I THINK
PERHAPS MAYBE THE NEXT THAT THAT
THAT MAYBE THAT CAN BE WORKED
OUT OKAY ALL RIGHT -- AND
CERTAINLY YOU KNOW I UNDERSTAND
YOU HAVE TO LIVE IN THIS
UNIVERSE SO THE OTHER QUESTION I
HAVE.
IS -- THE NC A DOUBLE A HAS A
GOVERNANCE BODY HER RIGHT.
IS BECAUSE OF UNIVERSITIES
CORRECT -- HAVE YOUR HAS YOU SEE
THE PRESIDENT HAS PRESIDENCY
ISSUE HAS PRESIDENT OF
UNIVERSITIES WRITTEN LETTERS AND
SAID WE WANT YOU TO CHANGE THE
RULES.
WE WANT TO SUPPORT THESE THINGS
BECAUSE WE THINK OUR STUDENTS
SHOULD BE EMPOWERED.
HAVE YOU LIKE TO TRY TO CHANGE
THE RULES AT ALL AND SEE THAT
WAY.
SENT LETTERS INDICATING THAT WE
STRONGLY DISAGREE WITH THOSE
EXISTING RULES.
THIS IS TYLER FROM THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA I WOULD
SAY IF IT'S SPECIFIC TO LETTERS
BUT I WOULD SAY IN THE GENERAL
SPHERE OF THE POLICY CHANGES
THAT HAVE OCCURRED.
BY THE NC DOUBLE A FOR EXAMPLE
WE TALKED ABOUT GETTING
SCHOLARSHIPS UP TO FULL COST OF
ATTENDANCE AND EVEN INCLUDING.
MORE THAN COSTA TENANTS LIKE
THINGS -- FOR LAPTOPS WE TALKED
ABOUT OTHER EXPENSES THAT THAT
GAP BETWEEN COSTA TENSENESS
SCHOLARSHIP BUT YEAH I THINK.
ABSOLUTELY I CAN SPEAK FOR THE
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA THAT WE
SUPPORT.
THAT INCREASE AND WE WANT TO
PROVIDE AS MUCH AS WE CAN TO
STUDENT ATHLETES WITHIN THE
CONFINES OF THE FRAMEWORK THAT
WE ALL VOLUNTARILY AGREED TO
OKAY JOINT.
ALL RIGHT SO THE DON'T FORGET I
MEAN IT'S IF IT'S A FRAMEWORK
YOU DID VOLUNTARILY.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME.
YOU KNOW FOR BERMAN TO TAILOR
NAZARIAN WE WE WE KNOW THAT WE
DON'T KNOW WE HAVE EXISTING LAWS
WE ALSO CHANGE LOS THAT'S WHY
WE'RE HERE RIGHT.
NOW WE HAVE ROLES ONE CHANGE
ROLES AND WE THINK THE RULES ARE
NOT RIGHT STERN FAIR.
WE SEEK TO CHANGE THEM THAT'S
FIVE PEOPLE COME HERE -- TO SO I
I GUESS.
YEAH ALSO CERTAINLY IS EXPRESSLY
AUTHOR WHEN MY CONCERNS I DON'T
WANT TO JEOPARDIZE OUR SCHOOLS
AND ATHLETES BUT THE SAME TIME --
I ALSO WANT TO SEE THAT.
YOU KNOW YOU'RE PART OF THAT
COMMUNITY ALL RIGHT YOU'RE VERY
IMPORTANT PART I COMMUNITIES
CALIFORNIA WALKS AWAY.
THAT SOUNDS REALLY GOOD THING
FOR NC DOUBLE WAY RIGHT BUT I
ONE KNOW HOW HARD OUR CALIFORNIA
SCHOOLS FIGHTING FOR STUDENTS.
SO THAT'S WHAT THE FIRST
QUESTION WAS ABOUT THE ISSUE
ABOUT DO YOU AGREE OR NOT WITH
THE REFORMS ASIDE FROM NC DOUBLE
A THEN WHAT ARE YOU DOING WITH
IN THE COMMUNITY TO CHANGE THOSE
THINGS SO IT'S GREAT AND CW'S
MADE SOME CHANGES.
BUT WE'RE SAYING IT'S NOT ENOUGH
SO I UNDERSTAND CERTAINLY CENTER
SCANNERS BRING A BILL TO SAY
WHAT WE WANT TO PUT SOME MORE
LEVERAGE BY ONE KNOW WHAT ARE
OUR SCHOOLS DOING. TO PUSH FOR
THE VERY SAME THINGS THIS BILLS
PUSHING FOR AND CERTAINLY I'D
LOVE TO HEAR FROM YOU I
UNDERSTAND US TO JUST SAID SHE'S
WILLING TO YOU KNOW THE FINE
TUNING ABOUT POLICY PIECES ASIDE
FROM THE NC DOUBLE A PART SO.
HE CAN YOU SPEAK TO THAT.
ALEX GRAVES GIVEN THE ICC YOU I
THINK YOU'RE TWO QUESTIONS WHAT
I WOULD JUST ADD THAT MY
COLLEAGUES IT KIND OF TOUCHED ON
APOLOGIES ARE TO LOOK EVEN
SPEAKING TO THE MAG ABOUT THE
SAME TIME -- SO I THINK IN --
TWENTY FOURTEEN OUR MEMBER
INSTITUTIONS ARE PART THE PAC
TWELVE WHICH THERE'S THERE'S TWO
FOR ME I SEE CO TWO FROM THE UC --
WE'RE PART OF THE PUSH TO
SUPPORT CHANGES AROUND
GUARANTEEING MULTI YOUR
SCHOLARSHIPS -- AND WE'VE ALSO
BEEN SUPPORTIVE OF IT WAS
MENTIONED THIS AT ADDRESSING THE
ABILITY OF INSTITUTIONS TO PAY--
FOR PERSONAL EXPENSES FOR
EXAMPLE FOR THINGS LIKE THAT
STUDENT ATHLETES BE ABLE TO GO
HOME DURING BREAK -- THOSE ARE
EXAMPLE THINGS IN RECENT YEARS
OUR INSTITUTIONS AS I UNDERSTAND
IT HAVE BEEN SUPPORTIVE OF OF
CHANGING POLICY TO BETTER MEET
THAT AND AND I APPRECIATE THAT
WILL BUT WHAT ABOUT.
EVEN FURTHER LIKE WHAT IT'S BEEN
PROPOSES BILL HAVE HAD HAD THEM
IS THAT SOMETHING THE
UNIVERSITY'S WOULD CONSIDER --
ACTUALLY.
BEING MORE VOCAL ABOUT I MEAN I
I'D LOVE TO KNOW WHAT YOUR
ACTUAL POSITION IS I MEAN IT'S
IT'S IT'S GREAT OF USA LNC BUT
DON'T DON'T HIDE BEHIND AND SEE
DOUBLE A SHOW ME WHERE YOU WHERE
YOU STAND.
SEPARATE FROM NC DOUBLE A AND I
THINK YOU KNOW TO YOUR OTHER
QUESTION.
THE RELATED QUESTION AROUND --
KIND OF IS IT JUST ISSUE THE NC
TO A OR THE OTHER ISSUES I THINK
I WOULD ECHO WHAT MY COUNTERPART
FROM C. S. U. S. SAID ABOUT
AROUND SOME -- CONCERNING -- AND
SEEKING CLARITY AND A BETTER
UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT
COMPENSATION FOR A NAME IMAGE
AND LIKENESS OKAY LOOKS LIKE AND
HOW -- WE OPERATE THE
OPERATIONALIZE THAT FOR PROGRAMS
OKAY SO SO LET ME JUST PUT IT
THIS WAY THEN.
I'D LOVE TO KNOW.
WHERE ARE UNIVERSITIES I MEAN WE
HAVE YOU SEEN YOU SEE AS YOUR
PUBLIC UNIVERSITIES?
RIGHT SO WE HEAR FROM WE'LL HEAR
FROM YOU AND YOU TALK TO US ALL
THE TIME ALSO THE OFTEN OR
PRIVATE DINNER.
WHERE YOU ACTUALLY STAND
[inaudible]
OKAY.
ALRIGHT BUT DON'T HIDE BEHIND NC
DOUBLE A TELL ME WHERE YOU
REALLY STAND BEHIND YOU MAY NEED.
TO THE AND WHAT YOU'RE WILLING
TO FIGHT.
FOR LIKE WE REALLY STAND.
OKAY -- AND I THINK WE NEED TO
HAVE THIS CONVERSATION CONTINUES
ON A SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY --
BUT I ALSO WANT AN HONEST
CONVERSATION ABOUT WHAT OUR OWN
UNIVERSITIES ARE DOING. TO
EMPOWER AND SUPPORT THEIR
STUDENTS.
AND WHAT YOU'RE WILLING TO FIGHT.
FOR NOT HIDE BEHIND [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR PAN ANY
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
CENTER WILK.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
SHARE YOUR CONCERNS AND I
TYPICALLY DON'T LIKE BILLS THAT
ARE LIKE CALIFORNIA ONLY.
THE FACT OF THE MATTER IS THE NC
DOUBLE A THREE BILLION DOLLAR
INDUSTRY IN THE CHEAT THEY TREAT
THEIR STUDENT ATHLETES LIKE
THEIR CHATTEL.
AND IT'S GOT TO STOP ENCOURAGE
YOU TO CONTINUE TO NEGOTIATE%
WITH THE CENTER ON THOSE THINGS
THAT ARE THAT YOU HAVE CONCERNS
WITH THAT ARE PART FROM THE NCAA.
BUT THE NCA IS NOT GOING TO
CHANGE AND TO WE FOR SOME TO
CHANGE SO I PLANS FOR YOUR BILL
TODAY AND I AM VERY.
APPRECIATIVE OF YOU MOVING
FORWARD WITH THIS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR BOOK AND
BEFORE WE ASK YOU TO CLOSE
CENTERS CARE I TOO WOULD JUST
LIKE TO SAY THAT.
CHANGES NEED TO BE MADE I THINK
YOUR STATEMENT ABOUT THAT
STARTED IN TWO THOUSAND TWO SO
AND CA IS BEEN AWARE OF THIS FOR
A NUMBER OF YEARS AND THEY
CHANGES.
AND I DO THINK THAT ARE WOMEN
ATHLETES TAKE THE BRUNT OF THIS
I HAVE A DAUGHTER WHO PLAY
BASKETBALL AND SOFTBALL IN
COLLEGE AND HER KNEES WILL NEVER
BE THE SAME FORTUNATELY SHE
DOESN'T LIKE TO WEAR HEELS
SOCIAL WE COULDN'T FLATS.
BUT I APPRECIATE YOU BRING THIS
FORWARD I APPRECIATE YOU WORKING
WITH THE COMMITTEE.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE THANK
YOU I PRECIADO THE DIALOGUE OF
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND I
REALLY APPRECIATE THE QUESTIONS
THAT YOU RAISING YOUR STATEMENTS
AND I COULD HAVE GIVEN YOU MORE
ANALOGIES AROUND -- VARIOUS --
ATHLETES INCLUDING OUR OLYMPIC
SWIMMERS MISSY FRANKLIN AND
KATIE LEDECKY ONE WHO WAS CITY
AND SEE TO A PLAYER FOR CAL THE
OTHER AT STANFORD.
BUT ALL HOLD OFF ON THAT -- I'LL
GIVE YOU AN ANALOGY OF YOU KNOW
WHEN CALIFORNIA MOVED TO MAKE
CLEAN AIR RAGS AND THEN LATER
OUR CLIMATE PROTECTION
REGULATIONS AUTO COMPANIES
UNIFORMLY SAID NO NO DO NOT DO
THIS IN THIS STATE ALONE W WANT
A LEVEL PLAYING FIELD WE ONLY
WANT.
TO DO SOMETHING THAT THE WHOLE
NATION DOES AND YET WE PURSUED
AND NOW MOST EVERY STATE MOST
EVERY -- YOU CAN BUY CLEAN CARS
EVERYWHERE -- WHEN WE INTRODUCED
AN INCREASE TO THE MINIMUM WAGE
OUR STATE CHAMBER WHEN AGAINST
THE MINIMUM WAGE BECAUSE AGAIN
WHY SHOULD CALIFORNIA BE
DIFFERENT -- IN YET LOOK WE'VE
HELPED TO NOT ONLY IMPROVE THE
ECONOMIC STATUS OF OUR OWN
RESIDENTS BUT MINIMUM WAGES HAVE
INCREASED ACROSS THE COUNTRY NOT
EVERYWHERE YET BUT THOSE ARE
JUST SOME EXAMPLES -- AND I
WELCOME OUR CALIFORNIA COLLEGES
PLAYING A LEADERSHIP ROLE IN
THIS SITE ABSOLUTELY WELCOME IT
AND EACH MEETING THAT I'VE HAD
WITH HIM I SAID LOOK JOINT
TOGETHER LET'S FIGURE OUT WHAT
WAYS WOULD YOU MODIFY THIS. TO
BE A REAL PARTNER TO BE THE
LEADERSHIP FOR THE CATALYST FOR
CHANGE.
INTERESTINGLY ENOUGH REPUBLICAN
CONGRESS MEMBER MARK WALKER AND
DEMOCRATIC CONGRESS MEMBER
CEDRIC RICHMOND HAVE NOW
INTRODUCED A BILL TO CONGRESS.
TO GET FEDERAL ACTION.
ON OTHER STATES HAVE BEEN
CONSIDERED SUCH ACTION SO WERE --
WE WILL BE ON THE GOOD SIDE OF
HISTORY WITH THAT I ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE.
HE CENTERS SKINNER TO HAVE A
MOTION MOVED BUSH MADE BY
SENATOR WELL BOUNCE SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ITEM THREE SB TWO OH SIX THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS LEYVA.
LEYVA I WILL CRY WILK I CHANGE
CHIANG I'D RUSSELL.
RUSSELL AYE GLAZER MCGUIRE PAN.
PAN HI.
THE BILL HAS ENOUGH VOTES BUT WE
WILL LEAVE IT ON CALL THANK YOU
CENTER SKINNER.
CENTER HERTZBERG YOU HAVE BEEN
INFINITELY PATIENT WITH US THIS
MORNING.
PLEASE COME FORWARD.
SB TWO SIXTY FIVE BY SENATOR
HERTZBERG.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS WELCOME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ALMOST TWO
YEARS AGO. TO THE DAY I STOOD AT
THIS DíAS BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE.
AND PRESENTED THE CHILD HUNGER
PREVENTION AND FAIR TREATMENT
ACT OF TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
AND RECEIVED.
A UNANIMOUS SUPPORT OF THIS
COMMITTEE AND EVERY COMMITTEE AT
EVERY FLOOR ACTION SINCE THEN.
IN TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN ON
THIS MEASURE AND THE REASON THAT
WAS THE CASE MADAM CHAIR.
IS BECAUSE THIS IS ONE OF THOSE
BILLS THAT JUST SCREAMED OF
EQUITY.
KIDS WHO GO TO SCHOOL BECAUSE
THEIR PARENTS DIDN'T HAVE THE
MONEY YOU'RE PAID A BILL ARE
GIVEN A DIFFERENT MEAL FOUR
OUNCES OF JUICE AND A HALF A
SANDWICH.
SOME ARE MORE STAMPED IN THEIR
HANDS MARK DID NOT TO GIVE ME A
MEAL OR SOME PEOPLE THERE
SITTING WITH THEIR FRIENDS ALL
OF A SUDDEN -- MEAL IS RIPPED
OUT IN FRONT OF THEM.
A GREGIS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
IN ALL COMMITTEES AND IN BOTH
HOUSES BECAUSE OF THE NATURE OF
THIS AND WHAT DID WE LEARN AND
WHY AM I BACK I'M A LITTLE
EMBARRASSED TO BE BACK HERE
TODAY.
BECAUSE OUR FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
IS CHANGE CERTAIN STANDARDS
DEPARTMENT OF AGRICULTURE AND
SOME SCHOOL DISTRICTS HAVE
CHOSEN TO TRY.
TO NIT PICK THE LAW THE FIGURE
OUT WAYS TO NOT TAKE CARE OF
THESE KIDS NOW I UNDERSTAND OF A
PARENT DOESN'T PAY THEIR BILL
IT'S ONE THING.
BUT YOU DO NOT SHAME A KID IN
SCHOOL PERIOD END OF CASE.
AND SO WHAT WE'RE DOING TODAY
AND TAKING THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENT BECAUSE THE ONE
QUESTION ABOUT THIS IT'S FAIRS
THIS MAY IN FACT REQUIRE COSTS
AND SO WE'LL PUT A SUNSET.
AND TAKE A LOOK AT WHAT THE
COSTS ARE FOR DISTRICTS BUT THIS
IS A SITUATION WHEN I HEARD
ABOUT THIS A FRIEND OF MINE TOLD
ME THAT THEY WERE SHOWED ME
MEMOS FROM SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WAYS TO GET
AROUND THIS BILL.
SO WE'RE BACK.
WE'RE BACK IN MORE FILL IN THOSE
HOLES AND I REMEMBER WHEN I
PRESENTED THIS BILL SENATOR WILL
JOIN DON FROM THE DíAS IS A CO
AUTHOR OF THIS MEASURE -- AMONG
OTHER REPUBLICANS OR NON DO IT
AGAIN.
SO WITH THAT -- I'LL HAVE A
WITNESSES PRESENT TEN AYE THANK
YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO YET AGAIN
PRESENT ON THIS VERY IMPORTANT
MEASURE.
THANK YOU CENTER HERTZBERG TWO
WITNESSES TO MINCE EACH PLEASE.
CAN REALLY ROSENBERGER WITH
SERVICE EMPLOYEES INTERNATIONAL
UNION WHERE DOES A POINT TO BE
BACK HERE ON THIS ISSUE -- OUR
CAFETERIA WORKERS WERE VERY
ENGAGE ON THIS IN PART BECAUSE
THEY'RE THE ONES THAT HAVE TO
ENFORCE THIS POLICY -- WHAT'S.
WHEN WE?
FIRST STARTED WORKING ON THIS
LIKE A MAYBE A HANDFUL OF
SCHOOLS IT'S NOT A HUGE ISSUE
EVERY SINGLE ONE OF OUR
CAFETERIA WORKERS SHARED A STORY
WITH US.
OUR WORKERS ARE OFTEN FOOD INTO
CARE AND FOR THEM TO HAVE TO
ENFORCE THIS ON THE STUDENTS IS
DEMORALIZING AND IT'S DIFFICULT
FOR THEM TO CONTINUE SERVING THE
SCHOOLS BUT THEY HAVE TO BECAUSE
IT'S THEIR JOB.
SO WE WOULD ASK THAT YOU NOT
ALLOW LOOPHOLES BUT THEN PUT THE
ONUS ON OUR WORKERS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
PLEASE PROCEED THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
JESSICA BARTH Là WITH THE
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY AND SPONSOR AND SUPPORT.
I DON'T THINK ANYBODY WOULD
DISAGREE THAT ONE OF MOST
DISCUSSING THINGS THAT CAN
HAPPEN IS THAT A HUNGRY CHILD
GOES WITHOUT FOOD -- WHEN THIS
ALSO HAPPENS IN A SCHOOL
ENVIRONMENT WHEN THERE'S A MEAL
ALREADY MADE FOR THEM?
THAT'S EVEN MORE DISGUSTING AND
WHEN THEY ARE THEN REQUIRED TO
GO BACK TO SCHOOL INTO THE
CLASSROOM.
AND TO PAY ATTENTION. TO BE
REPRIMANDED AND DOES THE PLANNED
IF THEY DON'T.
THIS IS NOT A STATUS QUO THAT
ANYBODY IN THE STATE CAN BE
PROUD OF LATE WE ALSO ARE
DISAPPOINTED BE BACK HERE IN TO
SEE -- SOME OF THE SCHOOLS
FINDING WAYS AROUND LAST YEAR'S
LAW -- AND AND WE KNOW THAT THE
ISSUE IS COMPLICATED AND SO WE
REALLY APPRECIATE THE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE FROM THE COMMITTEE
STAFF TO HELP TRY TO FIGURE OUT
HOW DO WE MOVE THIS FORWARD IN A
WAY THAT DOESN'T.
BANKRUPT OUR SCHOOLS THE DOESN'T
UNDERMINE ECONOMIC SECURITY OF
THE WORKERS BUT ALSO DOESN'T LET
A KID GO HUNGRY.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU GO AHEAD KEVIN AS THE
COALITION CALIFORNIA WHAT FOR
RIGHTS ORGANIZATION IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL AND I THINK
WITH THE DOING THE DOING CHILD
ABUSE WHEN THEY DO THIS TO KIDS.
AND SHAMEFUL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND YOU ALL WIN FOR
BEING UNDER TIME GOOD JOB.
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
PAMELA GIVES REPRESENTING THE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE BILL FOR THE REASONS
PREVIOUSLY STATED.
TURN MEMBERS CUT THE MUSTARD BUT
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
FOOD BANKS IN SUPPORT.
MORNING RESIDENTS ALSO ME HALF
OF THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS IN STRONG SUPPORT.
TRACY PATTERSON CALIFORNIA FOOD
POLICY ADVOCATES IN SUPPORT
REALLY GLAD YOU'RE LOOKING AT
THE SUSTAINABILITY ISSUES IT'S
GREAT.
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
CNN IS THEIR OPPOSITION.
PLEASE COME FORWARD MAKE A
LITTLE ROOM.
THANK YOU WELCOME.
GOOD MORNING BEGIN WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY.
ELIZABETH ASKED ABOUT THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF SCHOOL
BUSINESS OFFICIALS COUNCIL
SUPPORTS THE EFFORTS OF THE
AUTHOR TO ENSURE THAT ALL
STUDENTS HAVE ACCESS TO MALES
ARE NOT SHAMED WHEN HAVING
UNPAID SCHOOL MEALS.
ALL MALE FIGURES HOWEVER WE MUST
WE HAVE SOME FISCAL
IMPLEMENTATION CONCERNS -- THAT
WE'D LIKE TO SHARE.
WE HAVE CONCERNS WITH PROVIDING
ONLY ONE MEAL OPTION TO ALL
STUDENTS WITHOUT ADDITIONAL
FUNDING BECAUSE IT WILL CREATE A
FINANCIAL BURDEN ON SO MANY
SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
WHILE SOME SCHOO DISTRICTS MAY
BE ABLE TO USE PARENT TEACHER
ASSOCIATIONS AND PUBLIC AND
PRIVATE.
DONATIONS TO PAY FOR SCHOOL MIL
DEFICITS MOST SCHOOL DISTRICTS
TAP INTO THE GENERAL FUNDS TO
OFFSET THESE COSTS.
HI FREE IN REDUCE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS COSTS ARE MINIMIZED BY
THE COMMUNITY COMMUNITY
ELIGIBILITY PROVISION WHICH
PROVIDES FREE MEALS TO ALL
STUDENTS REGARDLESS OF INCOME
STATUS BUT NOT ALL SCHOOL SITES
QUALIFY FOR CP.
SOME SCHOOL DISTRICTS ESTIMATE
BETWEEN FIVE HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND TO A MILLION DOLLARS
ANNUALLY TO PROVIDE ONLY ONE
MEAL OPTION TO ALL STUDENTS.
THERE ARE SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE
PROVIDE ALTERNATIVE MEAL OPTIONS
TO ALL STUDENTS DALY.
ANY STUDENT MAY SELECT AN
ALTERNATIVE MEAL FOR THEIR MEAL
CHOICE HAVING THE SELECTIONS FOR
ALL STUDENTS ALLOW.
ALLOWS FOR STUDENT WITH
INSUFFICIENT FUNDS TO NOT BE
DIRECTLY IDENTIFIED WHEN THEY
RECEIVE THE CHOICE AS AN
ALTERNATIVE MEAL.
WE ALSO HAVE CONCERNS WITH THE
IMPLEMENTATION DATE THE BILL HAS
AN EMERGENCY CLAUSE AND WOULD GO
INTO EFFECT IMMEDIATELY.
THIS WOULD LIMIT THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT'S ABILITY TO PLAN
ACCORDINGLY. FOR THE ADDITIONAL
COSTS INTO THEIR SCHOOL BUDGET.
WE REQUEST THAT SB TWO SIXTY
FIVE BE AMENDED TO PROVIDE
FUNDING TO COVER THE COSTS FOR
UNIVERSAL MEALS IF THERE'S NOT A
BUDGET APPROPRIATION TIED.
THEN WE REQUEST THE BILL ALLOW
SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO PROVIDE AN
ALTERNATIVE MEAL IF THE
ALTERNATIVE MEAL IS AVAILABLE TO
ALL STUDENTS DALY.
AND WE ALSO ASK FOR A PHASE IN
IMPLEMENTATION DATE TO LAW
SCHOOL DISTRICTS TIME TO PLAN
AND BUDGET ANTICIPATED COSTS AND
HAVE ALIGNED WITH THE LOCAL.
CONTROL ACCOUNTABILITY PLAN AND
THE BUDGET PROCESS AND FOR THESE
REASONS BECAUSE WHAT HOUSING
OPPOSE UNLESS I'M IN A POSITION
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUE
WORKING WITH AUTHORED A STAFF ON
THIS BILL.
THANK YOU PLEASE PROCEED.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE INTO THE READ ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
NUTRITION ASSOCIATION.
CCNA REPRESENTS SCHOOL FOOD
SERVICE DIRECTORS -- EMPLOYEES
AND INDUSTRY MEMBERS WHO WORK
TOGETHER TO PROVIDE NUTRITIOUS
MEALS TO CALIFORNIA'S CHILDREN
AND TO MAKE SURE NO CHILD IS
HUNGRY -- CS IN A IS NEUTRAL ON
THE POLICY CHANGES ON THE BILL
WE DO HAVE STRONG CONCERNS ABOUT
THE COST -- WE APPRECIATE
SENATOR AND SPEAKS DESIRE TO
ENSURE THAT AN APPROPRIATE
PROCESS IN PLACE AND TO ADDRESS --
ENSURE THAT STUDENTS AB WHO THEN
PAID NO CHARGES -- ARE TREATED
FAIRLY AND NOT SHAMED -- OUR
MEMBERS WORK VERY HARD TO
PROVIDE -- THE MEALS OUT FOR OUR
CALIFORNIA'S CHILDREN.
THE PREPARE BREAKFAST LUNCH IS
AN AFTER SCHOOL SNACKS MANY HAVE
SUPPER AND WE CAN BACK PACK
PROGRAMS AS WELL THEY DO THE
WORK THEY DO.
BECAUSE THEY WANT TO MAKE SURE
STUDENTS ARE FED AND READY TO
LEARN.
THEY DON'T DO THE JOB FOR
FANFARE BUT BECAUSE THE KILLER
CERTAINLY NOT FOR FAME OR
FORTUNE BUT BECAUSE THEY CARE
ABOUT CHILDREN.
WE WISH THAT WE COULD PROVIDE
EVERY CHILD IN CALIFORNIA WITH
MEALS FREE OF CHARGE AND WE
WOULD LOVE TO WORK WITH SENATOR
HERTZBERG AND COMMITTEE FOR AN
ANNUAL APPROPRIATION TO DO SO --
OUR MEMBERS ALREADY HAVE
POLICIES IN PLACE THAT FOCUS ON
CONTACTED THE PARENT NOT THE
STUDIO.
THERE HAVE BEEN -- A NUMBER OF
POLICY CHANGES SINCE A. B. SB
TWO FIFTY THAT HAVE BEEN GOOD AT
CREATING AWARENESS AND WE THINK
THAT'S THAT HAS BEEN IMPORTANT.
BUT IT'S ALSO HAS INCREASED THE
COST DRAMATICALLY.
I'M MOST OF THE POLLS HE'S CALL
FOR PROVIDING THE SAME MAIL
HOWEVER SOME DO PROVIDE AN
ALTERNATE MAIL.
I WHICH IS ALLOWABLE BASED ON
THE INTERPRETATION OF OF SB TWO
FIFTY BY THE DEPARTMENT AND
OTHERS ARE THE GUYS THAT THAT
THE FIELD RECEIVED.
INCIDENTALLY AN ALTERNATE MEAL
AS MY COLLEAGUE NOTED IS OFTEN
CHOSEN BY STUDENTS -- BROTHER
THEY PREFER.
BUT SADLY UNPAID MEAL CHARGES
ARE NOT REIMBURSED BY FEDERAL
DOLLARS WE RECEIVED THE NATIONAL
SCHOOL LUNCH PROGRAM FOR SOME
DISTRICTS THAT COST CAN BE
ASTRONOMICAL AS NOTED IN THE
ANALYSIS AS YOU'LL SEE BY THE
SURVEY DISTRIBUTE THIS WAS A
SURVEY.
OF OUR MEMBERS OF THEIR COSTS IN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN PRIOR TO THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF SB TWO FIFTY
AFTER AND CURRENTLY.
BUT DEFICIT AT THE END OF THIS
FISCAL YEAR MUST BE COVERED BY A
DISTRICTS GENERAL FUND WHICH
MEANS THAT OTHER DISTRICT
PROGRAMS MAY NOT RECEIVE THE
FUNDS THEY NEED.
DISTRICTS OF IMPLEMENTED
MULTIPLE EFFORTS TO LOWER COST
THEY DO WHATEVER THEY CAN TO
ENROLL STUDENTS IN FREE AND
REDUCED LUNCH AND TO INCREASE
PROVISION.
TO AND C. E. P. PARTICIPATION
UNFORTUNATELY BECAUSE OF THINGS
GOING ON AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL
MANY FAMILIES ARE -- WARY OF
SIGNING UP AND NOT JUST BASED ON
IMMIGRATION STATUS BUT BECAUSE
THE FORMS REQUIRED ETHNICITY
SOMETHING REQUIRED UNDER FEDERAL
LAW.
OUR FOR OUR FOLKS ACOSTA
REDESIGNED AREAS WHERE STUDENTS --
PAY IN HOW THEY PAY.
BUT CASTIEL RICE WE'RE CONCERNED
BECAUSE OF THE REQUIREMENTS
UNDER STATE AND FEDERAL LAW
RELATIVE TO UNPAID DEBT IF WE
ARE UNABLE TO RESOLVE THE COST
ISSUE STUDENTS WILL BE AFFECTED
BY CUTS TO OTHER GENERAL FUND
BASED PROGRAMS.
AND MORE SCHOOL DISTRICTS COULD
BE PUT IN FISCAL DISTRESS.
AND WE AGREE AND UNDERSTAND THE
SENATORS AND CAN'T WITH SB.
TWO SIXTY FIVE WE GREATLY
APPRECIATE THE WILLINGNESS OF
HIS STAFF TO WORK WITH US TO
ADDRESS THESE THESE COST ISSUES.
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH HIM IN A STAFF TO DO SO.
THANK YOU.
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE OPERATE
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ANY
QUESTIONS COMMENTS CONCERNS
[inaudible]
CENTER PAN.
THANK YOU CENTERS FOR AGAIN --
AND AND I APPRECIATE -- YOUR
EFFORTS TO TRY TO SURE THAT
FIRST OF ALL CERTAINLY WE SHOULD
NOT BE SHAMING STUDENTS -- BUT
CAN YOU PERHAPS ADDRESS THE
OPPOSITION'S ISSUE ABOUT THE THE
THE CUT THE COST AND I THINK AN
ANALYSIS WITH THAT I THINK IT
DOES POINT OUT THERE'S ACTED
RATHER DRAMATIC RISE IN COSTS SO --
CAN YOU PERHAPS SPEAK TO HOW WE
SHOULD TRY TO ADDRESS THAT HOW
YOU THINK THAT SHOULD BE
ADDRESSED AND WITH A KIND OF A
YOU KNOW AND AND AND ALSO THE
MENTIONED ALTERNATIVE MEALS
AVAILABLE TO ALL STUDENTS AGAIN
I DON'T KNOW THAT THAT THAT
PERMIT.
THE STUDENTS TO CHOOSE WHICH
MILLER DATE ONLY BE FORCED TO DO
THE ALTERNATIVE.
MAYBE I SHOULD ASK THE
OPPOSITION REAL QUICK TO CLARIFY
THEIR AMENDMENT [inaudible]
AFTER PROPOSAL.
PLEASE PROCEED YES ELIZABETH
DESCHANEL CASPER -- YES WE KNOW
THAT THERE ARE SOME SCHOOL
DISTRICTS THAT PROVIDE
ALTERNATIVE MEAL OPTIONS TO ALL
STUDENTS EVERY DAY FOR THE HOW
THE THE MAIL IT BUT WITH THE
SENATE INTO UNFORTUNATELY DID
NOT HAVE ORDER.
PARENTS BEHIND WITH THE HAVE A
CHOICE OF EITHER MY OLD IT ONLY
HAVE THE ALTERNATE MEAL
[inaudible]
BOTH.
SO THOSE ARE YOU SAYING LEAST
ANSWERED ME ALL YOU GOT THAT
EVERYONE HAS A CHOICE STILL YES
OKAY HOLD ALTERNATIVE MEAL WHAT
IS AVAILABLE TO ALL STUDENTS.
AND ALSO INCLUDING THE STUDENT
WHO'S MAYBE BEHIND PAYMENT COULD
STILL PICK UP OKAY EXACTLY IF I
WHAT YOUR PROPOSAL IS OKAY THAT
BUT THAT IS ONE THAT IS NOT WHAT
THIS BILL DOES OKAY.
SO I KNOW YOU HAVE TO CLEAR
EVERYTHING THE ARK POSITION
ARGUES COMPLETELY MISSES THE
POINT IT MISSED THE POINT LAST
TIME IT MISSES THE POINT WORSE
THIS TIME.
IT MISSES THE POINT BECAUSE WE
HAVE A FEDERAL PROGRAM.
THAT PROGRAM STUDENTS CAN SIGN
UP FOR AND TO GET THEIR MEALS
PAID.
FOR IT AND THATS REIMBURSED TO
THE DISTRICT OKAY THAT'S PRETTY
SIMPLE THIS IS ABOUT THE PARENT
AND WE TESTIFIED LAST TIME THAT
YOU HAD PARENTS THAT WEREN'T
EVEN INFORMED THAT FOR THE THEY
WEREN'T EVEN GET A NOTICE.
AND THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS
MANAGEMENT WAS SO BAD THAT THEY
JUST SIMPLY PUT THE WORKERS IN
THE POSITION AND PUT THE
STUDENTS IN A POSITION TO RIP
OFF THE MEALS OR TO PUT KIM
SOMETHING ALTERNATIVE.
THE ALTERNATIVE MEAL PROGRAM
CAME OUT WITH THE NEW
ADMINISTRATION'S DEPARTMENT OF
AGRICULTURE I AM NOT ARGUING
WITH THERE'S AN ALTERNATIVE MEAL
THAT SUPPLIED TO EVERYBODY THIS
A LUNCH SHAMING BILL THIS IS A
BILL WHERE.
YOU NEED TO GET OFF YOUR ****
AND FIGURE OUT HOW TO COLLECT
THESE BILLS THIS IS AN OFFENSE
TO ME THAT THEY'RE OBJECTING TO
THE URGENCY BECAUSE ALL WE'RE
DOING IN THIS BILL IS SAYING
LIVE BY THE LAW.
AND DON'T TRY TO PLAY THE
LAWYERS GAME TO FIGURE OUT A WAY
TO GET AROUND IT THESE NOT WE'RE
ASKING FOR THIS A LUNCH SHAMINGBILL.
AND THIS IS BASICALLY REQUIRING
THESE ADMINISTRATIONS TO FIGURE
OUT HOW TO COLLECT THE BILL WITH
OUT.
SHAMING THE KIDS THERE IS A
FEDERAL PROGRAM THAT REIMBURSES
THEM THE ALTERNATIVE BILL
ABILITY FOR OTHER MEALS AS THE
BY THE WAY JUST YOU KNOW THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL JUST BLAST HALF
AN HOUR.
JUST JOINED A MULTI SUIT
LITIGATION AGAINST THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT DEALING WITH FEDERAL
NUTRITIONAL STANDARDS WITH A
NUMBER OF OTHER STATES BECAUSE
THIS IS A FEDERAL PROBLEM
DEALING WITH WHAT THEY'RE TRYING
TO DO. TO REDUCE THESE KINDS OF
BENEFITS TO KIDS BUT THAT'S A
SEPARATE A SEPARATE ARGUMENT THE
ARGUMENT IS MANAGER DISTRICT IN
A WAY THAT DON'T SHAME KIDS END
EVERY MORAL LEVEL.
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE ABOUT AND YES
THERE'S GOING TO BE SOME
PROBLEMS WERE PARENTS DON'T PICK
UP THE TAB YES THERE'S GOING TO
BE SOME PROBLEMS WERE MAYBE THAT
ABILITY MORE CREATIVE IN
COLLECTING THE BILL.
AND YES THIS COMMITTEE HAS
ADDRESS THAT BY PUTTING A SUNSET
ON THIS SO THAT WE CAN THEN DO A
DIAGNOSTIC TO MAKE A
DETERMINATION GOING FORWARD.
BUT TO TO OBJECT TO THIS URGENCY
WHEN IN FACT THIS IS THE LAW OF
THE LAND IN CALIFORNIA AND THESE
FEW DISTRICTS ARE TRYING TO GET
AROUND THE LAW SHAME ON THEM.
THANK YOU THANK YOU CENTER
HERTZBERG.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE CONCERNS.
SIR HERTZBERG WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE.
GONNA MOVE THE BILL THE BILL.
SO TAKE IT THE BILL'S BEEN MILK
MOVED YET AS A CO AUTHOR THANK
YOU.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE THANK
YOU THINK IT MADE MY CLOTHES I
THINK YOU DID.
BEEN SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
ITEM FOUR SB TWO SIXTY FIVE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS LEYVA.
LEYVA I WILL HI WILK AYE CHIANG.
DO ASAL GLAZER.
MCGUIRE PAN.
PAN AYE.
THE BILL ON CALL THANK YOU.
OUR NEXT WERE MOVING TO CENTER
BRADFORD CENTER BRADFORD ARE YOU
READY.
SB
.
FOUR TWENTY SIX IN A BREAD FOR
PLEASE PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I'M HERE TO PRESENT SB
FOUR TWENTY SIX I FIRST WANT TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE IN YOUR
STAFF FOR THE WORK YOU'VE DONE
ON THIS BILL AND I ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEE.
AMENDMENTS.
IN THE FIRST HALF CENTURY SENSE
I SHOULDSAY IN THE FIRST HALF
CENTURY SINCE THE KERNER.
COMMISSION REPORT ON URBAN
UNREST SELF LOS ANGELES HAS
EXPERIENCE LITTLE ECONOMIC
PROGRESS THE COMMISSION
CONCLUDED THAT A MOCK
INTERTWINING FACTORS.
THE FUNDAMENTAL CAUSES WERE
EVIDENT PERVASIVE DISCRIMINATION
AND SEGREGATION IN EMPLOYMENT
EDUCATION AND HOUSING HAVE
EXCLUDED COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
FROM THE BENEFITS OF ECONOMIC
PROGRESS.
AGAIN A HALF CENTURY LATER AND
THE GAP OF SCHOOL PERFORMANCE
BETWEEN SELF LOS ANGELES IN THE
MOST AFFLUENT NEIGHBORHOODS.
OF LOS ANGELES EXISTS AT THE
SAME LEVEL AS HE DID.
IN.
NINETEEN SIXTY THIS IS
UNACCEPTABLE EDUCATION STANDARD
FOR OUR YOUTH.
THE FUTURE OF OUR SOCIETY
DEPENDS ON THE WILLINGNESS TO
PREPARE ITS YOUTH.
AND THE YOUTH LEADERS TO BECOME
PARTNERS IN SOCIETIES PUBLIC
POLICY IN ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
INITIATIVES.
AND THIS IS WHY I AM PROUD TO
PRESENT SB FOUR TWENTY SIX TO
YOU TODAY.
SB FOUR TWENTY SIX EXPANSIVE ACT.
ACADEMIC AND LEADERSHIP SKILLS
OF HIGH SCHOOL AND COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENTS IN SOUTH LOS
ANGELES AREA -- THE FORMATION OF
THE TIMELY FALLS PROGRAM IN
PUBLIC POLICY AND SOCIAL
ENTREPRENEURSHIP.
HOUSE AT THE MIRMAN TIMELY
AFRICAN AMERICAN POLITICAL AND
ECONOMIC AND AND TO TO TO CAL
STATE DOMINGUEZ HILLS TO TIMELY
FALLS PROGRAM WILL ADDRESS THE
NEED BY PROVIDING EFFECTIVE.
CUTTING EDGE LEADERSHIP IN
EDUCATION TRAINING PROGRAMS
DEVELOP YOUTH WITH LEADERSHIP
SKILLS AND KNOWLEDGE IN THE
FORMATION.
FORMALIZATION THE AFOREMENTIONED
PUBLIC POLICY AND THE
DEVELOPMENT OF LOCAL ECONOMIES
ULTIMATELY WE ARE DOING.
WE'RE DOING WITH THIS BILL IS
PROVIDING YOUTH AND HISTORICALLY
UNDERSERVED AREAS WITH THE
RESOURCES TO BE ABLE TO MEET THE
SOCIAL AND ECONOMIC INTERESTS OF
THEIR COMMUNITIES.
WHILE ALSO PROVIDING THEM WITH
THE SKILLS TO INCREASE THEIR
COMPETITIVENESS TO EVENTUALLY
BOLSTERED THEIR COLLEGE
ENROLLMENT.
IN THE CALIFORNIA A UNIVERSITY
SYSTEM.
ANY SOCIETY REQUIRES GOOD
EDUCATION FOR ALL DESPITE WHERE
THEY LIVE AND HAPPEN TO RESIDE A
GOOD EDUCATION IS THE BACKBONE
OF OUR SOCIETY AND PREPARES OUR
YOUTH FOR THE WORK FORCE.
BUT MOST.
BUT BUT WE MUST FIRST ENSURE
THAT WE HAVE THE PROPER
EDUCATION AND SKILLS NOT ONLY TO
FILL THE NEEDS OF THE WORK FORCE
BUT ALSO IS TO SPUR JOB CREATION
AND ENTREPRENEURSHIP.
AND AGAIN THIS IS WHY SB FORTY
OF THE FOUR TWENTY SIX WILL
PROVIDE THIS THROUGH THE MORE OF
A DIME WE FELLOWSHIP PROGRAM A
WITH ME TO DO AS DR ANTHONY
CHABAD EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
INSTITUTE OURS FOR CLASS REGARD
VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER BRADFORD PLEASE
PROCEED.
HE NEEDS TO YOU NEED TO TURN ON
A DIRT ON OCTOBER THIRD IT'S
IT'S OFTEN ARE YOU [inaudible]
HELLO.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIRMAN I'M
DOCTOR ANTHONY SMILED ON THE
DIRECTOR OF THE MERVIN DONNELLY.
OUR POLITICAL ECONOMIC INSTITUTE.
AND I'D LIKE TO THANK A SENATOR
STEVEN BRADFORD FOR HIS
SPONSORSHIP OF SP.
FOUR TWENTY SIX THE REASON THAT
THE MERVYN TIMELY INSTITUTE
WANTS TO IMPLEMENT THE TIMELY
FELLOWS PROJECT IS TO TRY TO
REVERSE THE TREND.
A MALE AND ROLL MAN IN
UNIVERSITIES IN CALIFORNIA.
THE STUDY WAS JUST RELEASED THIS
FEBRUARY BY THE US DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION ON THE STATUS AND
TRENDS IN EDUCATION OF ETHNIC
AND RACIAL GROUPS.
ARE.
THROUGH.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN AND EVEN THOUGH.
HIGH SCHOOL DROP OUT RATE SO
MOST WHITES LATINOS AND BLACKS
HAVE DECLINED FROM -- TWO
THOUSAND TO TWENTY SIXTEEN
WHITES FROM A SIX POINT NINE TO
FIVE POINT TWO LATINOS FROM.
TWENTY SEVEN POINT EIGHT TO FOUR
POINT SIX ARE SCREWED ME TO
EIGHT POINT SIX AND BLACKS FROM
THIRTEEN POINT ONE TO SIX POINT.
TWO OUR THERE HAS BEEN TWO POINT
THREE MILLION LESS MEN ENROLLED
IN COLLEGE THAN WOMEN OVER THAT
PERIOD OF TIME.
IS LARGELY BECAUSE MALES ARE NOT
GOING TO COLLEGE THE LOWER
SOCIAL ECONOMIC -- DEMOGRAPHY
AND SOURCE OF LOS ANGELES IS AN
IDEAL SOCIAL LABORATORY TO FOCUS
ON THIS POPULATION -- WHERE OF?
MEALS ARE DISAPPEARING FROM
COLLEGES IN CALIFORNIA.
AND WE FEEL THAT IT NEEDS TO BE
STUDIED IN REVERSE THE TIMELY
INSTITUTE WANTS TO PARTNER WITH
HIGH SCHOOLS AND COMMUNITY
COLLEGES -- AROUNDIDENTIFYING
PARTICULARLY YOUNG MEN WHO WERE
NOT ON THE COLLEGE TRACK.
DC STUDENTS VERSUS THE A
STUDENTS AND TO HELP THEM
DEVELOP BOTH LIFE PLANS IN
EDUCATIONAL PLANTS THAT WILL
HELP THEM TRANSITION INTO THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND TO THE
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES.
THIS CURRICULUM INCLUDES
BROADENING -- THEIR PERSPECTIVE --
INTO A GLOBAL PERSPECTIVE BY
ENGAGING AND INTERNATIONAL
EXCURSIONS AND STUDY ABROAD
PROGRAMS WHICH ALLOWS THEM TO
DEVELOP THE SAME WORLD VIEW IS
MANY OF THE INTERNATIONAL
STUDENTS THAT THEY COMPETE
AGAINST.
AND HELP THEM UNDERSTAND WHY
HIGHER EDUCATION IS IMPORTANT TO
THEIR LIFE DEVELOPMENT.
AND SO I ASK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF SP FOUR TWENTY SIX
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL.
SEEN HEARING NONE THE COMMITTEE
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS
CONCERNS.
ALL RIGHT CENTER BRADFORD WHICH
LIKE TO CLOSE.
OUR FOR THE REASONS CLEARLY
STATED I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE THANK YOU SIR CAN SOME
OF THE BILL PLEASE.
THANK YOU SENATOR PAM AND
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ITEM NINE AS BEFORE TWENTY SIX
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS LEYVA AYE
LEYVA AYE WILK CHIANG LASSELL
GLAZER.
GLAZER AYE MCGUIRE PAN PAN AYE.
THANK YOU WILL LEAVE THE BILL ON
CALL THANK YOU SENATOR BRADFORD.
SENATOR ROTH.
I BELIEVE YOU HAVE THREE BILLS
TO PRESENT TODAY.
STARTING WITH SB.
FOUR SIXTY ONE PLEASE PROCEED
WHEN YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS SEE AS YOU WELL KNOW THE
CAL GRANT PROGRAM IN THE STATE
PROVIDES OUR STUDENTS AND
FAMILIES.
WITH MUCH NEEDED FINANCIAL AID.
HOWEVER OF THE STATUTORY
LIMITATION OF FOUR ACADEMIC
YEARS OF FULL TIME ATTENDANCE
CREATES A LARGE BARRIER. FOR
STUDENTS SEEKING TO GRADUATE IN
A FOUR YEAR TIME FRAME.
SOMETIMES FRANKLY IT IS
IMPOSSIBLE TO SIGN UP FOR THE
NECESSARY COURSES DURING THE
REGULAR ACADEMIC TERM AND SUMMER
SCHOOL.
BECOMES A NECESSITY NOT AN
OPTION.
UNFORTUNATELY CAL GRANT DOES NOT
PROVIDE ANY DEDICATED FINANCIAL
AID FOR SUMMER COURSES.
SO THIS BILL WOULD ANSWER THE
DEMONSTRATED NEED BY EXPANDING
THE CAL GRANT PROGRAM TO ALLOW
CAL GRANT A OR B. STUDENTS. TO
RECEIVE AN ADDITIONAL SUMMER CAL
GRANT AWARD FOR UP TO TWO SUMMER
TERMS CAPPED AT NIN UNITS FOR
PURPOSES OF TIMELY COMPLETION OF
A BACCALAUREATE DEGREE.
AT U. C. OR C. ISSUE.
EXPANDING CAL GRANT ELIGIBILITY
TO SUMMER SESSIONS WILL ALLOW
STUDENTS TO AFFORD SUMMER
COURSES REDUCE THEIR FINANCIAL
BURDEN.
AND GRADUATE IN A FASTER TIME
FRAME WITHOUT INCURRING
ADDITIONAL DEBT.
WE HAVE ENGAGE THE CALIFORNIA
STUDENT AID COMMISSION TO ENSURE
pWORKABLE FROM A PROGRAMMATIC
STANDPOINT I HAVE TWO WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT.
ANY CHIU COOPER FROM UC SANTA
BARBARA AND SHOWED NINO FROM CAL
STATE LONG BEACH.
CALIFORNIA STUDENT AID
COMMISSION REPRESENTATIVE IS
ALSO HERE FOR TECHNICAL SUPPORT.
CENTER THANK YOU CENTER ROTH
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT YOU EACH
HAVE TWO MINUTES -- THE ARMENIAN
AS KIM AND I SHARED WITH TO COOK
WINEMA FOURTH THERE ARE YOU LIST
OF CALIFORNIA BARBER SUIT.
THE REASON I'M HERE TODAY IS TO
TESTIFY WHY I BELIEVE THAT THIS
COMMITTEE SAID PASSABLE.
FOR SIX ONE WHICH WAS AUTHORED
BY SEN RICHARD ROTH AND WHICH
USED EXTEND THE CONTRACT THIS
SUMMER.
ALASTOR SYLLABLE PASSED TO THIS
COMMITTEE AND IT ACTUALLY
PASADENA ADAM SUPPORT.
NOW THE REASON I BELIEVE A
PASTOR THIS COMMITTEE WAS
BECAUSE THIS COMMITTEE BELIEVE
AND SAW THAT THERE'S SOME
PROBLEMS OFTEN THE PROBLEMS
INHERENT IN THE HIGHER EDUCATION
SYSTEM.
IT'S A PROBLEM THAT THE MAJORITY
OF FOR SOME REASON BLACK AND
BROWN PAPA RECIPIENTS AND ROLLED
THE UC DID NOT GRADUATE WITH
THEM.
IT'S A PROBLEM THAT CALIFORNIA'S
GOING TO EXPERIENCE A ONE TO ONE
MILLION COLLEGE GRADUATION GIFTS
ABOUT THE YEAR. TWENTY THIRTY
FOR THE WHAT'S THE PROBLEM THAT
WE KEEP ON SAYING THAT OUR
INSTITUTIONS OF FOR INSTITUTIONS
WHEN THE ACTUAL REALITY SUCCESS
TO GRADUATION.
NOW I HAVE TO WORK AT THE USES
BEACON AT TRADE OFFICE AND TO
THE REASON IS THAT OF THE POP
AND WE DID A CALCULATION.
WHAT WE FOUND WAS THAT IT WAS TO
RECEIVE THE FULL POWER GRANT AS
WELL AS THE INSTITUTIONAL GRANT
IT'S STILL NOT COULD BE ENOUGH
TO COVER THE TUITION CAP SPECIES
WITH SOME COURSES?
AT THIS BUT WE HAVEN'T START
COUNTING THE COST OF HOUSING THE
COST OF FOOD TO THE COST OF
TEXTBOOKS.
SO I HAVE TO SIT THERE AND TELL
THE STUDENTS HAVE TO SAY LOOK
I'M SORRY -- THAT YOUR CLASS
THAT YOU NEEDED TO GET INTIMATE
WAS OVER AND ROLLED OR I'M SORRY
THAT'S HAD A FAMILY EMERGENCY
AND I TAKE A LEAVE OF ABSENCE
I'M SORRY THAT YOU SWITCH TO
MAJOR.
LIKE THE MAJORITY OF STUDENTS IN
CALIFORNIA BUT YOU CAN HAVE TO
TAKE ON MORE DEBT.
YOU NEVER MISS OUT ON FUTURE
EARNINGS BECAUSE YOU CAN AFFORD
TO GRADUATE ON TIME YOU CAN FOR
SOME COURSES.
NOW THERE ARE THAT I'M THE ONE
WHO HAS TO TELL STUDENTS THIS
BECAUSE THE LAST TWO YEARS AGO I
WAS ACTUALLY THAT STUDENT.
AND IT'S BETTER TO GET MY FULL
PROGRESS BY ME TO GET MY FORCE
TO SNOW GRANT.
I STILL HAVE TO TAKE A LOOK.
I STILL AT TWO FIFTY DOLLARS A
WEEK AND I STILL HAD TO GET TO
SEE SOME SCHOOLS GOSSIPS TO SO
THAT I COULD AFFORD EIGHT UNITS
OF SOME COURSES.
DOUBLE AS I AM HEARING WITH
STUDENTS OF CALIFORNIA HERE AND
THE REASON WE'RE HERE IS BECAUSE
WE BELIEVE THAT THIS COMMITTEE
CAN HELP US GET ONE STEP CLOSER
TO FIX THESE FUNDAMENTAL
PROBLEMS INHERENT IN HIGHER
EDUCATION.
THAT'S WHY WE ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
AS YOU DID LAST YEAR LET YOU
COLLEAGUES GLASSER BECAUSE I
BELIEVE THAT MUCH LIKE THEN YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THAT WE NEED TO
FIX FINANCIAL AID.
THANKS VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU WELL SAID NEXT WITNESS.
HELLO EVERYBODY MY NAME IS JONI
NO ON THE CHAIR FOR THE COUNTIES
STUDENTS ASSOCIATION -- KERN
STUDENT ACTUALLY GRADUATE
STUDENT AT CALIFORNIA STAE
UNIVERSITY LONG BEACH -- BUT
ALSO A JUST FINISH GRADUATING --
WITH I'M ALUM FROM FROM
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY LONG
BEACH AND DEFINITELY A
FINANCIALLY RECIPIENT CAL GRANT
RECIPIENTS.
BUT I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CONCERT SOON SO STATION AND
REPRESENTING NEARLY HALF A
MILLION STUDENTS -- FIRST I'D
LIKE TO THINK THE YOU SEE
SENATOR ROTH AND THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA STUDENT
ASSOCIATION -- FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP ON THIS BILL -- YOU
MAY BE FAMILIAR BUT SEASON SAY
HAS BEEN REALLY INTERESTED IN
PAIN COMPREHENSIVE FINANCIAL AID
REFORM.
AND SOME OF THAT IS SOME SOME OF
THIS ACTUALLY FITS DIRECTLY IN
LINE WITH THAT.
SO ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE'RE
WE'RE FOCUSED ON IS ADDRESSING
SOME OF THE ISSUES WITH THE
OVERALL COST OF ATTENDANCE --
MORE IT GETTING RID OF
ELIGIBILITY REQUIREMENTS THAT
ARE UNNECESSARY AND RESTRICTIVE
AN EXCLUSIVE.
WE'RE ALSO INTERESTED IN.
DEFINITELY INCREASING MORE
ACCESS FOR STUDENTS LOW INCOME
STUDENTS HAVE A SUMMER CAL GRANT --
FIRST MANY STUDENTS AND SOON
LIKE MYSELF -- I'M IT
TRANSFORMATION EIGHTY COLLEGE --
YOU KNOW ALTHOUGH IT'S SUPPOSED
TO BE A TWO YEAR PLAN I WANT TO
TRANSFER AND LOTS OF TIMES IT
TAKES A LITTLE BIT MORE BEYOND
THOSE TWO YEARS.
AND FOR A STUDENT LIKE MYSELF.
IN TAKING ALL THE COURSES THAT
WERE RECOMMENDED -- I STILL WAS
NOT ABLE TO GRADUATE WITHIN
THOSE TWO YEARS AND QUITE
FRANKLY AS A NONTRADITIONAL
STUDENT HAVING MEDICAL EXPENSES
WORK EXPENSES ARE OF HAVING TO
WORK -- AND THE COST OF
EDUCATION NOT BEING SUBSIDIZED
IS THIS SUMMER SUMMER CLASSES
WERE CUT KIND OF OUT OF THE
QUESTION JUST NOT REALLY AN
OPTION FOR ME CAN AFFORD IT --
SO.
THE BILL LIKE THIS -- INCREASING
THE THAT ADDITIONAL GRANTED TO
HELP STUDENTS TAKE ON THOSE
SUMMER CLASSES CAN REALLY -- IT
REALLY MAKES A BIG DIFFERENCE IN
A BIG IMPACT O ON CALIFORNIA
THE ECONOMY OF CALIFORNIA -- BUT
MOST IMPORTANTLY I WHAT I REALLY
BELIEVE IS THAT.
FROM MY EXPERIENCE WITH I HAD TO
OFTEN SEE MY CLASSMATES.
GRADUATE A LITTLE BIT WHAT WILL
COME FOR A LITTLE BIT MORE
AFFLUENT BACKGROUNDS BUT I SAW
THEM GRADUATE A YEAR BEFORE ME
SO I HAD TO TAKE THAT ACTUALLY.
THAT EXTRA YEAR AT THAT
CALIFORNIA'S LEADERS LONG BEACH --
AFTER I HAD TRANSFERRED.
AND I THINK THOSE INSTANCES ARE
IT'S NOT UNIQUE TO MYSELF MANY
STUDENTS ARE ALSO GOING THROUGH
THE SAME ISSUES -- BUT TIME.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ZERO IN SUPPORT OF THIS.
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS IN SUPPORT.
JAKE BREMNER ON BEHALF OF THE
CAMPAIGN FOR COLLEGE OPPORTUNITY
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
MANY RODRIGUEZ ON BEHALF OF THE
EDUCATION TRUST WEST IN SUPPORT.
MORE SECONDS AWESOME BEHALF OF
THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS IN STRONG SUPPORT.
MAGGIE RIGHT WITH CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY WE DON'T HAVE A
LETTER ON FILE BUT WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MARIO GUERRERO ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT.
ALEX BEFORE UC STUDENT
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG SUPPORT.
KALRA PHASE YOU SEE SINICIZATION
STRONG SUPPORT.
FROM MONGOLIA YOU FEELING
UNDERGRADUATE SUFFICIENT IN UC
STUDENT ASSOCIATION STRONGLY.
FOR THANK YOU ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
DOES ANYBODY HAVE ANY COMMENTS
CONCERNS QUESTIONS.
MOVE THE BILL SERRATO JUDGE
CLOSE THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR YOU
KNOW WE SPEAK IT HERE ABOUT THE
CALIFORNIA DREAM AND I THINK ALL
OF US HAVE EXPERIENCED IT.
BUT OUR STUDENTS CAN BE PART OF
THAT CALIFORNIA DREAM IF THEY
CAN'T GET ACROSS THE FINISH LINE.
SO FRANKLY WE MUST PROVIDE THEM
WITH ALL THE RESOURCES NECESSARY
IN ORDER TO GET THERE.
IF FAR CALIFORNIA STUDENTS ARE
TRULY OUR FUTURE IN THE STATE
AND WE KNOW THAT THEY ARE.
I THINK WE OWE THAT TO THEM SO I
RESPECTFULLY AS FEAR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER ROB THE BILL'S
BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR PAN MA'AM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ITEM ELEVEN SB FOUR SIXTY ONE
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS LEYVA.
LEAVE THE AYE WILK CHIANG TO
WRESTLE GLAZER GLAZER AYE
MCGUIRE PAN.
CAN I THE BILL ON CALL CENTER
ROTH YOU HAVE SB.
FIVE FIFTY FOUR THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR OF MEMBERS.
AS A SOME OF YOU KNOW BACK IN
NOVEMBER OF TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN OF THE SENATE HELD AN
INFORMATIONAL HEARING ON CAREER
TECHNICAL EDUCATION.
SELECT COMMITTEE THAT -- I AM
PRIVILEGED TO CHAIR AND AT THAT
HEARING WE HEARD FROM MANY
STAKEHOLDERS ON THE NEED FOR
POLICY CHANGES AND INCREASED
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES TO IMPROVE
THE OUTCOME. FOR PARTICIPATING
MINOR AN ADULT STUDENTS ENROLLED
IN CT WE WERE ALSO MADE AWARE
THAT 30% OF WORKERS IN THE
UNITED STATES WILL NEED TO
CHANGE JOBS OR UPGRADE THEIR
SKILLS SIGNIFICANTLY BY.
TWENTY THIRTY AND 65% OF PRIMARY
SCHOOL STUDENTS TODAY WILL HOLD
JOBS IN THE FUTURE THAT SIMPLY
DO NOT EXIST TODAY.
ACCORDING TO RESEARCHERS
CALIFORNIA WILL BE SHORT ABOUT
ONE MILLION EMPLOYEES WITH
BACHELOR'S DEGREE IS AND PERHAPS
MORE OF MORE SIGNIFICANCE TO
THIS PROGRAM.
ROUGHLY ONE THIRD OF NEW JOBS
CREATED IN THE STATE WILL
REQUIRE SOME TRAINING BEYOND
HIGH SCHOOL.
BUT LESS THAN A FOUR YEAR DEGREE.
SO TO ADDRESS THESE NEEDS WE'RE
GOING TO NEED TO ENSURE THAT OUR
C. T. PROGRAMS ARE AGILE THAT
THEIR COLLABORATIVE THAT THEY
ARE INCLUSIVE AND THAT THEY ARE.
EFFECTIVE.
WITH REGARD TO THIS BILL SENATE
BILL FIVE FIVE FOUR I WOULD LIKE
TO BEGIN BY ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEES TECHNICAL AMENDMENT.
DESCRIBED ON PAGE FIVE OF THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS.
IN SUMMER THE BILL INTENDS ON
PROVIDING AN ADULT HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENT WITH THE SAME BENEFIT
AFFORDED TO MINOR HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS WHO WISH TO TOOL AND
ROLE IN A COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
RESEARCH BOTH NATIONALLY AND IN
CALIFORNIA'S DOCUMENTED THAT
DUAL ENROLLMENT IS A POWERFUL
STRATEGY FOR INCREASING COLLEGE
SUCCESS.
AND AFFORDABILITY FOR LOW INCOME
STUDENTS WE ALSO KNOW THAT OVER
85% OF THE STUDENTS ARE PEOPLE
OF COLOR.
WITH LATINOS MAKING UP 64%.
WHEN IT COMES TO ATTENDING A
POST SECONDARY EDUCATION
PROGRAMS SUCH AS AN ASSOCIATE
DEGREE PROGRAM OR A BACHELOR'S
DEGREE PROGRAM?
ONLY 2% OF THESE ADULTS STUDENTS
TAKE PART.
WE NEED TO DO BETTER.
THIS BILL PROVIDES A STREAMLINED
APPROACH FOR HIGH SCHOOL
EQUIVALENCY STUDENTS TO CAN
CURRENTLY IN ROLE IN COMMUNITY
COLLEGE BY SIMPLIFYING THE
ENROLLMENT PROCESS AND IN SOME
CASES WAVING TUITION.
AND FEES I HAVE WITH ME TODAY --
MATT MARIN DIRECTOR OF ADULT
EDUCATION HIGH SCHOOL
PARTNERSHIPS THE CHAFEE COLLEGE
AND BRIANNA BRUHNS DIRECTOR OF
POLICY AND ADVOCACY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA EDGE.
COALITION.
THANK YOU CENTER ROTH WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT YOU EACH HAVE TWO
MINUTES.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS BRIANNA FRIENDS AND THEN THE
DOCTOR POLICY NOT BECAUSE HE FOR
THE CALIFORNIA I'D COALITION.
THE IT'S COALITION IS A
NONPARTISAN COALITION OF
BUSINESS LABOR EDUCATION WORK
FORCE AND SOCIAL JUSTICE
ORGANIZATIONS AND WITH A PROUD
SPONSOR IS I'VE SB.
FIVE FIVE FOUR AS THE SENATOR
MENTIONED RESEARCH SHOWS THAT
DUAL ENROLLMENT PROGRAMS
INCREASE ACCESS TO POST EX POST
SECONDARY EDUCATION AND TRAINING.
THESE PROGRAMS IMPROVE SUCCESS
FOR ALL STUDENTS PARTICULARLY
YOUNG MEN OF COLOR LOW INCOME
AND FIRST GENERATIONS STUDENTS.
ONE EXAMPLE OUR INSTITUTION GP
COLLEGE OPERATED AN INTERNAL
DUAL ENROLLMENT PILOT PROGRAM
OFFERING ADULT HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS ENROLLED IN HIGH SCHOOL
DIPLOMA OR HIGH SCHOOL
EQUIVALENCY COURSES THE
OPPORTUNITY TO DUEL AND TRULY
INVOLVED IN COMMUNITY COLLEGE
COURSES.
THE SUCCESSES SEEN WITHIN THIS
PILOT ENCOURAGE AT THAT ADDS TO
WORK WITH SENATOR ROTH TO EXTEND
TO ENROLLMENT OPPORTUNITIES TO
ADULT SCHOOL STUDENTS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE.
HERE TO SPEAK TO THE SUCCESS OF
THAT PROGRAM ITS POTENTIAL IS
DOCTOR MATTHEW MORE IN OF TV
COLLEGE AND I'LL YIELD THE REST
OF MY TIME TO HIM.
THANK YOU PLEASE PROCEED THANK
YOU GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
THANK OU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK THIS MORNING MY NAME IS
MATTHEW MARIN AND I'M THE
DIRECTOR OF DISTANCE EDUCATION
ADULT EDUCATION HIGH SCHOOL
PARTNERSHIP SUCH A FEW COLLEGE.
THANK YOU -- SENATOR LEYVA FOR
YOUR WORK IN OUR DISTRICT TO
SUPPORT HIGHER EDUCATION.
ORIGINAL SCAN CONDUCTED BY TV
COLLEGE AND THE ADULT SCHOOLS OF
THE WEST AND ADULT EDUCATION
CONSORTIUM FOUND THAT BETWEEN
TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN AND TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN ONLY TWO
HUNDRED AND NINE OUT OF THE
SEVENTEEN THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED
AND THREE ADULTS SCHOOL
ENROLLEES IN THE CHAFEE COLLEGE
SERVICE STEP.
DISTRICT ENROLLED IN A CHIEF YOU
COLLEGE CREDIT COURSE.
OF THESE MOST FOR ESL ENROLLEES.
SO THE NUMBER OF HIGH SCHOOL
EQUIVALENCY AND HIGH SCHOOL
DIPLOMA STUDENTS WERE FAR BELOW
1%.
THIS PAINTED A DARK PICTURE OF
COLLEGE TRANSITION FOR THOSE IN
OUR COMMUNITY WHO ARE MOST
LIKELY TO REMAIN IN POVERTY.
WITHOUT IN ATTEMPTING TO IMPROVE
ON THIS CRISIS OF TRANSITION
CHAFEE COLLEGE AND THE ADULT
SCHOOLS IN ITS SERVICE DISTRICT
EMBARKED ON A RADICAL STRATEGY.
WE COLOCATED CREDIT BEARING C.
T. E. AND COLLEGE TRANSITION
COURSES ADULT SCHOOL CAMPUSES.
AFTER ONE SEMESTER VERY LOW
ENROLLMENT AMONG HSE AND HSE
STUDENTS THE ADULT SCHOOL STAFF
EXPRESSED THAT MANY WERE NOT
ENROLLING BECAUSE THEY WERE
INTIMIDATED BY THE COMPLEXITY OF
MATRICULATION.
ASSESSMENT AND THE PERSONAL
IDENTIFYING INFORMATION REQUIRED
TO OBTAIN FINANCIAL AID SUCH AS
INCOME VERIFICATION AND
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS INFORMATION.
IN CALIFORNIA SPECIAL PART TIME
ADMIT DUAL ENROLLMENT IS A TOOL
THAT COLLEGES USED TO ENROLL
HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS TUITION
FREE.
WITHOUT REQUIRING FINANCIAL AID
APPLICATIONS INCOME VERIFICATION
RESIDENCY INFORMATION AND A TV
COLLEGE ASSESSMENT.
EAGER TO OVERCOME THE BARRIERS
OF THE PREVIOUS SEMESTERS
ENROLLMENT CHALLENGES IN SPRING
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN CHAFEE
COLLEGE CREATED A STRUCTURE DUAL
ENROLLMENT PROGRAM FOR THE ADULT
HSE AND HSE STUDENTS.
USING THE SPECIAL PART TIME
ADMIN ENROLLMENT PROCESS.
THE PROGRAM SUBSTANTIALLY
INCREASE ENROLLMENT FROM THESE
POPULATIONS WAS ADORED BY THE
ADULT SCHOOL ADMINISTRATORS AND
RECEIVE TREMENDOUS INTEREST FROM
OTHER COLLEGES AND ADULTS
SCHOOLS.
THE SPECIAL ADMIT PROCESS
ENCOURAGED A STRONG PARTNERSHIP
OF SHARED CULTURE IN PROGRAM
OWNERSHIP BETWEEN THE COLLEGE
AND THE ADULT SCHOOL.
BY GIVING ADULT SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS OR THEIR
DESIGNEES LOCAL CONTROL OVER
ENROLLMENT IN THE PROGRAM
THROUGH THE REQUIREMENT OF THEIR
SIGNATURE.
ADDITIONALLY STUDENTS WERE NOT
REQUIRED TO COMPLETE THE
INVASIVE FINANCIAL AID
APPLICATION PROCESS A KEY
BARRIER DISCOURAGING STUDENTS
FROM ENROLLING.
THE COLLEGE AND THE ADULT SCHOOL
ADVERTISE THE CLASSES FREE HELD
AN APPLICATION WORKSHOP IN
ORIENTATION AND WE ENROLL THE
STUDENTS THE FOCUS WAS SUPPORT
AS OPPOSED TO INK IDENTITY
VERIFICATION.
AFTER THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE
NOTIFY TV COLLEGE THAT A SPECIAL
ADMIT STATUS ONLY APPLIED TO
HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS ENROLLED IN
HIGH SCHOOLS.
AS OPPOSED TO ADULT SCHOOL HIGH
SCHOOL DIPLOMA STUDENTS.
WE DISCONTENT WE JUST CONTINUE
TO SPECIAL ADMIT ADULT SCHOOL
PROGRAM.
THE COLLEGE HAS NOW HALTED ITS
CREDIT BEARING TO ONE ROMAN
ADULT EDUCATION PROGRAM DUE TO
THESE BARRIERS.
SB FIVE FIFTY FOUR WILL MAKE A
PATHWAY POSSIBLE TO RESTART THIS
IMPORTANT WORK AT CHAFEE AND
OTHER COLLEGES IT WILL ALSO
PLACE CALIFORNIA AS THE LEADER
IN PROVIDING AN EQUITABLE
EXPANSION OF DUAL ENROLLMENT. TO
INCLUDE ADULTS AS WELL AS
TRADITIONALLY H. HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT.
CHECK BREMNER ON BEHALF OF THE
CAMPAIGN FOR COLLEGE OPPORTUNITY
IN SUPPORT.
TAYLOR MYERS FOR CALIFORNIA
COMPETES IN STRONG SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING DON CAP KEY MCCUE
CAP CAN ASSOCIATE SOME HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL FOR ADULT
EDUCATION IN CALIFORNIA DOLE
EDUCATION ADMINISTRATORS
SUFFICIENT BOTH ENTITIES
REPRESENTING K. TWELVE DOT
SCHOOLS IN STRONG SUPPORT.
MATT PATTON CALIFORNIA
AGRICULTURAL TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU YOU DIGITAL WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT.
ANY OPPOSITION.
SEEING MERRY MEN WILL GO BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS OR CONCERNS.
MOVE THE BILL SENATE ROTH WHICH
LIKE TO CLOSE THIS RESPECTFULLY
AS FOR AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
ITEM SEVENTEEN SB FIVE FIFTY FOR
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS LEYVA.
LEYVA AYE WILK CHIANG TO WRESTLE
GLAZER GLAZER AYE MCGUIRE PAN
PAN AYE.
BELIEVE THE BILL ON CALL THANK
YOU.
ALL RIGHT SENATOR RON TO HAVE
ONE LEFT SB FIVE SIXTY THREE
PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR OF WANT TO START
BY ACCEPTING ALL OF THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THAT ARE
SUMMARIZED BEGINNING ON PAGE SIX
OF THE STAFF ANALYSIS AND
pDRIFTED IN DETAIL ON THE
ATTACHMENT.
I BELIEVE THAT THE COMMITTEE
STAFF IS DISTRIBUTED TO YOU. TO
BE CLEAR I WILL SPEAKING TO THE
SPEAKING TO THE CONTENTS OF THE
BILL AS AMENDED PER THE STAFF'S
RECOMMENDATIONS.
THIS BILL SEEKS TO ENHANCE THE
EXISTING COLLEGE AND CAREER
ACCESS PATHWAYS PROGRAM WHICH
WAS ESTABLISHED BY AB TWO EIGHT
EIGHT SOME REMEMBER HOLDEN IN.
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN THE CAP IS
A SIX YEAR DUAL ENROLLMENT PILOT
PROGRAM DESIGNED TO INCREASE
COLLEGE ACCESS BY BRINGING
COLLEGE COURSES. TO HIGH SCHOOL
CAMPUSES VIA PATHWAY AGREEMENTS
BETWEEN THE SCHOOL AND COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICTS.
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
CHANCES OFFICE IS REQUIRED TO
PREPARE AND AN EVALUATION OF
THIS CAP PROGRAM BY JANUARY TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY ONE INCLUDING
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR IMPROVEMENT.
BASED ON FEEDBACK ALREADY
PROVIDED BY CAP PARTICIPANTS IT
IS CLEAR THAT THE PROGRAM HAS
YET TO UNLOCK.
ITS FULL POTENTIAL THE NUMBER OF
CAP PARTICIPANTS IS FEWER THAN
ANTICIPATED AND THE AVAILABILITY
OF STUDENT FOCUS SERVICES.
SPECIFICALLY ADMISSIONS
ASSISTANCE ACADEMIC COUNSELING
AN OUT REACH IS LACKING.
THIS BILL SIX TO ONE ENSURE THAT
THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE
EVALUATION IS AS HELPFUL AS
POSSIBLE TO EXISTING AND
PROSPECTIVE CAP PARTICIPANTS.
AND TWO DEMONSTRATES THE VALUE
THAT EFFECTIVE AND FULLY FUNDED
CAP AGREEMENTS BRING. TO
COMMUNITIES IN THE STATE.
THE BILL ESSENTIALLY HAS THREE
COMPONENTS THE FIRST COMPONENT
WOULD EXTEND THE CAP PROGRAM FOR
AN ADDITIONAL FIVE YEARS UNTIL
JANUARY. TWO THOUSAND TWENTY
SEVEN THE SECOND COMPONENT WOULD
ENHANCE THE CURRENT CAP SUMMARY
REPORT ROOF WHICH IS REQUIRED
FROM THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE.
BY INCLUDING SEVEN NEW
ARAMETERS FOR PROGRAM
IMPROVEMENT AMONG THOSE SEVEN
ARE WAYS TO REDUCE PAPER BASED
REGISTRATIONS IMPROVING THE
TRACKING AND MONITORING OF
STUDENT PARTICIPANTS. THREE
DEMONSTRATING BEST PRACTICES FOR
SUCCESSFUL CAP PARTNERSHIPS
STATEWIDE.
THE THIRD COMPONENT WOULD
ESTABLISH A CAP COMPETITIVE
GRANT PROGRAM THE GRANTS WILL BE
ADMINISTERED BY THE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE AND AWARDED TO THREE CAP
PARTNERSHIPS IN THE STATE ONE IN
THE NORTH ONE IN THE CENTRAL
PART OF THE STATE AND ONE IN.
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA TO BE
DETERMINED DETERMINED.
THAT DEMONSTRATE THE PROPER MIX
OF SUPPORT SERVICES FOR ACADEMIC
SUCCESS STUDENT PARTICIPATION
SUSTAINABILITY AND EDUCATOR
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT. TO
PROVIDE GREATER DETAIL IN THIS
BILL I HAVE WITH ME DR BRIAN
REESE WHO IS THE PRESIDENT.
OF NORCO COLLEGE.
SENATE ROTH PLEASE PROCEED THANK
YOU VERY MUCH -- FOR FOR HAVING
ME HERE THANK YOU -- CENTER TO
LABOR FOR CHAIR OF THE COMMITTEE
THANK YOU TO COMMITTEE MEMBERS
THANK YOU CENTER OFF AND STAFF
FOR HELPING WORK ON THIS.
A SINNER OFF MITCHELL MY NAME'S
BOB BRYAN RESTOCKED RECENT
PRESIDENT OF NORCO COLLEGE -- A
COMMUNITY COLLEGE IN THE INLAND
EMPIRE -- AND WE'RE SO PLEASED
TO BE WORKING ON THIS BILL -- AS
YOU ALL KNOW THE STATE
LEGISLATURES BEEN WORKING ON
BILLS FOR A FOR A LONG HISTORY
TO HELP STUDENTS HAVE ACCESS TO
COLLEGE EDUCATION WHILE THEIR
ROE IN HIGH SCHOOL AND SB.
FIVE SIXTY THREE IS ONE OF THE
BUILDING BLOCKS IT ADDS TO THAT --
THAT LONG HISTORY -- IT HELPS
REMOVE SOME BUREAUCRATIC HURDLES
THAT WE FOUND IN THE PROCESS AND
IT'S GOING TO HELP -- ADD SOME
WRAPAROUND SERVICES WE REALLY
NEED TO FIGURE OUT THE THE THIS
IDEA OF WRAPAROUND SERVICES --
FOR THESE -- THESE PROGRAMS --
WE'VE BEEN -- WORKING ON THESE
SERVICES FOR QUITE AWHILE AND
THE REALLY ESSENTIAL AT IF YOU
IF YOU WERE TO THINK UP TRYING
TO PUT A HIGH SCHOOL IN A
COMMUNITY COLLEGE TOGETHER THEY
DON'T YOUR SINK RIGHT UP -- HIGH
SCHOOLS HAVE THEIR OWN KIND OF
BUREAUCRATIC SYSTEMS WEIGH EVEN
ROLLING STUDENTS SUPPORTING
STUDENTS COMMUNITY COLLEGES HAVE
THEIRS AND IT'S DIFFICULT TO PUT
THE TWO TOGETHER.
AND SO IN ORDER TO PUT THEM
TOGETHER YOU NEED TO PROVIDE
SOME WRAPAROUND SERVICES -- IN
THE PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN THE TWO
AND ONCE YOU DO THAT A SUCCESS
RATES REALLY START TO INCREASE
LET ME GIVE YOU.
A QUICK EXAMPLE OF THIS.
IN THE EARLY ARE TO THOUSANDS WE
STARTED OFFERING COLLEGE COURSES
TO JFK HIGH SCHOOL TO SMALL HIGH
SCHOOL.
IN -- IN NORCO.
AND BY TWO THOUSAND EIGHT WE HAD
ONE STUDENT GRADUATE.
ARE.
THEY WOULD THEY WALKED ACROSS
THE STAGE AT THE HIGH SCHOOL
DIPLOMA AND AT THE SAME TIME
THEY GOT THERE A A DEGREE SO
WHILE THEY WERE IN HIGH SCHOOL
THEY FINISHED THE ASSOCIATES
DEGREE.
IN TWO THOUSAND NINE WE HAD ZERO
STUDENTS DO THAT. TWO THOUSAND
TEN WE HAD TO STUDENTS WALK
ACROSS THE STAGE GET THEIR A A
DEGREE AT THE SAME TIME. TWO
THOUSAND ELEVEN ONE STUDENT TWO
THOUSAND TWELVE ZERO STUDENTS
TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN FOR
STUDENTS TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN
ONE STUDENT. TWO THOUSAND FIVE
FIFTEEN WE HAD FIVE STUDENTS AND
THAT'S THE YEAR WE GOT A GRANT.
AND ADDED WRAPAROUND SERVICES
INTO THIS PROCESS.
BY TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN ITS
STATE AT FIVE STUDENTS.
BUT BY TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
THE WRAPAROUND STE -- SERVICES
STARTED TO KICK IN AND EIGHTEEN
STUDENTS WALKED ACROSS THE STAGE
HAVING RECEIVED THEIR A A DEGREE
WHILE THEY WERE IN HIGH SCHOOL.
LAST YEAR I WAS AT THE
GRADUATION TWENTY SEVEN STUDENTS
WALKED ACROSS THE STAGE GETTING
AN A A DEGREE.
AND I SPOKE WITH THE PRINCIPAL
THIS MORNING WE'RE ON TRACK TO
HAVING THIRTY STUDENTS THIS YEAR
WALK ACROSS THE STAGE AND THAT'S
A SMALL HIGH SCHOOL THERE'S ONLY
ABOUT A HUNDRED AND SEVENTY FIVE
GRADUATE SO LAST YEAR. 15% OF
THE STUDENTS WALKED ACROSS THE
STAGE FROM THAT HIGH SCHOOL WITH
AN A A DEGREE.
AND FORTY EIGHT ALMOST HALF OF
THE STUDENTS FINISH THEIR
FRESHMAN YEAR WHILE THEY WERE IN
HIGH SCHOOL.
NOW IF YOU THINK ABOUT THE COST
SAVINGS TO THOSE FAMILIES AND
WE'RE WHEN WE'RE WORKING IN A
LOW SCS COMMUNITY.
IF ALL THE STUDENTS WOULD FINISH
HER EIGHT AGREE AND THEIR
FRESHMAN YEAR WHILE THEY WERE IN
HIGH SCHOOL.
HAD DECIDED INSTEAD TO DO THOUGH --
DO THEIR STUDIES AT THE CSU IT
WOULD COST THEM THREE POINT
THREE MILLION DOLLARS
COLLECTIVELY THEY SAVED THREE
POINT THREE MILLION DOLLARS.
IF ALL OF TEM HAD DID STATE
GOING TO SPELL UC'S IT WOULD
COST HIM FOUR POINT FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS TO DO THE WORK THAT THEY
DID WHILE THEY WERE IN HIGH
SCHOOL IN THIS IS FREE EDUCATION
NOW WE'VE EXPANDED THAT PROGRAM
TO ELEVEN HIGH SCHOOLS.
OKAY AND OUT WE HAVE ELEVEN
PEOPLE WORKING ON THAT WHO ARE
ALL IN GRANTS WE NEED TO FIGURE
OUT AS A SYSTEM HOW WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE.
HOW WE'RE GONNA WHAT KIND OF
WRAP AROUND SERVICES WE NEED TO
PROVIDE IN THE I THINK THIS BILL
REALLY WILL HELP US DO THAT
THANK YOU?
EXCELLENT GREAT STATISTICS
OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL. EIGHTY ONE ON THE
COMMITTEE YES SENATOR PAN -- SO
APPRECIATE THOUGH FOR YOU TEND
TO AND BRING FOR THE BILL I
UNDERSTAND THAT -- WHEN THE
QUESTIONS RAISED AN ANALYSIS WAS
THE ISSUE ABOUT WELL KNOWN THE
EVALUATION ISN'T TAKING PLACE
THE LETTER I GOT THE ALSO THE
POINT THAT HEY WE KNOW THINGS
THAT WERE?
HELLO CAN MAKE BETTER.
EVEN BEFORE THAT AND BUT I JUST
IN TERMS OF SPEAKING TO THE
EVALUATION NOW WE'RE EXTENDING
THE PROGRAM LONGER.
IS THERE STILL REQUIREMENTS THEN
FOR THE COMMITTEE CALL
CHANCELLOR TO THEN PRODUCE AN
EVALUATION OF THE I GUESS NEW
UPDATED VERSION NOW WITH THE
CHANGES THAT YOU PUT IN PLACE IN
THIS BILL.
SO ARE WE GOING TO DISSIPATE --
BECAUSE THERE'S A SUNSET DATE
UNDERSTAND FOR THE MEN AND SO --
I DID I ALSO A BE SURE THE
EVALUATION IS WELL I'M GOING
IT'S OF THESE YOU'LL BE SLIGHTLY
DIFFERENT VALUATION BECAUSE
MAKING SOME CHANGES NOW MID
STREAM.
JULY TWELFTH JULY ONE TWENTY
TWENTY FOR A FOR THE REPORT -- A
REPORTER'S RECORD OKAY ALL RIGHT
SO I CLARIFIED TO BE SURE THAT
WE WILL GET EVALUATION OF THE
NOW MODIFIED VERSION OF OF THIS
OF THIS PROGRAM [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
BECAUSE CENTER PANEL JUDGE MOVE
THE BILL I WOULD LIKE TO MOVE
THE BILL THANK YOU SENATE ROTH
WAS THAT CLOSE I MEAN I I THINK
I NEED.
TO ADD TO MY RESPONSE TO TO MY
COLLEAGUES QUESTIONS THERE IS A
REPORT DUE IN.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AT THAT WE
DON'T CHANGE THAT DATE AND THE
PILOT PROGRAM REPORT IS DUE BY
JULY ONE TWENTY TWENTY FOUR
ACCORDING TO THE HOUSE.
AND THE MANAGER I DON'T THINK I
COULD HAVE -- CLOSED ANY BETTER
THAN DR REISS DID SO -- AGREED
TO STAND ON THAT RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE VERY GOOD
THOSE ARE GREAT STATISTICS VERY
PROUD OF WHAT WE WANT TO HEAR.
I'M SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
I AM EIGHTEEN SB FIVE SIXTY
THREE THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS LEYVA.
LEAVE THE AYE WILK CHAIN TO
WRESTLE GLAZER.
PLEASE THEIR AYE MCGUIRE PAN PAN
AYE.
WE'LL LEAVE THAT ON CALL THANK
YOU SENATOR ROTH THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR COLLEAGUES THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE YOUR WELCOME
SENATOR MONEY COME ON DOWN.
THANK YOU SB.
FOUR SIXTY SEVEN PLEASE PROCEED
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
AS THE NUMBER OF CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS AND FOOD IN
SECURITY CONTINUES TO RISE.
THE CSU AND YOU SEE HAVE AN
OBLIGATION TO PROVIDE
PROSPECTIVE STUDENTS WITH
ACCURATE ESTIMATES FOR THE COST
OF ATTENDING THEIR SCHOOLS.
AND THE METHODOLOGY THEY USED TO
DETERMINE THOSE ESTIMATES.
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN THE
LEGISLATURE PASSED ASSEMBLY BILL
NINE NINETY AUTHORED BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RODRIGUEZ WHICH NOW
REQUIRES THE C. ISSUE AND YOU
SEE THE POST ON THEIR INTERNET
WEBSITES.
HE ESTIMATED MARKET COST OF AN
OFF CAMPUS ONE BEDROOM APARTMENT
WELL THIS IS A GOOD FIRST STEP.
PROSPECTIVE STUDENTS COULD
BENEFIT MORE FROM COMPREHENSIVE
INFORMATION ON THE EXPENSES THEY
WILL FACE WHEN THE IN RURAL.
SB FOUR SIXTY SEVEN REQUIRES THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY AND
REQUEST THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA. TO PLACE ON THEIR
WEBSITES THE CONFERENCE OF COST
OF ATTENDANCE INCLUDING THE
CURRENT COST OF AN ON OFF CAMPUS
TWO BEDROOM APARTMENT IN A
SINGLE BEDROOM IN A PRIVATE HOME
FOR PROSPECTIVE STUDENTS.
THIS BILL EMPOWERS PROSPECTIVE
STUDENTS TO MAKE FINANCIALLY
RESPONSIBLE DECISIONS FROM
REVIEWING A PERSPECTIVE SEE
ISSUE OR YOU SEEN.
MEMBERS AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME
LAST YEAR I VOTE -- I'D LIKE.
TO INVITE OUR WITNESSES TO
TESTIFY THROUGH THE CHAIR IS ARE
YOU THE CHAIR CURRENTLY YES
THANK YOU -- WE HAVE PAGE LOGAN
WHO'S A STUDENT AT CAL POLY A
SAN LUIS OBISPO AND JAKE ONE CAN
SALSA STUDENT AT CAL POLY THANK
YOU THANK YOU CENTER MINING --
WITNESSES SUPPORT THAT WE ASK
THAT YOU TRY BETWEEN THE TWO OF
YOU WITHIN FOUR MINUTES THANK
YOU.
THE GREEN BUT THERE YOU GO.
HELLO AND THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND CHAIRMAN AND HONORABLE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
PAIGE LOGAN AND I'M A FIFTY YEAR
POLITICAL SCIENCE MAJOR I CAL
POLY SAN LUIS OBISPO AND I'M
HERE TO SPEAK ON BEHALF OF SB.
FOUR SIXTY SEVEN I'D ALSO LIKE
TO THANK SENATOR MONNING FOR
AUTHORING INTRODUCING OUR BILL.
I'M A FIRST GENERATION COLLEGE
STUDENT THAT'S MY FAMILY AN I
WERE NEVER AWARE OF THE TRUE
EXPENSES THAT CAME ALONG WITH
THE COLLEGE ATTENDANCE.
THE STIGMA BEHIND COLLEGE LOAN
DEBT DISSUADED MY FAMILY AND I
FOR TAKING OUT SUBSTANTIAL LOANS
TO COVER THE COST OF ATTENDANCE
ASIDE FROM MY TUITION.
WHEN THE TIME CAME FOR ME TO
MOVE OFF TO COLLEGE I HAD TO
TAKE ON MORE FINANCIAL
RESPONSIBILITIES FOR MYSELF?
MY SINGLE MOTHER AND I HAD TO
COVER THE EXPENSES OF TO LIVING
UNITS WHICH IS GOING TO BE
NEARLY IMPOSSIBLE.
I WAS PRETTY MUCH FORCED TO FIND
A JOB AND WORK AS MUCH AS I
COULD WHILE ALSO MAINTAINING MY
SCHOOL WORK.
I PERSONALLY HAVE TO WORK ABOUT
THIRTY FIVE TO FORTY HOURS A
WEEK TO SUPPORT MYSELF
FINANCIALLY THROUGH COLLEGE.
HAVING TO WORK IN ORDER TO EARN
A CERTAIN INCOME EACH MONTH
LIMITS THE AMOUNT OF UNITS I CAN
TAKE EACH QUARTER.
HAVING TO FOCUS ON MY FINANCIAL
NEEDS HAS RESULTED IN FIND
FALLING BEHIND IN MY DEGREE
PROGRESS AND UNLIKE -- AND LIKE
MANY OTHER COLLEGE STUDENTS ARE
OUT CALIFORNIA I'M GRADUATING AS
A FIFTH YEAR.
FURTHERMORE I DIDN'T HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO REACH MY FULLEST
POTENTIAL DURING MY
UNDERGRADUATE YEARS.
UNLIKE MY FELLOW CLASSMATES I
CAN AFFORD TO EVEN CONSIDER
APPLYING FOR THOSE UNPAID
INTERNSHIPS.
OR EVEN WITHOUT THOSE AMAZING
STUDY ABROAD SEMESTERS.
I DEFINITELY STRUGGLE TO MAKE
ENDS MEET THESE PAST FIVE YEARS
I'VE BEEN UNWILLINGLY STUCK IN
MY CURRENT LIVING SITUATION
BECAUSE IT'S THE CHEAPEST RUN
OPTION I'VE FOUND FOR MY BUDGET.
I KNOW I'M NOT THE ONLY STUDENTS
SUFFERING WITH THE SIMILAR
STRUGGLES.
THROUGH MY EXPERIENCES IN
CONVERSATIONS WITH MY PEERS
ABOUT THESE ISSUES WE HAVE
GATHERED AND ORGANIZED AS A
CLASS TO CONSTRUCT THIS PIECE OF
LEGISLATION AND ATTEMPT TO BRING
MORE TRANSPARENCY TO THE
ESTIMATED COST OF ATTENDANCE
PROJECTED BY CALIFORNIA
UNIVERSITIES.
HOW CAN CALL JUNE STILL COVERED
ENOUGH IN THEMSELVES AND THEIR
FUTURES IF THEY'RE STRUGGLING
WITH THE FINANCIAL BURDENS ON A
MONTH TO MONTH BASIS?
FINDING PLACES TO RENT BECOMES
MORE COMPETITIVE AND EXPENSIVE
EACH YEAR I BELIEVE THAT THERE
NEEDS TO BE MORE ACTION FOR
MAKING THE COST OF ATTENDANCE
MORE TRANSPARENT.
MORE TRANSPARENT COST
PROJECTIONS WILL OUR PROSPECTIVE
STUDENTS TO NAVIGATE THE COST
ESTIMATES AND FIND THEIR BESTED
PERSONAL NEEDS.
I KILEY THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
SUPPORT OF SB.
FOUR SIXTY SEVEN THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR IN ARNOLD
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR PROVIDING
US WITH THE OPTION TO SPEAK
TODAY.
I'D LIKE TO START BY EXPRESSING
OUR GRATITUDE TOWARDS -- CENTER
MONNING AND HIS STAFF FOR THEIR
EFFORTS AND WILLINGNESS TO TAKE
ON THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS TAKE WALKEN'S I AM A
FOURTH YEAR POLITICAL SCIENCE
MAJOR CAL POLY SAN LUIS OBISPO
HERE STRONG SUPPORT AS BEFORE.
SIXTY SEVEN AS BEFORE SIXTY
SEVEN BUILT UPON PART OF
LEGISLATION TO ADDRESS THE
PREVIOUSLY MENTIONED ISSUE AT
HAND THROUGH ONE EXPANDING ON AB
NINE NINETY TO INCLUDE THE COST
OF A TWO BEDROOM APARTMENT.
AND ONE PERSON BEDROOM IN
PRIVATE HOMES ALONG SO THE COST
OF A ONE BEDROOM APARTMENT
IMPOSING THESE COSTS ON
RESPECTIVE INSTITUTIONS
FINANCIAL AID WEBSITES THAT
PROVIDE CATEGORIZE COST OF
LIVING ESTIMATES. TO SEPARATE
BECAUSE OF COST ESTIMATES OF
OTHER BECAUSE LIVING CATEGORIES
INCLUDING BUT NOT LIMITED TO THE
ESTIMATED.
BECAUSE OF THE FOLLOWING LIVING
AT HOME OR CURRENT RESIDENTS THE
COST OF FOOD BECAUSE THE
TRANSPORTATION BOOKS AND
SUPPLIES.
MISPLACE EXPENSES TUITION
MENTORS IN FEES AND THREE
INCLUDING A STATEMENT THE STRESS
OF THE PRESS -- PROSPECT OF
STUDENTS THAT THE COST WAS THAT
ARE MERELY ESTIMATES AND THAT
THEY ARE ENCOURAGED TO CONDUCT
RESEARCH TO ASSESS THEMSELVES
AND BETTER OUTLINING THE COST.
THAT WILL SATISFY THE INDIVIDUAL
NEEDS. FOR TRANSPARENCY SICK THE
BILL WULD ASK THE INSTITUTIONS
INCLUDE A DESCRIPTION AS THE HOW
THE DATA PRESENTED WAS DERIVED.
THROUGH DESCRIBING THE
METHODOLOGY INCLUDING THEIR
SOURCES UNIVERSITIES ARE HELD TO
A HIGHER LEVEL OF ACCOUNTABILITY
WILL ALSO GIVING STUDENTS A
SPRINGBOARD AND BEGINNING TO
DERIVE THEIR OWN INDIVIDUALIZED
COST OF ATTENDANCE ESTIMATES.
URGING STUDENTS TO DO THEIR OWN
RESEARCH ENSURE THAT STUDENTS
ARE SEEKING OUT COST ESTIMATES
ON THEIR OWN CASE BY CASE BASIS.
PLACING A LEVEL SHARE
RESPONSIBILITY AND UNIVERSITIES
AND STUDENTS.
DOES THIS LEVEL OF TRANSPARENCY
ACCESSIBILITY INCONSISTENCY WITH
THE STUDENTS IN PLANNING THEIR
FINANCIAL PACKAGES WHEN
DETERMINING WHICH UNIVERSITIES
BEST FIT FOR THEIR FINANCIAL
LIMITATIONS.
WITH MORE ACCURATE PLANNING
STUDENT SUPPORTERS WOULD BE ABLE
TO MINIMIZE THE BURDENS THAT
COME WITH TRYING TO MAKE THE
PROCESS MEN'S GIVEN CURRENT
CIRCUMSTANCES.
I'D LIKE TO THANK YOU ALL AGAIN
FOR YOUR TIME INSPECT WE ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT AS BEFORE SIXTY
SEVEN THANK YOU THANK YOU TO
HAVE ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
A WASHINGTON WITH THE CAL STATE
STUDENT ASSOCIATION AND WE ARE
CO SPONSORS OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
ELIZABETH MARSHALL STUDENT AT
CAL POLY SAN LUIS OBISPO IN
SUPPORT OF THE STE.
ENGINE OF A SKETCH STUDENT AT
CAL POLY SAN LUIS OBISPO IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
BILLY BARTON STUDENT AT CAL POLY
SAN LUIS OBISPO IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
VERY SUCH DIVERSE STUDENT CAL
POLY SAN LUIS OBISPO AND STRONG
SUPPORT.
MORNING HARASSING KIRK STUDENT
CAL POLY SAN LUIS OBISPO IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
CURING ALLTEL'S STUDENT CAL POLY
SAN LUIS OBISPO STRONG SUPPORT.
RUBY LEDFORD STUDENT AT CAL POLY
SAN LUIS OBISPO AND STRONG
SUPPORT.
BRETT RAFFISH STUDENT A COUPLE
AS SOON AS POSSIBLE IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
DOMINIC MALICE DO NOT CAL POLY
SAN LUIS OBISPO AND STRONG
SUPPORT.
JEANETTE HARRIS STUDENTS
CANNIBALIZING OBISPO STRONG
SUPPORT.
JULIA BAYLISS STUDENT AT CAL
POLY SAN LUIS OBISPO ALSO IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
CAN A WAR THERE'S STUDENT
COWBOYS IN THIS THE BEST PHONE
STRONG SUPPORT.
JEANNIE GOOD JERRY A PREVIOUS
STUDENT COUPLERS ELSA'S BUT ALSO
TOOK FIVE YEARS TO GRADUATE.
IN A STRONGLY SUPPORT.
MARY BUTLER SOON AT CAL POLY SAN
LUIS OBISPO IN STRONG SUPPORT.
ALEX BEFORE YOU SEE STUDENTS
ASSOCIATION STRONG SUPPORT.
EVAN MILLER STUDENT AT CAL POLY
SAN LUIS OBISPO IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
IN THEIR SIZING HIM STUDENT AT
UCLA AND ON BEHALF UC'S TING
ASSOCIATION STRONGLY SUPPORT.
COM YOU'RE FACING A UCLA ARM
ALSO INSTRUCTS SUPPORT.
MONTEL AS A STUDENT YOU FEEL A
STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL SUPPORT.
ANY OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
SEEING AND HEARING THEN WE'LL
COME BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
SENATOR GLAZER.
THANK YOU AT YOUR LEYVA AT FIRST
TO SAY THE AUTHOR THANK YOU FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP IN THIS AREA
IT'S THAT SUCH AN IMPORTANT
THING TO DO. TO PROVIDE THIS
TYPE OF DISCLOSURE FULLY SUPPORT
OF THE BILL.
I ALSO WANT TO I THINK STUDENTS
WHO TRAVELED SO FAR FROM IS A
CELL AND ELSEWHERE TO BE HERE
TODAY IT'S AN IMPORTANT PART.
OF US MAKING GOOD CHOICES IS TO
HAVE THE INVOLVEMENT OF ALL OF
ALL OF OUR COMMUNITIES INCLUDING
OUR STUDENT COMMUNITY I THINK
IT'S VERY HELPFUL THAT YOU HAVE
COME HERE AND AND SHARED YOUR
EXPERIENCES.
I KNOW YOU HAVE WITH THE AUTHOR.
I I HAD ONE OTHER OBSERVATION
AND AND IT CAME OUT OF A JUST A
MOMENT AGO I WAS IN ANOTHER
COMMITTEE.
GOVERNMENT FINANCING WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT STUDENT HOUSING
AND THE BUT THE PROBLEM IS THAT
THAT THAT WE HAVE WITH THE
HOMELESSNESS GROWING AND ALL OF
OUR CAMPUSES.
THE AFFORDABILITY ISSUE NOT JUST
STATEWIDE BUT CERTAINLY -- IT
WITH OUR STUDENTS AND OUR CAMPUS
IS -- AND A NUMBER OF THE
SENATORS -- AND THE PANEL.
I TALKED ABOUT HOW WE NEED TO
FOCUS ON THAT ISSUE AND THAT
PART OF THAT DISCUSSION WAS THAT.
IN SO MANY CASES OUR OUR
CAMPUSES ARE ALMOST LIKE ISLANDS
AND WHEN WE ENACT POLICIES
AROUND THE STATE DEALING WITH
LOTS OF DIFFERENT THINGS.
WE DON'T THINK ABOUT THE STUDENT
COMMUNITY AND WITHIN THIS TO
CAMPUS COMMITTEE THEY DON'T
THINK ABOUT -- OTHER STATE
ACTIVITIES AND HOW THEY CAN
BETTER LINCOLN CAN ACT AND AND
AND TAKE ADVANTAGE AND I'LL GIVE
YOU THREE EXAMPLES -- CERTAINLY
IN THE AREA OF FOOD -- BASIC
NEEDS HUNGER.
WE DON'T DO IT ON MENTAL HEALTH
LIKE WE SHOULD.
PROBLEMS OF MENTAL HEALTH IN OUR
COMMUNITY CERTAINLY EXISTED OUR
CAMPUSES WHERE WE WORKING BETTER
TOGETHER.
AND THE ISSUE OF HOUSING IS
CERTAINLY.
YOU KNOW I TOP EXAMPLE AS WELL
WE ARE TRYING TO WE KNOW WE HAVE
A HOUSING CRISIS IN THE STATE WE
ARE TRYING TO FIND WAYS TO DEAL
WITH IT INCLUDING SUBSIDIES --
FOR HAVE A HOUSING THAT'S THAT
ALLOWS THAT THAT DEALS WITH THE
HOMELESS POPULATION AND OTHERS
BUT YET WE DON'T BRING THE
CAMPUS COMMUNITY IN THOSE
CONVERSATIONS -- AND SO IT'S
MORE THAN JUST DISCLOSURE WHICH
IS REALLY IMPORTANT AND VALUABLE
IT'S ALSO MAKING SURE THAT OUR
CAMPUS COMMUNITIES CAN TAP INTO.
OUR STATE RESPONSE TO THE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING TO
HOMELESSNESS -- THAT THAT WE
SHOULD BE TOGETHER AND WE SHOULD
MAKE SURE THAT THAT'S A PART OF
OUR CONVERSATION SO THAT'S JUST
AN OBSERVATION AS I APPLAUD YOU
AND YOUR LEADERSHIP ON THIS BILL.
THANK YOU CENTER GLAZER.
ANYTHING ELSE ALL RIGHT.
EDU MOVE THE BILL THANK YOU
CENTER GLAZER.
YOUR MONEY WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
AND JUST BRIEFLY I APPRECIATE
SENATOR GLAZERS COMMENTS AND I
THINK. ONE OF THE MANIFESTATIONS
OF THIS EFFORT IS TO SHOW
STUDENTS STEPPING UP IN BEING
ENGAGED IN I JUST WANT TO
APPLAUD THE STUDENTS FROM.
NOT JUST CAL POLY SAN LUIS
OBISPO THEY'RE THE THEY'RE THE
MOTIVE FORCE BEHIND THIS BUT
THEN THE COLLABORATION WITH
STUDENTS FROM OTHER CAMPUSES.
AND WE DO FACE TREMENDOUS
CHALLENGES OF OF HOUSING MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES OF HUNGER.
WARNING OF STUDENTS LIVING IN
CARS AND THEN TRYING TO DECIDE
WHERE TO PARK AT NIGHT SO THAT
THEY CAN BE SAFE -- WE CAN DO
BETTER THAN THAT AND I WOULD
JUST CLOSE FINALLY ON SAYING.
I THINK IT'S IN OUR UNIVERSITIES
WHERE WE HAVE THE BRAIN TRUST IN
THE INVESTMENT -- TO JOIN US AND
SOLVING SOME OF THESE PROBLEMS
SO -- AS I HEARD YOUR AYE VOTE I
ALSO ENCOURAGE HER STUDENT
LEADERS TO CONTINUE WORKING WITH
THIS ON MANY OTHER ISSUES AS
WELL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR RUNNING THE
BILL HAS BEEN MOVED BY CENTER
GLAZER MENEM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
ITEM TWELVE SP FOUR SIXTY SEVEN
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS LEYVA AYE LEYVA
AYE WILL HI WILK I CHIANG LU
ASAL GLAZER.
GLAZER AYE MCGUIRE PAN.
PAN AYE.
WE WILL BE THE BILL ON CALL
THANK YOU SENATOR MINING THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY. FOR
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM THIRTEEN SB FOUR EIGHTY
FOUR SENATOR PORTANTINO.
CENTER PORTANTINO BEGIN WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS -- TODAY I AM
PRESENTING SB FOUR EIGHTY FOUR
WHICH SEEKS TO SIMPLIFY THE
TRANSFER PROCESS FROM CALIFORNIA
COMMITTEE COLLEGES. TO THE YOU
IN C. S. U. FOR STUDENTS WHO
HAVE COMPLETED THE DEGREE
REQUIREMENTS FOR THE ASSOCIATE
DEGREE FOR TRANSFER THE AT T..
FOR ABOUT HALF OF THE STUDENTS
IN CALIFORNIA THE PATH TO A
BACHELOR'S DEGREE IS TO
TRANSFERRING FROM A COMMUNITY
COLLEGE.
DESPITE.
WONDERFUL LEGISLATIVE EFFORTS TO
SIMPLIFY THE TRANSFER PROCESS
FROM THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES TO THE UC IN THE C.
ISSUE.
THEY DO WILL CONTINUE TO REMAIN
COMPLEX AND DIFFICULT. FOR SOME
STUDENTS TO RESEARCH HAS FOUND A
FEW SYSTEMATIC PROBLEMS WITH THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE EIGHTY
TEAS SUCH AS LACK OF
UNDERSTANDING OF THE DEGREE.
BY THE STUDENTS AND CHALLENGES
FOR UNIVERSITIES TO CERTIFY
WHETHER OR NOT THE TRANSFER
STUDENT ACTUALLY HAS THE AT T..
S. B. A FOR WOULD REQUIRE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES TO
IDENTIFY AT T. STUDENTS.
AND AWARD THEM THEIR EARNED
AGREE AND ADD THEM TO AN
IDENTIFICATION SYSTEM THAT IS
ELECTRONICALLY AVAILABLE FOR THE
CAL STATE IN THE UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA -- UNIVERSE
CALIFORNIA THIS BILL WILL MAKE
SURE THAT STUDENTS TO EARN THEIR
DEGREE ACTUALLY RECEIVE THEIR
DEGREE AND TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THE
BENEFITS -- TO TO BE SHORT RIGHT
NOW IF YOU COMPLETE YOUR CREDITS
AND YOU TRANSFER.
UNLESS YOU PRO ACTIVELY GO DOWN
AND WE'RE CLASS THE DEGREE YOU
DON'T GET IT.
SO WHEN YOU GRADUATE HIGH SCHOOL
YOU DON'T HAVE TO ASK FOR YOUR
HIGH SCHOOL DIPLOMA.
YOU GET IT SO BASICALLY WITH
THIS BILL SAYS IS IF YOU'VE ARE
IN THE CREDITS.
YOU SHOULD GET YOUR DEGREE AND
WE SHOULD KEEP TRACK OF YOU AS
YOU PROGRESS THROUGH THE SYSTEM.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR RIVAL.
THANK YOU CENTER PORTANTINO
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
HELLO AGAIN ALEX CASE THAT THE I
CC YOU -- WE HAVE A SUPPORT
AMENDED POSITION ALASTOR BUDGET
NEGOTIATIONS WE THIRTY NINE OF
OUR INSTITUTIONS AGREED TO
ASSIGN AT T. AGREEMENTS TO
INCREASE PATHWAYS FOR STUDENTS
TO OUR INSTITUTIONS AND WE WOULD
BE VERY APPRECIATIVE OF HAVING
ACCESS TO THIS DATABASE SO WE WE
CAN ALSO IDENTIFY -- STUDIO
COMPLETED EIGHTIES ARE LOOKING
TO CONTINUE THEIR EDUCATION
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT THEY'RE IN OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL.
ANY COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
OF THE BILL CENTER PORTANTINO.
CENTER WILK.
NO OKAY SERVER TO REJECT CLOSE.
S. RIVAL VERY GOOD THE BILLS
WILL BY SENATOR GLAZER MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ITEM THIRTEEN SB. FOUR EIGHTY
EIGHTY FOUR THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS LEYVA.
LEYVA I WILL WILK I CHIANG WHO
ASAL GLAZER.
GLAZER AYE MCGUIRE PAN PAN.
NINE WE HAVE TO TRY TO GO.
I APOLOGIZE WE HAD SOMEONE WHO
WANT TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION IF
YOU WANT TO COME AND SHARE YOUR
THOUGHTS WITH US I APOLOGIZE AT
THE BILL'S ALREADY BEEN VOTED ON
BUT I DON'T WANT TO DENY ANYBODY
THEIR DEMOCRATIC RIGHT PLEASE
COME ON DOWN SORRY I DIDN'T
T A WORRY
LIFE IS A TEAM EFFORT.
THANK YOU I JUST GOT HERE.
NO PROBLEM HI MY NAME IS ROSE
MERRY AND TUNES I AM A FORMER
LABOR AND DELIVERY NURSE.
AND A FORMER COLLEGE HEALTH
NURSE.
SO -- AS A LABOR AND DELIVERY
NURSE FOR TWENTY FOUR YEARS.
I'VE SEEN A LOT OF THINGS GOING
ON WITH THE ITEMS.
THAT ARE MENTIONED.
IN.
SB.
TWENTY FOUR YOU KNOW WHAT THIS
IS THE WRONG BILL AND THE WRONG
COMMITTEE THAT BILL'S GOING TO
BE UP IN HEALTH COMMITTEE A
LITTLE LATER TODAY THE EDUCATION
COMMITTEE IS NOT VOTING ON IT
TODAY THAT IS CORRECT IT'S NOT
ON OUR YEAH AND FIGURED I WOULD
ASK.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR INDULGENCE YOU'RE
WELCOME THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR TIME AND YOU'LL SEE ME LIKE.
SOUNDS GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WE ARE NOTHING IF NOT
ACCOMMODATING ON THE EDUCATION
COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU CENTER PORTANTINO.
NEXT UP IS SENATOR JACKSON I
THINK I SEE YOU.
HEALTH MAY BE A LITTLE STRICTER
THOUGH THIS AFTERNOON.
GOOD TO KNOW SENATOR PAN.
SENATOR JACKSON YOU HAVE SB FOUR
NINETY THREE PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE
READY THANK YOU AND AND I HOPE I
AM IN THE RIGHT COMMITTEE.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS I AM
PLEASED TO PRESENT SB FOUR
NINETY THREE TWO TODAY.
THIS IS LEGISLATION THE CODIFIES
FUNDAMENTAL TENANTS AND
REQUIREMENTS.
OF FEDERAL TITLE NINE STANDARDS
INTO CALIFORNIA LAW.
TITLE NINE HAS BEEN A AN
ENORMOUS BENEFIT TO ASSURING A
EQUALITY AND EQUITY IN EDUCATION.
BUT SADLY IN SOMEWHAT SHOCKINGLY
SEXUAL ASSAULT.
AND VIOLENCE IN HIGHER EDUCATION
IS PERVASIVE.
ACCORDING TO THE TWENTY SIXTEEN
CAMPUS CLIMATE SURVEY VALIDATION
STUDY OF TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND
COLLEGE AND UNIVERSITY STUDENTS.
AN ESTIMATED 62% OF WOMEN AND
61% OF MEN.
SAY THEY HAVE EXPERIENCED SEXUAL
HARASSMENT ONE IN FIVE WOMEN.
AND ONE IN FOURTEEN MEN.
EXPERIENCE SEXUAL ASSAULT WHILE
IN COLLEGE.
HOWEVER DUE TO THE UNDER
REPORTING OF SEXUAL HARASSMENT
AND VIOLENCE THE RATES ARE
LIKELY.
MUCH HIGHER.
THE PREMISE OF TITLE NINE IS A
LACK OF EQUITY MEANS TO SPREAD
AND UNEQUAL EDUCATIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES.
AND HOSTILITY CATION --
ENVIRONMENT FURTHER DENIES
EDUCATIONAL OPPORTUNITY.
THE PASSAGE OF SB NINE SIXTY
SEVEN IN TWENTY FOURTEEN WHICH
ESTABLISHED AN AFFIRMATIVE
CONSENT STANDARD THE FIRST
APPLICATION OF THE YES MEANS YES
CONCEPT.
IN THE COUNTRY CALIFORNIA TOOK
STEPS TO AID COLLEGE AGE MEN AND
WOMEN IN ADDRESSING THE ISSUE OF
SEXUAL ASSAULT AND VIOLENCE ON
CAMPUS [inaudible]
HOWEVER.
WE CANNOT BE SATISFIED WITH THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THAT MEASURE
INSTEAD WE HAVE TO CONTINUE TO
LEAD THE NATION IN EDUCATING OUR
YOUNG PEOPLE BOTH WOMEN AND MEN.
ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE OF RESPECT
AND MAINTAINING HEALTHY PEER AND
DATING RELATIONSHIPS.
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSED REGULATIONS TO TITLE
NINE WHICH HAVE NOT YET TAKEN
EFFECT.
AIM TO CHANGE THE WAY SCHOOLS
ARE REQUIRED TO RESPOND TO
REPORTS OF SEXUAL HARASSMENT AND
ASSAULT IN WAYS THAT ACTUALLY
MAKE IT HARDER. FOR SURVIVORS TO
REPORT AND THREATEN STUDENTS TO
ACCESS TO EDUCATION AFTER THEY
DO REPORT.
SB FOUR NINETY THREE ADDRESSES
COLLEGE AND UNIVERSITY SEXUAL
HARASSMENT AND ASSAULT IN
CALIFORNIA LAW.
BY PUTTING IN PLACE GUIDELINES
AND PROCEDURES FOR SCHOOLS TO
USE IN RESPONDING TO ALLEGATIONS
OF SEXUAL HARASSMENT AND ASSAULT
INCLUDING NOTICE.
AND POSTING REQUIREMENTS TO
ENSURE STUDENTS ARE AWARE OF
THEIR RIGHT.
THEIR OPTIONS AND THE PROCEDURES
THAT MUST BE FOLLOWED AS WELL AS
TRANSPARENCY IN THOSE PROCEDURES
FOR INVESTIGATING COMPLAINTS IN
ORDER TO ENSURE A FAIR AND
EQUITABLE PROCESS FOR BOTH
PARTIES.
AND AS A RECOVERING LAWYER AND
AS THE CHAIR OF THE SENATE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE IT IS
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT AND I AM A
STRONG ADVOCATE.
IN DUE PROCESS IN ALL
CIRCUMSTANCES AND SO THIS BILL
REQUIRES COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES TO PUBLISH THE
CONTACT INFORMATION FOR
INDIVIDUALS RESPONSIBLE FOR
INVESTIGATING COMPLAINTS.
AND INSTITUTING CORRECTIVE
MEASURES THE RULES AND
PROCEDURES FOR PREVENTION OF
SEXUAL HARASSMENT AS WELL AS
GRIEVANCE PROCESS A GRIEVANCE
PROCEDURES PROVIDING FOR THE
PROMPT AND EQUITABLE RESOLUTION
SEXUAL HARASSMENT AND ASSAULT
COMPLAINTS.
THE BILL WOULD ALSO REQUIRE
SCHOOLS TO PROVIDE TRAINING TO
EMPLOYEES ENGAGED IN THE
GRIEVANCE PROCESS.
ON TRAUMA INFORMED BEST
PRACTICES -- FOR INVESTIGATING
SEXUAL HARASSMENT OR ASSAULT
COMPLAINTS.
AS WELL AS TRAINING IN IMPLICIT
BIAS AND THE HISTORY HISTORY OF
INSTITUTIONAL RACISM AND RACIAL
INEQUITIES IN SCHOOL
DISCIPLINARY PROCESS SEES WHAT
WE SEE OUT IN THE OUTSIDE WORLD
IN TERMS OF DISCRIMINATORY
PRACTICES WE ALSO SADLY.
SEEN COLLEGES AND THOSE NEED TO
BE CORRECTED AS WELL NOW.
THERE IS SOME OPPOSITION TO THIS
A GROUP OF MOMS WHO WILL.
TELL YOU THAT THIS BILL IS
FLAWED THAT IT DOESN'T REFLECT
THE FINDINGS OF GOVERNOR BROWN'S
TASK FORCE THAT USED IN CORRECT
STANDARDS FOR FINDING OF FAULT.
AND THAT THE TRAUMA INFORMED
TRAINING REQUIRED BY THE BILL
PREJUDICES THE PROCESS AGAINST
RESPONDENTS.
THESE CLAIMS ARE JUST SIMPLY NOT
CORRECT.
NOTHING IN THE GOVERNOR'S TASK
FORCE REPORT IS CONTRARY TO THE
REQUIREMENTS OF OUR BILL.
USE OF THE PREPONDERANCE OF THE
EVIDENCE STANDARD IS FULLY
APPROPRIATE FOR A STUDENT
DISCIPLINARY HEARING.
AND OP OPPONENTS ARE TRYING TO
CONFLATE CRIMINAL PROCESS.
AND THE STANDARD OF PROOF WE
REQUIRE IN CRIMINAL PROCEEDINGS
WITH ADMINISTRATIVE PROCEEDINGS.
THE USE OF TRAUMA INFORMED
TRAINING DOES NOT BIASED THE
PROCESS AGAINST ANYONE WHAT IT
DOES.
IS IT INSURES THAT A SURVIVOR IS
NOT HARMED OR RE TRAUMATIZED BY
THE ADMINISTRATIVE PROCESS THAT
THE BILL SETS OUT.
AND WITH ME THIS ONE MORNING OUR
REPRESENTATIVES VEHICLE RIGHT
ADVOCATES THE SPONSOR OF THE
BILL.
AND G. JERRY A FORMER STUDENT
WHO IS HERE TO SHARE HER STORY
WITH US.
WITH THAT I WOULD RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR IPHONE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE.
MY NAME IS MA HI ABRAHAM AND I'M
AN ATTORNEY WITH EQUAL RIGHTS
ADVOCATES A CALIFORNIA NONPROFIT.
WE PRACTICE UNDER TITLE NINE
RELATED CIVIL RIGHTS LAWS TO
PROTECT WOMEN AND GIRLS AND
WE'VE BEEN DOING SO SINCE
NINETEEN SEVENTY FOUR JUST TWO
YEARS AFTER TITLE NINE WAS
ENACTED.
STUDENTS EDUCATION CIVIL RIGHTS
WERE ESTABLISHED TO INSURE
EQUITABLE ACCESS TO EDUCATION.
THE SAFEGUARD AGAINST THE PUSH
OUT OF WOMEN AND GIRLS STUDENTS
OF COLOR LGBT Q. I STUDENTS
STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES.
THAT IS EDUCATION CIVIL RIGHTS
WERE CREATED AND ARE IN PLACE TO
PROTECT STUDENTS WHO HAVE
HISTORICALLY BEEN DENIED EQUAL
ACCESS TO INSTITUTIONS.
COVETED BY THE ELITE AND
POWERFUL THE PRIVILEGED AND
ENTITLED.
THESE ARE THE SAME STUDENTS THAT
AS EXISTING VOLUMINOUS AND SOUND
DATA AMPLY SHOWS STILL FACE
THREATS TO THEIR PHYSICAL SAFETY
AND ABILITY TO RECEIVE EQUITABLE
ACCESS TO AN EDUCATION.
THE CIVIL RIGHTS ARE UNDER
ATTACK AS THE SENATOR NOTED.
OF THE CURRENT ADMINISTRATION IS
TURNING CIVIL RIGHTS ON ITS HEAD
TO WORK AGAINST THE VERY PEOPLE
THAT THESE PRINCIPLES IN THESE
RIGHTS ARE MEANT TO PROTECT.
AUGUST TOWARD ACCESS AND EQUITY
FOR STUDENTS WHO HAVE SUFFERED
SEXUAL HARASSMENT AND ASSAULT IS
THERE FOR IN JEOPARDY.
AS BEFORE NINETY THREE IS
NECESSARY TO PROVIDE CRITICAL
GUIDANCE FOR COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES SO THAT THEY CAN
RESPOND APPROPRIATELY TO
ALLEGATIONS OF SEXUAL ASSAULT
AND VIOLENCE.
AND ENSURE THAT CALIFORNIA'S
STUDENTS ARE AFFORDED
COMMONSENSE.
AND FACT SUPPORTED EDUCATION
RIGHTS IN THE STUDENT MISCONDUCT
INVESTIGATION PROCESS TO THE
CALIFORNIA COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES CONTINUE TO MOVE
FORWARD TOWARD EQUITABLE ACCESS.
EQUAL RIGHTS ADVOCATES OPERATES
A NATIONAL HELPLINE THROUGH THAT
HELPLINE WE HEAR FROM COUNTLESS
STUDENTS ABOUT THE CHALLENGES
THEY FACE AFTER THEYHAVE
REPORTED SEXUAL ASSAULT TO THEIR
SCHOOLS.
WE HAVE THE PRIVILEGE OF MEETING
MISS GINA G. JERRY -- THIS
HOTLINE.
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT YOUR WE
STRONGLY URGE YOUR EIGHTY YOUR
AYE VOTE ON SB FOUR NINETY THREE
AND WITH THAT I'D LIKE TO SEE
THE REST OF MY TIME TO MR JERRY.
HELLO GOOD MORNING -- MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY BEFORE
YOU -- AND MY SUPPORT FOR US
BEFORE.
NINETY THREE I KNOW FIRST HAND
WHY THIS BILL IS NEEDED I WAS
RAPED IN COLLEGE I KNOW ALL TOO
WELL THE HARM THAT OCCURS WHEN A
SCHOOL FAILS TO PROPERLY RESPOND
APPROPRIATELY.
MY NAME IS GINA COULD JERRY I
GRADUATED FROM CAL POLY SAN LUIS
OBISPO WITH A DEGREE IN
AEROSPACE ENGINEERING IN JUNE.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN DURING MY FINAL
YEAR I WAS RAPED BY MY SENIOR
PROJECT GROUP MADE WHILE WE WERE
ON OUR DESIGN REVIEW TRIP TO
EDWARDS AIR FORCE BASE.
I REPORTED MY APE TO THE
PROFESSOR THE WEEK AFTER IT
HAPPENED AND I HAD TO FACE MY
RAPIST EVERY SINGLE DAY IN CLASS.
MY PROFESSOR REPORTED IT TO
CAMPUS POLICE AND THE TITLE NINE
OFFICE.
I TO STAY IN TOWN FOR WINTER
BREAK AND ASK SHOULD ANXIOUSLY
WORK WITH THE PROFESSORS IN
SCHOOL TO GET MY RAPIST AT LEAST
MOVED OUT OF MY CLASS.
BEFORE THE QUARTER STARTED.
DURING THE AN INVESTIGATION IT
WAS DIFFICULT TO GET IN TOUCH
WITH THE TITLE MY OFFICE
DIRECTLY.
THEY OFTEN DIDN'T ANSWER THE
PHONE AND OFFICE WAS FREQUENTLY
CLOSED AND LOCKED UNKNOWN
WHATEVER ANSWER THE DOOR.
SOME OF THE PHONE NUMBERS ARE
POSTED ON THE WEBSITE DIDN'T
EVEN WORK OTHERS WENT STRAIGHT
TO VOICEMAIL AND ANY OCCASIONS
THAT THE TITLE NINE OFFICE DID
SPEAK WITH ME.
THEY WERE HOSTILE I'LL OFTEN
CONDESCENDING AND WHEN I ASKED
FOR TIME LINES.
I WAS REPRIMANDED WHEN I RE ASK
QUESTIONS OR DIDN'T REMEMBER
INFORMATION.
AFTER SIXTY WORKING DAYS NOT
INCLUDING WEEKENDS OR HOLIDAYS
OR DAYS OFF THE TITLE NINE
OFFICE EXTENDED THE
INVESTIGATION TIME LINE WITH AN
ADDITIONAL THIRTY WORKING DAYS
CITING CASE OVERLOAD
[inaudible]
AS THEN ABOUT A DAY BEFORE THE
DETERMINATION WAS SUPPOSED TO BE
RELEASED I WAS TOLD THAT THERE
WOULD BE ANOTHER THIRTY DAY
EXTENSION BECAUSE OF NEW
EVIDENCE BEING CITED.
THE NEW EVIDENCE WAS THAT THEY
FINALLY INTERVIEW THE PROFESSOR
WHO REPORTED IT -- SIX MONTHS
LATER.
AND I WAS SURPRISED THAT THEY
HAD INTERVIEWED HIM UNTIL ONE
DAY BEFORE THE INVESTIGATION WAS
SUPPOSED TO CLOSE AND THE NEW
DEADLINE WAS SET FOR ABOUT A
MONTH BEFORE SUPPOSED TO
GRADUATE.
I DIFFICULTY IN SCHOOL BECAUSE
OF THE TRAUMA OF THE ASSAULT
ITSELF BUT BECAUSE THE SCHOOL'S
RESPONSE SCHOOL DID NOT TAKE THE
STEPS TO ENSURE THAT I WOULDN'T
HAVE TO ENCOUNTER MY RAPIST IN
ORDER TO CONTINUE MY EDUCATION.
IN FACT THEY PUT ME INTO THE
SAME CLASSES HIM AN ACADEMIC
QUARTER AFTER THE RATE.
ACCIDENTALLY I GUESS THE SCHOOL
TOLD ME THAT I COULD TRY TO COME
UP WITH A PLAN FOR MY WHEN MY
RAPIST SHOULD BE ALLOWED TO COME
ONTO CAMPUS BUT THEY SAID I
WOULD HAVE TO DRAFT UP THE
SCHEDULE.
AND THAT I WOULD HAVE TO ALLOW
HIM TO BE ABLE TO GO TO ALL THE
SAME CLASSES THAT I HAVETO TAKE
FOR OUR DEGREE.
COMPLETION.
I THOUGHT IT WAS INAPPROPRIATE
FOR THE SCHOOL ASKED OUT OF ME
AND I DECLINED TO TAKE ON THAT
RESPONSIBILITY.
I SAW HIM ALL OVER CAMPUS NOT
JUST IN THE PLACES WE HAD
AEROSPACE ENGINEERING CLASSES
BUT ALSO AT THE GROCERY STORE
AND OTHER PLACES.
AND IT WOULD IMMEDIATELY GIVE ME
AN OVERWHELMING SENSE OF PANIC
ANXIETY FEAR AND SO MUCH SO THAT
I HAD TO MISS MULTIPLE CLASSES
ACTS FOR EXCEPTIONS.
ETCETERA.
I'D BEEN LIED STUDENT ON MY
SCHOOLS FORMULA AS THE TEAM
WHICH WAS DESIGNING TESTING AND
BUILDING A WORKING RACE CAR.
I'D BEEN ACTIVELY INVOLVED IN
THIS ACTIVITY FOR FOUR YEARS
HOWEVER I HAD TO STEP DOWN FROM
THIS POSITION SO THAT I CAN
FOCUS ON GETTING THROUGH THIS
EXPERIENCE ACTUALLY GRADUATING
AFTER FIVE YEARS AT CAL POLY.
I ALWAYS CONCERNS ON SEVERAL
OCCASION ABOUT THE SCHOOLS TITLE
NINE PROCESS AND EVEN WALKED
INTO THE OFFICE OF THE PROVOST
OF THE SCHOOL BUT THEY ALSO
SUGGESTED I PROVIDE WRITTEN
FEEDBACK ON THE SCHOOLS PROCESS
FOR THEM TO CONSIDER AT SOME
UNKNOWN FUTURE DATE.
OR TOLD ME I WOULD HAVE TO WAIT
UNTIL THE CASE WAS CLOSED EVEN
TALK ABOUT IT WITH THEM.
THE TITLE -- NINE INVESTIGATOR
EVENTUALLY CONCLUDED THAT MY
CLASSMATE WAS RESPONSIBLE FOR
THE RATE.
HOWEVER I STILL HAD TO SEE HIM
FOR THE REMAINDER OF THE YEAR-DURING THE APPEALS PERIOD SO
EVEN THOUGH HE WAS RESPONSIBLE.
HE WAS ALLOWED TO CONTINUE
ATTENDING CLASSES AND FINISH OUT
THE QUARTER.
A MONTH AFTER I GRADUATED AND
THE FRIDAY BEFORE I WAS GOING TO
START MY FULL TIME JOB AS A
PRODUCTION ENGINEER AT A
COMMERCIAL SOLID COMPANY.
I WAS NOTIFIED THAT MY RAPIST
WHO IS STILL STUDENT HAD
APPEALED THE TITLE NINE
DETERMINATION AND THAT THE CSU
TITLE NINE OFFICE HAD OVERTURNED
THE FINDING.
FROM THE INVESTIGATION AND NOW
FROM MY RAPIST WAS NOT
RESPONSIBLE FOR ANY SEXUAL
MISCONDUCT.
THEY INDICATED THAT BECAUSE I
HAD CRIED IMMEDIATELY AFTER THE
INCIDENT AND CALLED MY BOYFRIEND
AFTER THE ASSAULT THAT THIS
INDICATED I WAS AWARE OF
CONSEQUENCES AND FELT GUILTY
ABOUT WHAT HAD HAPPENED.
THE CSU OFFICE DID NOT CONTACT
ME OR AS FAR AS I KNOW ANY OTHER
WITNESSES BEFORE OR OVERTURNING
THIS FINDING.
I WAS TOLD I HAD TEN DAYS TO
RESPOND WITH THE APPEAL OF THE
NEW OUTCOME.
I CALLED THE TUNNEL NINE OFFICE
ON MULTIPLE OCCASIONS TRYING TO
GET MORE INFORMATION WAS UNABLE
TO GET A TIMELY RESPONSE.
WHEN I DID GET A RESPONSE THEY
SAID?
THAT THEY WERE SUPERSEDED BY THE
CSU TITLE NOT OFFICE AND THEY
COULD NOT GIVE ADVICE ON WHAT TO
DO BE ON SUGGESTING I RIGHT NOW
I FEEL.
WHEN THE CSU OFFICE FINALLY
CALLED ME BACK CHOOSE VERY STERN
AND CONDESCENDING WITH ME OVER
THE PHONE AND TOLD ME THAT IT
APPEARED I DID NOT KNOW WHAT
COERCION AND?
SHE ALSO SUGGESTED I CHANNEL MY
ANGER AND ENERGY INTO WRITING MY
APPEAL.
I FINALLY LEARNED OF THE INITIAL
DETERMINATION WAS OVERTURNED
BECAUSE THE CSU TITLE NINE
OFFICE DETERMINED THAT ALTHOUGH
I WAS.
NOTABLY INTOXICATED I WAS NOT
INCAPACITATED ON THE NIGHT NIGHT
OF THE INCIDENT.
AT LEAST FOUR WITNESSES
CONFIRMED THAT THEY WERE WORRIED
FOR MY HEALTH AND SAFETY THE
NIGHT OF THE INCIDENT DUE TO MY
LEVEL OF INTOXICATION.
THE CSU TITLE NINE OFFICE
REJECTED MY APPEAL.
THEY SAID THAT THE ADDITIONAL
EVIDENCE THAT ARE PROVIDED AND
THE WITNESSES I CITED COULD NOT
BE INTRODUCED AT THE APPEAL
STAGE AND THAT IT WAS NO LONGER
RELEVANT TO MY CASE AND WAS NOT
CONSIDERED.
IF I DIDN'T HAVE SUCH A STRONG
SUPPORT NETWORK THAT I DO.
I PROBABLY WOULD'VE TAKEN
ANOTHER YEAR TO GRADUATE OR
DROPPED OUT OR PROBABLY EVEN
KILLED MYSELF.
I'D SO MUCH FEAR GOING TO
CLASSES THAT I BECAME A HOMEBODY
I STILL DON'T EVEN GO OUT TO THE
GROCERY STORE IT SAFELY
DELIVERED TO MY HOUSE BECAUSE I
CAN'T GO ON PUBLIC.
I'VE TO PRETEND EVERY SINGLE DAY
OF MY THE MOST IMPORTANT YEAR OF
COLLEGE THAT THIS WASN'T
AFFECTING ME THAT SEEING HIM IT
DIDN'T EMOTIONALLY HURT ME.
AND MAKE ME FEAR FOR MYSELF.
THE SCHOOL DID VERY LITTLE TO
ENSURE MY SAFETY MY MENTAL
HEALTH OR MY ACADEMIC SUCCESS.
THE TITLE NINE OFFICER WOULD
CALL ME IN THE MIDDLE CLASS
ASKING ME TO DESCRIBE VERY
SPECIFIC DETAILS ON MY RIGHT ON
THE SPOT IN ORDER TO GO BACK TO
CLASS AND ACT LIKE NOTHING
HAPPENED -- I STILL GO TO
THERAPY EVERY SINGLE WEEK TO
ADDRESS THE EMOTIONAL TRAUMA NOT
ONLY FROM THE RAPE OF FROM MY
SCHOOLS PROCESS.
AND RESPONSE I STILL HAVE
TROUBLE SLEEPING AT NIGHT.
AND WHAT ALL THIS WAS HAPPENING
I TO TELL MY BOSS ABOUT IT
BECAUSE I HAD TO TAKE SICK LEAVE
TO BE ABLE TO WRITE MY APPEAL.
AND CALL THE TITLE NINE OFFICE --
BUT MY EXPERIENCE HIGHLIGHTS ALL
THE PROBLEMS THAT MANY COLLEGE
STUDENTS FACE.
THIS SYSTEM IS SO HORRIBLY
BROKEN AND HAS A LONG LASTING
IMPACT ON ALL SURVIVORS AND I'M
CONCERNED THAT THIS COMPLETE
LACK OF UNDERSTANDING AROUND
RAPE AND CONSENT -- BUT I'M
FEARFUL THAT OTHER CASES THAT
ARMED IS.
WHAT I THOUGHT OBVIOUS IS MINE
WILL BE MISHANDLED AND MISUSE?
SO THAT'S WHY I'M USING WHAT
PRIVILEGE I HAVE AND I'M
THANKFUL THAT IT HAPPENED TO ME
IS SO I CAN SPEAK FOR FOR YOU
GUYS BECAUSE LIKE WHAT IF MY
REGIS WAS VIOLENT.
I SAW HIM EVERY SINGLE DAY FOR
MY SENIOR CLASS RIGHT AS I LEFT
CLASS HE WOULD WALK IN.
AND EVERYONE KNEW WHAT HAPPENED
IS IS ON THE SENIOR PROJECT
DESIGN REVIEW TRIPS SO FORTY TWO
PEOPLE WERE THERE.
BUT THEY SAW HIM EVERY DAY SO.
YOU KNOW THEY DON'T THINK IT
ACTUALLY MATTERED OR HE DIDN'T
GET ANY REPERCUSSIONS -- SO WITH
THAT I'D JUST LIKE TO CLOSE
BECAUSE I SUPPORT SB FOUR NINE
THREE WHAT IT INCLUDES THE
TRAUMA INFORMED TRAINING.
IS VERY IMPORTANT FOR SURVIVORS
OF SEXUAL ASSAULT EVER REQUIRE
THAT COLLEGES HAVE A CLEAR
PROCESS IN PLACE FOR RESPONDING
TO SEXUAL ASSAULT.
IT WOULD ALSO REQUIRE A MUCH
NEEDED TRAINING ON HOW TO
ACTUALLY HANDLE INVESTIGATIONS.
TO ENSURE A FAIR PROCESS FOR ALL
STUDENTS IN A TIMELY MANNER. FOR
THESE REASONS I URGE YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU FOR GIVING ME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH YOU
TODAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY THANK YOU FOR BEING
BREAKING BRAVE ENOUGH TO COME
FORWARD WE REALLY APPRECIATE
THAT -- I THINK WE DID TWO
WITNESSES TWO MINUTES EACH.
SENATOR OR OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
MILEY'S AT ALL WITH THE AMERICAN
ASSOCIATION OF UNIVERSITY WOMEN
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
JULIE MCCORMICK THE WINDS
FOUNDATION OF CALIFORNIA WOMEN'S
POLICY INSTITUTE A CO SPONSOR
AND IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
FILES ENOUGH FROM BE SEWER
VIOLENCE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
ALEX BEFORE UC STUDENT
ASSOCIATION STRONG SUPPORT.
GIVE ME OVERSEE WHAT THE
SOUTHEAST ASIA RESOURCE ACTION
CENTER AND STRONG SUPPORT.
RESIDENTS ALSO BEHALF OF THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SOCIAL WORKERS.
MARIO GUERRERO ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION A
STRONG SUPPORT.
A NURSING HIM ON BEHALF OF THE
UCC ASSOCIATION IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
CALL ME A PHASE USES TO
ASSOCIATIONS REALLY STRONG
SUPPORT.
OUR MONDO LEYVA YOU SIX
DIFFERENT OFFICIAL STRONGLY
SUPPORT.
ANGEL MARTINEZ CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY WE ARE WORKING WITH
THE AUTHOR WE APPRECIATE THE
CONVERSATIONS WE'VE HAD WITH THE
AUTHOR.
ON THE BILL WITH THE SUPPORT OF
A OF A PREVIOUS LEGISLATION
LEGISLATION SB ONE SIX NINE
SUPPORTER NIGHT SIX SEVEN AS
WELL.
BUT WE DO HAVE SOME CONCERNS
WITH THE SOME OF THE PROVISIONS
THE BILL THEY RELATE MORE TO
JUDICIARY SIDE OF THE BILL
CONCEPTS OF RIGHT OF ACTION THE
LIST OF ATTORNEYS SO WE'D LIKE
TO ORDER THE AUTHOR IS BLOOM WAS
FOR THE NEXT COMMITTEE.
ALEX GRAYS AT THE ICC ON THE
INTEREST OF TIME I WOULD JUST
ECHO WHAT MY COUNTERPART FROM
CSU SAID THANK YOU.
JUSTIN SILICON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
CHANCES OFFICE WERE SUPPORTIVE
OF THE INTENT AND WILL CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH THE AUTHOR.
BRIAN MACKLIN YOUTH COMMUNITY
COLLEGE WE GET CALIFORNIA I'M
JUST HERE TO COOK MY COMMENTS --
ECHO THE COMMENTS MY COLLEAGUES
ON THE OTHER SYSTEMS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT -- ANY OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL.
PLEASE COME FORWARD
.
BEGIN WHENEVER YOU'RE READY YOU
EACH HAVE TWO MINUTES BUT I
THINK WE WENT A LITTLE OVER ON
THE SUPPORT SO WE CAN GO A
LITTLE OVER AS WELL.
EXACTLY TEN MINUTES AND FIFTY
ONE SECONDS IS WHAT THE WHAT SO
I WOULD REQUEST THAT WE GET AT
LEAST TEN MINUTES IF NEEDED I
DON'T THINK WE'LL NEED THAT ACT
WELL YOU KNOW WHAT IT'S NOW WE
WE TWO MINUTES EACH WE WE DIDN'T
INTERRUPT HER TESTIMONY.
WE'D LIKE YOU TO TRY AND STICK
TO TWO MINUTES WILL LET YOU GO A
LITTLE BIT OVER BUT WHAT I CAN
DO A SOLID TEN MINUTES THANK YOU.
VERY GOOD.
FIRST OF ALL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
LISTENING TO US IS SEEING US
TODAY I THINK YOU ALSO.
CENTER WILK OF VICE CHAIR SO I
AM HERE TODAY.
I'M A MOM JUSTICE CENTER JACKSON --
STATED NOT ONLY REPRESENTING MY
SON WHO WAS WRONGFULLY ACCUSED
OF SEXUAL MISCONDUCT AND
ULTIMATELY.
KICKED OUT OF SCHOOL.
BUT I'M REALLY HERE ALSO BECAUSE
HIS TIME IS PAST THAT WAS BACK
IN TWENTY FIFTEEN NOTHING I CAN
DO FOR HIM NOW.
BUT ALSO I AM REPRESENTING THE
OTHER SEVENTY YOUNG OVER SEVENTY
YOUNG MEN AND WOMEN IN OUR
FAMILY SUPPORT GROUP WHO
ATTENDED A COLLEGE -- A
CALIFORNIA COLLEGE WRONGFULLY
ACCUSED AND SUSPENDED OR
EXPELLED WITH THEIR LIVES
CHANGED FOREVER.
WE OPPOSE US BEFORE NINE THREE
WHICH SEEMS TO BE A DO OVER TO
SOME EXTENT OF SB.
ONE SIX NINE WHICH WAS ALSO OF
COURSE AUTHORIZED BY SENATOR
JACKSON AND ULTIMATELY VETOED BY
GOVERNOR BROWN.
AND DURING THAT VETO PROCESS --
HE HE PUT TOGETHER AN EXPERT
PANEL OF FOLKS TO DIG INTO THIS
ISSUES QUICK GOV MORE TO SEE
WHAT THINGS.
ARE THE RIGHT THING TO DO THEY
CAME UP WITH A FORMAL LETTER
WHICH ALL OF YOU HAVE IN YOUR
OFFICES.
THAT WE SENT OVER OVER THE PAST
WEEK.
THAT TALKED ABOUT TWENTY
DIFFERENT ITEMS TO DIG INTO A
DRESS AND AS FAR AS WE CAN SEE
I'LL SEE IN OPPOSITION TO WHAT
SENATOR JACKSON JUST SAID WE'RE
NOT SEEING MUCH.
OF THOSE RECOMMENDATIONS PUT
INTO SB -- FOUR NINE THREE I CAN
ALSO SAY THAT WHAT'S INTERESTING
ABOUT THIS CONCEPT IN THE MOST
RECENT SCALE THAT WAS UP HERE
TALKING WE ARE NOT IN A POSITION
OF INVESTIGATING FIRST OF ALL IT
SOUNDS LIKE WHATEVER CAL POLY
WAS IT.
THEY DID A HORRIBLE JOB HORRIBLE
JOB I CAN TELL YOU I'VE BEEN AND
I'VE BEEN A A MENTOR OR SOMEONE
IN SUPPORT OF SOME OF THESE
YOUNG MEN THAT HAVE HAD TO GO UP
IN FRONT OF THESE HEARING PANELS
PRETTY SCARY. FOR THEM A LOT
SCARIER THAN THIS AND SALES A
STATE.
THEY'RE DOING IT RIGHT I WAS
THERE AND THEY HAVE THEIR OWN
POLICIES AND PROCEDURES AND WE
WALKED AWAY AND I SAID I'M SORRY.
THEY DID IT RIGHT WHAT THE RIGHT
WAY.
THAT GIRL WAS RAILROADED.
AND THAT'S NOT WHY WE'RE HERE
WE'RE HERE BECAUSE OF THE
WRONGFULLY ACCUSED STUDENTS AND
A LACK OF DUE PROCESS THAT
CONTINUES TO BE IN PLACE.
IT WAS IN PLACE AND WOULD BE
PERPETUATED IN SB ONE SIX NINE
IT WOULD BE PERPETUATED HERE AND
SB.
FOUR NINE THREE WE URGE EVERYONE
ON THIS COMMITTEE.
TO CHALLENGE SENATOR JACKSON TO
WORK WITH THE OPPOSITION AND PUT
SOME REAL.
OF A TAKE THESE RECOMMENDATIONS
FROM THE VARIOUS GROUPS THIS
EXPERT PANEL AS WELL AS OTHER
GROUPS.
AND WORK ON A BETTER BILL IT CAN
BE DONE WE WOULD LOVE TO WORK
WITH HER ON THIS.
I KNOW THAT MOST OF THE CENTERS
ON THIS PANEL YOU'VE GOT KIDS.
WITH THEIR COLLEGE AGE THERE
SENATOR WILK YOU'VE GOT AN ADULT
OF SUN TO ADULT WE IDEA APPEARS
YOUR DAUGHTER AND YOUR SON --
AND HOPEFULLY THEY WERE ON
SKATES DOES THEY WENT TO THEIR
COLLEGE CAREERS IN BEING --
ACCUSE OF SOME SORT OF SEXUAL
HARASSMENT OR SEXUAL MISCONDUCT
I CAN TELL YOU FOR OUR KIDS THAT
WENT THROUGH THIS SUICIDE
[inaudible]
SUICIDE IDEATION.
SUICIDE ATTEMPTS PTSD.
I'M JUST TALKING ABOUT.
THE FOLKS I KNOW I KNOW.
pMENTION THAT I'M ALSO
REPRESENTING.
THEY ALSO HAD THE SAME SCARS
THAT THEY HAVE BEEN HAVING TO
DEAL WITH.
AND I THINK IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT TO KNOW THAT AS WE
TAKE A LOOK AT POTENTIALLY
MOVING THIS BILL ALONG I WANT
YOU TO THINK OF A FEW THINGS.
FIRST SINCE TWO OF TWENTY
SEVENTEEN EARLY TWENTY SEVENTEEN
ONE CENTER JACKSON FIRST
INTRODUCED SB ONE SIX NINE SINCE
THEN.
THERE HAVE BEEN AT LEAST FIVE
CALIFORNIA COURTS OF APPEAL AND
NUMEROUS CALIFORNIA SUPERIOR
COURT COURTS.
HAVE FOUND BOTH PUBLIC AND
PRIVATE SCHOOLS SEXUAL
MISCONDUCT DISCIPLINARY PROCESS
FATALLY FLAWED.
BUT THEY CREATE AN UNACCEPTABLE
UNACCEPTABLE RISK OF BIAS STRAY
SO FAR FROM THE PRINCIPLES THAT
UNDERLIE OUR DEMOCRACY AND HAVE
COMPLETELY OBLITERATED DUE
PROCESS THIS IS SINCE THIS SB
ONE SIX NINE WAS BORN.
THIS IS IN CALIFORNIA
[inaudible]
ALSO.
CALIFORNIA AFRICAN AMERICAN
MOTHER.
OF AN INNOCENT TRAUMATIZED
SEVENTEEN YEAR OLD WHO ATTEMPTED
SUICIDE ONCE TOLD US THIS FAMILY
SUPPORT GROUP THAT I BELONG. TO
FOR US IT'S JUST MORE OF THE
SAME AND EXPERTS AGREE CAMPUS
SEXUAL MISCONDUCT POLICIES
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACT
MINORITIES UNDERSERVED IN FIRST
GENERATION COLLEGE STUDENTS.
I'M NOT SEEING ANYTHING
SUBSTANTIAL IN SB -- ONE SIX
SKEWS ME FOUR NINE THREE TO
CHANGE THAT IT WAS IN ONE SIX
NINE EITHER.
SO NO MATTER YOUR PARTY
AFFILIATION PLEASE PLEASE
UNDERSTAND WE WANT YOU TO SAY NO
TO THIS BILL.
ASK SENATOR JACKSON TO GO BACK
TO THE DRAWING BOARD.
FISH AND WORK WITH THOSE THAT
HAVE BETTER IDEAS WORK WITH
THOSE THAT WORKED WITH THIS TASK
FORCE AND LET'S MAKE A BETTER
BILL WE WOULD LIKE THAT THANK
YOU.
NEXT WITNESS IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE.
I LIKE TO BEGIN WAS SENT -- I
THINK WE ALL CAN AGREE THAT --
ONE INSTANCE ARE ONE EXAMPLE.
OF SEXUAL ASSAULT ON ACCOUNT
WHICH CAMPUS IS ONE TOO MANY.
I WILL SHARE MY EXPERIENCE WITH
YOU GUYS. SIX YEARS AGO TO THE
DATE.
I WAS FALSELY ACCUSED OF SEXUAL
HARASSMENT.
SO THIS WOULD HAPPEN OF THOSE
FALSELY ACCUSED I WAS EXPELLED.
WITHOUT ANY PROCESS.
WITHOUT ANY HEARING.
THERE'S NOTHING JUST BY BOAT
[inaudible]
SO.
WHEN IT COMES THIS ISSUE -- FOUR
NINE THREE MY CONCERN IS THE
PROCESS.
I THINK WE ALL CAN AGREE A LIKE
THE WOMAN SAT BEFORE ME SAID
THAT THE SYSTEM IS BROKEN AND
HER AND I BOTH CAN AGREE.
AT THE I WAS SUSPENDED I WAS
GIVEN NOTHING.
NO PROCESS NOT HEARING ANYTHING
OF THE ONLY THING I WAS OF TO DO
WAS JUST APPEAL TO THE STATE
BOARD OF REGENTS.
AND ULTIMATELY LED TO ME --
REPRESENTING MYSELF IN FEDERAL
COURT -- CASE DISMISSED.
HERE'S WHY.
AS WE ALL KNOW IT SEEMS LIKE
EVERYONE IS TESTIFIED BEFORE YOU
GUYS AWARE OF THE OF
DISADVANTAGES THAT COMES WITH --
COME FROM A FAMILY OF LESSER
MEANS AND THE ALSO IN HER
DISADVANTAGE OF BEING OF AN
AFRICAN AMERICAN MALE.
WE HAVE AN AMERICAN MILLION RISK
YOU ACCUSE WHETHER SURE NOT OF
SEXUAL ASSAULT AND HARASSMENT.
THE AUTOMATICALLY OPPORTUNITY.
NO MYSTERY STORY -- NO TURNING
WAS TO REPRESENT YOU.
THAT WAS SIX YEARS AGO -- OVER
THE COURSE OF THE PAST SIX YEARS
UP TO A LOT OF OUR WORK IN
CONGRESS -- BUT THE STATE
LEGISLATURES WELL -- WE RAISE
THE ISSUE OF FALSE ACCUSATIONS
TO NATIONAL PROFILE.
AND THE NATIONAL PROFILE OTHER
STATES ARE BEGINNING. TO TO
FOLLOW SUIT AND MAKE CHANGES OF
MISSOURI -- FOR ONE CALIFORNIA
HOPEFULLY -- FOR TO ANDREW
SITTING NEXT TO ME SHE WAS JUST
A BILL -- ONE SIXTY NINE WE'VE
HAD MEETINGS WITH -- CHAIRMAN
LEYVA AS WELL AS SENATOR JACKSON
AND ALMOST OF RESPECT YOUR
EFFORT.
BUT I THINK THE FOCUS SHOULD BE
ON UP.
GETTING THE PROCESS CORRECT.
IT'S SO FRUSTRATING SO BEFORE
YOU GUYS IN AND OUT HERE THIS
ISSUE TURNED INTO A PARTISAN
ISSUE THE NECESSARY POLITICAL
PARTISAN BUT EITHER YOU'RE A
VICTIM ADVOCATE OR YOU ARE A
REBEL POLISHES.
NOW LET'S ALL AGREE RAPE IS A
HARMFUL THAT NEVER GOT THE FOR
PROCES WE'RE NOT SITTING HERE
ACROSS AND YOU GUYS IN
OPPOSITION FROM SENATOR JACKSON
WERE SAYING HEY.
I ECHO THE WOMAN THE SEVEN FOR
ME SAID THE PROCESS IS BROKEN
BECAUSE IF YOU'RE HIT WITH A
FALSE ACCUSATION.
LET ME TELL YOU MY LIFE HAS BEEN
EVER SINCE SIX YEARS LATER ONE
THE FIRST THING THAT HAPPENS.
ACADEMIC DEATH PENALTY.
CAN TRANSFER TO ANOTHER COLLEGE
MY UNIVERSITY WAS FORCED ENOUGH
TO ALLOW ME TO COMPLETE THE
FINAL REMAINING CLASS ONLINE.
ADAM THIS IS A BECOME A LAWYER
APPLY TO TWENTY LAW SCHOOLS
REJECTED BY NINETEEN ONLY
ACCEPTED THE ONE AFTER REACHED
OUT AND FIND A SYMPATHETIC LAW
SCHOOL DEAN THOSE SYMPATHETIC TO
MY SITUATION.
THAT WAS A STRUGGLE THAT I HAD
TO DO TO GET INTO LAW SCHOOL NOW
HERE WE ARE ON TURN THE CORNER.
AS FAR AS THE PRESS PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT IS CONCERNED AND I'M
LOOKING FOR JOBS AND ULTIMATELY
AN ADMIN SO THE CALIFORNIA STATE
BAR.
NOW EVERY JOB THAT I'VE APPLIED
FOR INCLUDING THE CALIFORNIA
STATE BAR THERE IS A BOX THAT
YOU HAVE TO CHECK THIS SAYS HAVE
YOU BEEN ACCUSED.
OR HAVE YOU COMMITTED AN
INSTANCE OF SEXUAL VIOLENCE OR
ASSAULT.
I HAVE THE CHECK YES IN THAT BOX.
HERE IT IS -- INTERNSHIP FOR THE
SUMMER IS A RESPECTED LAW FIRMS
AND I'M GETTING SO THE SAME
KNOWS I GOT SO WHEN I WAS
APPLYING.
OF POSSIBLE REACHING OUT.
A PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE HAD
INTEREST IN ME YOU WANT TO BEAT
UP ON HIS CAMPAIGN AND THE FIRST
QUESTION THAT HE ACTS.
OF A VERY SOFT VETTING PROCESS
WAS.
DO YOU HAVE ANY ISSUES OF SEXUAL
ASSAULT AND HARASSMENT AND
ANSWER THAT IS HONEST YES.
BUT I WAS FALSELY ACCUSED.
I SPEND MY SCENARIO I I TOTAL MY
MY MY ADVOCACY EFFORTS YEARS OF
HISTORY INCLUDING A MISSILE LAW
SCHOOL AND HE SAYS I'M SORRY.
WE HAVE TO IN THIS RELATIONSHIP
HERE AND I CAN ONLY TELL THEM
UNDERSTAND.
IN THE NATIONAL LANDSCAPING AS
FAR AS CURRENT EVENTS ARE
CONCERNED.
I THINK WE ALL CAN AGREE THE
CLIMATE IS CHANGED -- FALSE
ACCUSATIONS ARE VERY REAL
REALITY NO ONE WANTS TO BE WEAK
ON ACCUSATIONS OF SEXUAL ASSAULT.
FALSE ACCUSATION WITHOUT PROCESS
THEY AFFECT US ALL -- SITTING
STANDING MEMBERS FORMER SENATOR
MINNESOTA OUR RANKIN RESIGNED
WITHOUT PROCESS LIEUTENANT
GOVERNOR OF VIRGINIA.
IT'S BORDERLINE WE DON'T KNOW
AND AS WE KNOW NO FORMER VICE
PRESIDENT CURRENT EVENT JOE
BIDEN.
WELL JOHN AS HE WAS GOING TO
HAPPEN WITH HIM.
MY HEART GOES OUT TO THOSE THREE
AND MARK WAS OUT EVERYONE IS
SIMILARLY SITUATED TO ME EVEN
VICTIMS OF SEXUAL ASSAULT.
I ALEX.
ANALYSTS HERE OR THIS WITH THIS
IS A COMMITTEE I'M SORRY
[inaudible]
BOOKS -- STAY BILL.
FOR NINETY THREE I RESPECT THE
EFFORT PUSHED A SMALL SLICE IN
THE MIDDLE OF SAYS LET'S GET THE
PROCESS RIGHT.
WE ALL CAN AGREE THE RAPE IS.
AN ACTUAL -- PEOPLE TO COMMIT
SEXUAL ASSAULT OR WILL PEOPLE.
MY CONCERN THE CONCERNS
ORGANIZATION IS LET'S GET THE
PROCESS RIGHT AND WE WANT TO
HELP TO MAKE SURE.
THAT THE STATE CREATE SELENITE
PROCEDURES THAT ARE DESIGNED. TO
MAXIMIZE THE LIKELIHOOD OF A
RELIABLE AND ACCURATE DECISION
MAKING CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION NAME ORGANIZATION AND
OPPOSITION.
JONDO STRONGLY OPPOSED PARENT
MAY I TAKE THIRTY SECONDS OF
YOUR TIME [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I'M A CALIFORNIA MOTHER I HAVE A
SON AND A DAUGHTER BOTH THAT
CALIFORNIA COLLEGES NAME.
OR I CANNOT GIVE YOU MY NAY AS
FOR FEAR OF HARMING MY SON WHO
WAS FALSELY ACCUSED BUT I
STRONGLY OPPOSE FOR NINETY CURE
ME.
AND TRY TO MAKE YOUR PRACTICES
IN OR YOU'RE GUILTY PRESUMING
FROM THE BEGINNING OF AMBASSADOR
GAVE YOU MA'AM WE DO HAVE RULES
AND REGULATIONS HERE I'M SORRY
YOU FOR YOUR TIME THANK YOU.
NAME ORGANIZATION OPPOSITION
THIS IS NARROW SO I'M ALSO IN
STRONG OPPOSITION OF THIS MY SON
WAS FALSELY ACCUSED OF A KISS
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU OPERATE BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS
CONCERNS.
DOCTOR PAN.
SENATE JACKSON I KNOW THAT --
YOU'VE WORKED VERY HARD ON THIS
ISSUE AND I KNOW THAT ALSO --
YOU'RE SOMEONE WHO'S -- AS A WHO
VERY MUCH VALUES -- THE
IMPORTANCE OF THE APPROPRIATE
JUDICIAL PROCESS IN FACT TEACHER.
THE DISTRICT COMMITTEE -- NIGHT
THE OPPOSITION.
I THINK YOU MADE A POINT ABOUT --
WHAT THE WITNESSES ACTUALLY I
DON'T IS GINGER TEACHER SELF AND
YEAH MY NAME IS JOSEPH?
OKAY I THANK YOU -- SO CERTAINLY
I THINK ON ONE LEVEL I THINK --
ONE CAN ARGUE THAT THERE THIS
MAY BE ADMINISTRATIVE PROCESS
BUT SEEMS OUT FREE SIGNIFICANT
CONSEQUENCES ON RIGHT I MEAN --
SILICON SOURCES ALL THE PLACES
CONTINUE PERHAPS SPEAK A LITTLE
BIT TO THAT -- THERE THE ISSUE
ABOUT -- ON ONE LEVEL OF COURSE
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT SCHOOLS AND
THEIR PROCESSES WHICH ARE YOU
KNOW WHEN TO SAY AS OUR MINISTRY
TO EVENTS AND I FEEL SO WELL
THIS ADMINISTRATIVE CRIMINAL
WHAT STANDARD TO USE BUT THAT
SAME TIME THE LEVEL CONSEQUENCES
AND IT'S NOT GOING TO JAIL. FIVE
I MEAN CERTAINLY IS VERY
SIGNIFICANT TO CAN YOU SPEAK TO
THAT SURE AND THAT'S WHY WE WILL
THAT'S WHY PART OF WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO HERE IS SET UP AN
APPROPRIATE ADMINISTRATOR.
APPROPRIATE ADMINISTRATIVE
PROCESS.
THAT GIVES BOTH SIDES THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT THEIR
CASE -- THAT MAKE SURE THAT
THERE ARE PROCEDURES FOLLOWED
WHERE THE FACTS CAN BE
ASCERTAINED IN A A NON BIASED OR
I SHOULD SAY IMPARTIAL.
ACCURATE AND FAIR MANNER SO THAT
THE PROCESS THAT THEN.
IN SHOES IS ONE THAT GETS TO THE
ACCURACY OF THE ALLEGATIONS AND
THE RESPONSE TO THOSE
ALLEGATIONS AND THEN A FINDING
BASED UPON A DETERMINATION OF
WHETHER IT'S MORE LIKELY THAN
NOT THAT THE EVENT OCCURRED.
AND ALSO IT ADDRESSES THE FACT
THAT EACH INSTITUTION -- IS ABLE
TO SET FOR THE ITS OWN --
RESPONSES ONCE A FINDING IS MADE.
SO WE HEARD THE THE VICTIM OF
THIS ASSAULT.
TESTIFIED SHE HAD TO SEE THE HER
RAPIST EVERY DAY -- AND YOU
DIDN'T HEAR HER ASKING TO HAVE
THAT PERSON -- REMOVED FROM
CAMPUS TRANSOCEAN HAVE TO DEAL
WITH THAT ON A DAILY BASIS.
THE WHOLE NOTION OF TRAUMA BASED --
A SENSITIVITY SO THAT A SHE HAD
NEEDS TO TALK WITH PEOPLE AND
POTENTIALLY A NEED TO HAVE
THERAPY WHICH OBVIOUSLY WE SEE A
LOT 34% OF WOMEN WHO ARE RAPED
ON COLLEGE CAMPUSES WILL DROP
OUT OF SCHOOL.
IN GREAT MEASURE THAT'S BECAUSE
THEY ARE NOT.
ABLE OR NOR SHOULD WE ASK THEM
TO HAVE TO FACE.
THEIR PERPETRATOR ON A DAILY
BASIS OR OFTENTIMES ARE IN THE
SAME DORM IN THE SENT THE
REQUEST OF THE VICTIM IS LOOK I
JUST DON'T WANT TO HAVE TO SEE
THIS PERSON.
WHEN I WAKE UP IN THE MORNING IT
CAN BE?
A KIND OF A SEVERITY THAT WOULD
JUSTIFY -- OF FREQUENTLY TO THE
EXTENT THAT SCHOOLS HAVE EVEN
BOTHERED TO TRY TO TAKE THESE
CASES SERIOUSLY AND I THINK WE
HAVE TO START FROM THAT
FUNDAMENTAL PRINT PREMISE.
IS THAT SCHOOLS ARE STILL THERE
EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTIONS.
THIS IS A WHAT THEY ARE AND
KNOWN.
FOR AND THE FACT THAT WE ARE NOW
REQUIRING THAT THEY TAKE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THE STUDENTS
WHO ATTEND THEIR SCHOOLS.
THIS IS A ROAD MAP TO GIVE THEM
OF THE KIND OF TOOLS THEY NEED
TO DO THIS RIGHT.
THE BES WAY TO DO THIS WOUD BE
TO HAVE ALL THESE CASES TAKEN
INTO CRIMINAL COURT AND WE HAVE
A SYSTEM THERE THAT'S ALREADY
WELL ESTABLISHED.
BUT MOST OF THESE VICTIMS DON'T
WANT TO DO THAT.
AND WHAT OUR ULTIMATE GOAL IS TO
STOP THIS KIND OF BEHAVIOR ON
OUR COLLEGE CAMPUSES ONE IN FIVE
WOMEN.
ARE SEXUALLY ASSAULTED DURING
THE COURSE OF THEIR CAREER.
AND ONE IN FOURTEEN MEN.
SO WE HAVE AN EPIDEMIC.
THIS BILL TRIES TO ADDRESS THE
FACT THAT.
NUMBER ONE THIS DOES OCCUR.
NUMBER TWO WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT THERE IS TO PROCESS FOR
BOTH SIDES AND I THINK THAT.
THERE IS CHOOSE ME THAT COMMON
THREAD EVERYBODY WANTS TO HAVE A
FAIR PROCESS THAT'S WHAT THIS
BILL IS DESIGNED TO DO IS TO
CREATE A FAIR PROCESS.
RECOGNIZING THE NEEDS OF VICTIMS
AND OF OF SURVIVORS OF
RECOGNIZING THAT FOR MOST
SURVIVORS RAPE IS A TRAUMATIC
EXPERIENCE.
AND THAT WE NEED TO ADDRESS IT
IS SUCH.
AN TO RECOGNIZE TO THAT THERE
ARE SOMETIMES DIFFERENT POINTS
OF VIEW AND THAT THOSE POINTS OF
VIEW SHOULD BE ABLE TO BE
PRESENTED TO WIN IT TO A AN
INDEPENDENT NON BIASED FACT
FINDER.
AND THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL TRIES
TO DO.
CAN I RESPOND PLEASE NO THANK
YOU SENATOR JACKSON ANY OTHER
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
MA'AM WE WILL ASK YOU TO BE
REMOVED IF YOU CANNOT CONDUCT
YOURSELF PROPERLY.
THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE FROM THE COMMITTEE
SENATOR DORADO.
SENATE JACKSON -- THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR RAISING THIS ISSUE AND
PROCEEDING TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT
IT.
BOB AND I KNOW THAT YOU ARE A
STAUNCH CHAMPION FOR CIVIL
RIGHTS AND FOR EVERYBODY TO BE
TREATED -- RIGHT.
WE ALSO KNOW.
THAT IN THE JUDICIAL SYSTEM
[inaudible]
THAT.
THE JAILS AND THE PRISONS ARE
FULL OF PEOPLE OF COLOR
PRIMARILY MEN OF COLOR BUT THAT
IS ALSO PART OF OUR THE BAD SIDE.
OF OUR JUDICIAL SYSTEM AS WE
KNOW THAT RACISM HAS PLAYED A
BIG ROLE IN A MUCH BIGGER ROLE
THAN IT SHOULD WHICH IS THE
OTHER.
EXTREME OF HOW VICTIMS AND WOMEN
ARE TREATED.
HOW DO YOU RESPOND TO THAT HOW
DO YOU AND AND AND I KNOW YOU
YOU JUST MENTIONED MAYBE EXPLAIN
A LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT THE DUE
PROCESS RIGHT RIGHT TO MAKE SURE?
THAT EVERYONE STE EVERYONE HAS
THAT DAY IN COURT IT WILL
DOESN'T FEEL THEY'VE BEEN LEFT
OUT I AM I DON'T KNOW IF YOU
WERE HERE WHEN I MENTIONED THAT
THE BILL ALSO REQUIRES SCHOOLS
TO PROVIDE TRAINING TO EMPLOYEES
ENGAGED IN THIS PROCEDURE.
ON BOTH A TRAUMA INFORMED BEST
PRACTICES AS WELL AS TRAINING ON
IMPLICIT BIAS.
IN THE HISTORY OF INSTITUTIONAL
RACISM AND RACIAL INEQUITIES IN
SCHOOL DISCIPLINARY PROCESS SEES
SO THAT WE HAVE THAT.
AT SO THAT WE HAVE THAT --
CONSCIOUSNESS AND RECOGNIZE THAT
THERE ARE INSTANCES WHERE THEIR
ASSUMPTIONS MADE IMPROPERLY --
BASED UPON.
RACIAL BIASES -- I WOULD ALSO
LIKE TO MENTION TOO THAT THE
DISTANT TEST TAKES AN AFRICAN
AMERICAN WOMEN.
BEING THE VICTIMS OF THE SEXUAL
VIOLENCE ARE I THINK EVEN HIGHER
THAN A WEEK WOMEN WHO ARE NOT OF
COLOR.
SO AGAIN THIS IS SOMETHING WHERE
WE WE NEED TO EDUCATE OURSELVES
AND WE NEED TO EDUCATE THOSE WHO
ARE GOING TO BE ASKED.
TO INITIATE AND TO CONDUCT THOSE
PROCEEDING SO THAT THEY CAN BE.
AS ACCURATE AND THIS FACT DRIVEN
AS HUMANLY POSSIBLE.
THANK YOU CENTER JACKSON ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS OF
THE COMMITTEE.
VERY GOOD SIR JACKSON WHICH IS
OUR MOTION.
THANK YOU SENATOR RAZA SENATE
JACKSON WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS I KNOW THIS IS A
DIFFICULT.
ISSUE OF THE THAT -- IF IF THIS
WERE PERFECT WORLD WOULD BE ABLE
TO JUST SORT OF PUT A THUMB
PRINT THAN WOULD FIND OUT
WHETHER PEOPLE ARE TELLING THE
TRUTH THAT WE'RE NOT TELLING THE
TRUTH.
BUDGET -- THAT ISN'T SO THE
WORLD WE LIVE IN BUT WHAT WE CAN
DO AND WHAT THIS BILL TRIES TO
DO.
IS MAKE THIS PROCESS AS FAIR AND
ACCURATE AS POSSIBLE -- I THINK
AT THE END OF THE DAY WE'RE ALL
LOOKING FOR THE SAME RESULTS AS
THE CHAIR OF THE SENATE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE IS SOMEONE
WHO.
HAS SPENT.
SEE I'VE BEEN AN ATTORNEY FOR OF
NEVER MIND A LONG TIME OVER
THIRTY YEARS -- PROBABLY CLOSER --
TO FORTY I AM COMMITTED. TO THE
TO THE METHOD BY WHICH WE BRING.
TO TO JUSTICE AS ACCURATELY AS
FAIRLY AND AS CONSISTENTLY AS WE
POSSIBLY CAN.
WITH THE ULTIMATE GOAL THAT WE
WILL MAKE IT CLEAR THIS BEHAVIOR
IS NOT ACCEPTABLE ON OUR
CAMPUSES WILL NOT BE TOLERATED.
AND THAT AT THE END OF THE DAY
WE WILL NOT HAVE TO HAVE THESE
KINDS OF PROCEEDINGS GOING
FORWARD SO WE DO KNOW THOUGH
THAT SEXUAL HARASSMENT AND
ASSAULT IMPEDED STUDENTS RIGHT
TO PURSUE AND RECEIVE AN
EDUCATION.
IN A SAFE NON DISCRIMINATORY
ENVIRONMENT THAT'S THE EDUCATION
PART OF THIS AND THIS MEASURE
PROVIDES A BASELINE PROCESS FOR
HIGHER EDUCATION STUDENTS WHEN
IT COMES TO ENFORCEMENT OF THEIR
CIVIL RIGHTS. TO BE AN EQUITABLE
PROCESS AND TO BE TO GIVE
EQUITABLE ACCESS TO EDUCATION
AND THE PROTECTIONS THAT WE HAVE
BEEN TRYING TO IN TITLE NINE AND
ITS IMPLEMENTING REGULATIONS.
HAVE BEEN AND WILL CONTINUE TO
BE AN IMPORTANT TOOL FOR
STUDENTS SURVIVORS AND ADVOCATES
HELPING TO MAKE OUR CAMPUSES A
SAFER SPACE FOR STUDENTS.
AND THIS MEASURE I BELIEVE
CONTINUE SAID IMPORTANT WORKING
WITH THAT I WOULD RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR JACKSON THE
BILLS WERE MOVED BY SENATOR
DORADO MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
ITEM FOURTEEN AS BEFORE NINETY
THREE THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
JUDICIARY LEYVA.
LEYVA AYE WILK WILK AYE CHIANG
CHIANG I'D WOULD ASAL.
JUDGE RASOUL AYE GLAZER MCGUIRE
MCGUIRE AYE PAN.
PAN AYE.
BELIEVE THAT BILL ON CALL BUT IT
DOES HAVE ENOUGH VOTES TO GET
OUT THANK YOU CENTER JACQUI
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
NEXT UP IS SENATOR BATES.
SENATOR BATES PERCY WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
PERCENT.
SB.
FIVE FORTY ONE ARE I AM I WOULD
LIKE TO START BY ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS WHICH
APPEAR ON PAGE FOUR OF THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS.
AS AMENDED SB FIVE FORTY ONE
REQUIRES ALL KINDERGARTEN
THROUGH TWELFTH GRADE PUBLIC AND
PRIVATE SCHOOLS WITH AN
ENROLLMENT OF FIFTY OR MORE
STUDENTS TO CONDUCT ONE LOCKDOWN
DRILL PER SCHOOL YEAR.
GIVEN THE UNFORTUNATE THREATS TO
CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS TODAY'S
STUDENT VOLUNTEERS STAFF
TEACHERS AND ADMINISTRATORS
CANNOT BE PREPARED ENOUGH FOR
THE UNKNOWN.
FROM DEVASTATING WILDFIRES TO
ACTIVE SHOOTERS ON CAMPUS WE
NEED TO ENSURE THAT ALL PEOPLE
ON SCHOOL CAMPUSES ARE PREPARED
TO ACT IMMEDIATELY WHEN
CHILDREN'S UTMOST SAFETY IN MIND.
EXISTING EDUCATION CODE REQUIRES
ELEMENTARY SCHOOLS TO CONDUCT
FIRE DRILLS REGULARLY AN
INTERMEDIATE LEVEL AND SECONDARY
SCHOOLS AT LEAST TWICE A YEAR.
EXISTING STATUTE HOWEVER DOES
NOT REQUIRE TRAINING FOR ANY
OTHER TYPES OF THREATS THAT MAY
OCCUR ON A CAMPUS.
THAT MADE JEOPARDIZE THE SAFETY
OF ALL ON CAMPUS SOME SCHOOL
DISTRICTS HAVE TAKEN IT UPON
THEMSELVES TO PROVIDE THIS
TRAINING.
BUT IT IS CRITICAL FOR ALL OF
OUR SCHOOLS AND CHILDREN TO BE
PREPARED FOR EVERY SITUATION.
LAST YEAR TREMENDOUS STRIDES ARE
WERE MADE IN THE LEGISLATURE TO
ADDRESS SCHOOL SAFETY BUT
MEASURES A LACK TO A REQUIREMENT
TO CONDUCT A LOCKDOWN DRILLS.
I AUTHORED SB TWELVE ALL THREE
AND TWENTY EIGHTEEN THAT PASSES
COMMITTEE ON THE SENATE FLOOR
UNANIMOUSLY WITH BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT.
SB FIVE FORTY ONE IS NEEDED TO
ENSURE ALL CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS
ARE MEETING A BASIC STANDARD TO
HAVE ANNUAL LOCKDOWN TRAININGS
ON SITE IN ORDER TO BE PREPARED.
SERGEANT DERREN VERY I'M OUT
WITH THE ORANGE COUNTY SHERIFF'S
OFFICE IS HERE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SENATOR BATES PLEASE
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT PLEASE
PROCEED.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
MY NAME IS SERGEANT-- RAM AND I
AM PLEASEDTODAY TO REPRESENT
THE ORANGE COUNTY SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT IN SUPPORT OF SB FIVE
FORTY ONE WHICH REQUIRES ONE
LOCKDOWN DRILL PER YEAR IN ALL
K. THROUGH TWELVE SCHOOLS WITH
FIFTY STUDENTS ARE MORE.
IN MY CAPACITY AS A SERGEANT
WITH THE SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT I
OVERSEE THE SCHOOL MOBILE SAYS
MATT RESOURCE TEAM ALSO KNOWN AS
SMART.
THIS UNIT RESPONSE ALL INCIDENTS
RELATED TO VIOLENCE THREATS OF
VIOLENCE POSSESSION AND OUR USE
OF WEAPONS UNSTABLE BEHAVIORS
AND SUICIDAL ACTIONS ARE
TENDENCIES.
THAT POSE A THREAT TO OTHERS AT
K. TWELVE SCHOOLS.
THE ORANGE COUNTY SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT'S JURISDICTION
INCLUDES THE LARGE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS OF CAPISTRANO AND
SETTLE BACK VALLEY AND PORTIONS
OF MANY NORTH ORANGE COUNTY
SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
I SUPERVISE ALL OUR SCHOOL
RESOURCE OFFICERS AND DALY
INTERACT WITH OUR EDUCATIONAL
PARTNERS.
THE EFFORTS OF SMART AND SIMILAR
INITIATIVES HAVE BEEN SUCCESSFUL
IN IDENTIFYING AND ELIMINATING
THREATS.
FROM TWENTY FIFTEEN TO TWENTY
SEVENTEEN SMART FIELDED FOUR
HUNDRED AND SIXTY NINE CALLS FOR
SERVICE.
WHICH INCLUDED INVESTIGATING
THREATS AS WELL AS INVESTIGATING
REPORTS OF WEAPONS ON CAMPUS AND
OTHER ILLEGAL ACTIVITY.
THE TEAM MADE A HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY THREE ARRESTS OVER THOSE
THREE YEARS AND A HUNDRED THIRTY
SEVEN OF THOSE STUDENTS WERE
MANDATED TO PARTICIPATE IN OUR
YOUTH OF OUR DIVERSION PROGRAM.
EVEN WITH THE BEST OF EFFORTS
AND SYSTEMS IN PLACE WE MUST
ALWAYS BE PREPARED FOR THE WORST
POSSIBILITY.
CREATION MEANS PRACTICE STUDENTS
FACULTY AND PARENTS.
MUST KNOW WHAT TO DO AND WAS
EXPECTED IN THE EVENT OF AN
ACTIVE SHOOTER OR OTHER
INCIDENTS OF VIOLENCE.
REQUIRE AN ACTIVE THREAT DRILLS
WILL SAVE LIVES.
WE KNOW THE STRATEGY OF REQUIRED
SAFETY DRILLS IN CALIFORNIA THE
SCHOOLS SCHOOLS ARE MANDATED.
TO TO REQUIRED FIRE DRILLS.
EVEN WITH THAT HEARINGS TO
STRICT FIRE CODE AND THE USE OF
FIRE SPRINKLERS SCHOOL FIRES CAN
OCCUR.
YES AS A RESULT THE SCHOOL FIRES
HOWEVER ARE RARE.
STUDENTS AND TEACHERS ARE WELL
VERSED IN WHAT TO DO DURING A
FIRE AND KNOW HOW TO SAFELY
EVACUATE BECAUSE THEY PRACTICE.
SIMILARLY WE MUST ENSURE
PRACTICES A CRANE WITH REGARDS
TO ACTIVE THREATS.
AS WE ANALYZE THE TRAGIC SCHOOL
SHOOTINGS OVER THE LAST FEW
YEARS LAW ENFORCEMENT IS ABLE TO
IDENTIFY COMMON THREADS IN
TACTICS USED BY THE SHOOTERS.
AS A RESULT WE ARE ABLE TO
DETERMINE THE BEST SAFETY
STRATEGIES THAT SHOULD BE
EMPLOYED IN ORDER TO ELIMINATE
OR REDUCE FATALITIES IN A
SHOOTING INCIDENT OR THREAT
OCCURRED.
IN ONE OF OUR LOCAL CAMPUSES.
THE BEST STRATEGIES HOWEVER ARE
USELESS UNLESS THE BROADER
SCHOOL COMMUNITY KNOWS WHAT TO
DO WHEN THEY ARE IN DANGER.
THE DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND
SECURITY'S RUN HIDE FIGHT
PROGRAM IS ONE SUCH EXAMPLE OF
THE USABLE STRATEGY.
IS STUDENTS AND TEACHERS ARE NOT
AWARE OF WHAT TO DO HOWEVER THE
STRATEGIES MEANING LESS.
THE LEGISLATION BEFORE YOU TODAY
IS AN EXCELLENT OPPORTUNITY FOR
THE STATE TO CODIFY A RECOGNIZE
A BEST PRACTICE INTO LAW.
SUCH A REQUIREMENT WILL ENSURE
THAT OUR SCHOOLS DEDICATE TIME
AT LEAST ONCE PER YEAR. TO
PREPARE FOR A MOMENT IN TIME
WHICH WE HOPE WILL NEVER OCCUR.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
TODAY.
THANK YOU I APOLOGIZE IT IN SAY
TWO MINUTES EACH SO IF YOU CAN
SIXTY TWO MINUTES PLEASE PICK IT
IS OKAY NOT YOUR FAULT.
AFTERNOON GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS AND MY NAME IS
YVONNE CARRY ON WITH THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS.
ACCESS SUPPORTS SB FIVE FOUR ONE
BECAUSE CONDUCTING LOCKDOWN
DRILLS AND BEING PREPARED TO
RESPOND ACTIVE THREATS SAVES
LIVES.
NOTHING BETTER EXEMPLIFIES THIS
THEN THE STORY OF RANCHO TO
HAMMER ELEMENTARY SCHOOL UP IN
CORNING CALIFORNIA.
IN NOVEMBER TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN A SHOOTER CAME ON A
CAMPUS JUST BEFORE THE START OF
SCHOOL.
MORE THAN ONE HUNDRED ROUNDS
WERE SHOT ON CAMPUS AN ATTEMPT
TO KILL SMALL CHILDREN AND STAFF.
THANK GOD NO ONE DIED THAT DAY.
THE SCHOOL COMMUNITY WILL BE THE
FIRST TO TELL YOU THAT THIS WAS
THE CASE BECAUSE THEY WERE
PREPARED BY PERFORMING MONTHLY
LOCKDOWN DRILLS.
THE MOMENT A LOCKDOWN WAS CALLED
STUDENTS WERE QUICKLY AN ORDERLY
SECURED IN CLASSROOMS AND DOORS
WERE LOCKED.
THE GUNMAN HAD NO VISIBLE
TARGETS AND WAS UNABLE TO GAIN
ENTRANCE.
ENTRANCE INTO THE CLASSROOMS
WERE CHILDREN WERE HIDDEN.
IT IS EASIER TO CONVINCE
OURSELVES THAT THIS WILL NEVER
HAPPEN IN OUR COMMUNITIES BUT
THE FACT OF THE MATTER IS THERE
WILL BE MORE SCHOOL SHOOTINGS
AND ALL COMMUNITIES ARE AT RISK.
STUDENTS AND STAFF MUST BE
PREPARED.
THEY MUST BUILD THE MUSCLE
MEMORY TO ACT QUICKLY AND BY
THEMSELVES EVERY POSSIBLE SECOND.
THE TO HIM INCIDENT AS PROOF
THAT EVERY SECOND MATTERS IN
THESE SITUATIONS.
AT RANCHO TO HIM ELEMENTARY THE
SHOOTER ANSWERED CAMPUS JUST
EIGHT SECONDS AFTER THE LOCKDOWN
HAD BEEN EXECUTED.
A CLOSE BY SHARING THAT ACTS --
HAS DEVELOPED A SCHOOL CRISIS TO
KATE AND AS IDENTIFIED BEST
PRACTICES AS AS THEY RELATE --
TO LOCKDOWN DRILLS AND THE AND
THESE -- THIS CALL TOOK HIS
HOUSE ON OUR WEBSITE.
AND WE THINK THE SENDER FOUGHT
DURING THIS IMPORTANT MEASURE AN
ASPIN RIVAL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR SHARING
A GOOD STORY.
US SENATOR AT THE ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS IN SUPPORT OUR
BUSINESSES AND SUPPORT.
NONE ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
BRING BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
CENTER PAN.
THANK YOU AND CENTER BATES FIRST
FALL I WANT TO THANK YOU -- FOR
PRESENTING THE BILL ONLINE AT
WILL NOT PULL THAT OFF CONSENT -
AND I APPRECIATE -- WHAT YOUR
WITNESS TO PRESENT AND THEN AND
I ALSO WANT TO RECOGNIZE -- YOUR
YOUR DEDICATION TO CHILDREN AND
THEIR SAFETY IN YOUR CAREER AND
YOUR WORK IN THE LEGISLATURE SO
I DEFINITELY WANT -- TO
EMPHASIZE THAT -- MY CONCERN AND
IT'S NOT SO MUCH WITH.
MY MY I GUESS MY CONCERN ABOUT
LOCKDOWN DRILLS AND I AND I HEAR
WHAT YOU'RE THE WITNESSES OF
SAID.
IN TERMS OF IT'S IT'S GOOD WE
SHOULD BE PREPARED RIGHT AND
SELL NOT OPPOSED TO THAT.
BUT I ALSO. TO BE SURE THAT WHEN
WE'RE DOING THIS THAT WERE NOT
ACTUALLY TRAUMATIZING THE
STUDENTS -- AND SOMETIMES EVEN
THE SPECKLED IN THE STAFF I
THERE'S BEEN SOME NEWS REPORTS
ABOUT -- ONES THAT PERHAPS WERE
DONE -- OVER TO THE ETHNICALLY --
WHEN HAS TO THINK ABOUT SOME
AREAS YOU HAVE YOU'RE TELLING --
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL SOON SO I
APPRECIATE TO THAT WE HAD A A
POSITIVE SALE AT YOU KNOW THAT
THAT DID THE RESULTED AND AND
AND AND AND AND A SITUATION
WHERE NO STUDENT WAS -- WHAT WAS
KILLED I THINK -- WE CAN TALK
THE I. NATO THIS BILL ISN'T
ABOUT WE CAN TALK ABOUT LARGER
POLICIES TO TRY TO WITH THAT
MIGHT BE MORE EFFECTIVE IN
REDUCING THOSE TYPES OF
INCIDENTS IN THE OPPORTUNITY BUT
I I DO WANT TO JUST.
TOUCH A LITTLE BIT ABOUT.
NO WE WON'T BE SURE THAT WHAT
WE'RE DOING IS NOT ACTUALLY
CREATING A TRAUMATIZE ARE
CREATING FEAR IN.
OUR STUDENTS AND OUR STAFF RIGHT
THAT WE DO WANT TO TRAIN FOR
RIGHT YOU DIFFERENT THINGS --
INCLUDING YOU KNOW WHAT TO DO IF
THERE IS A SHOOTER -- AND OTHER
TYPES OF SITUATIONS BUT I ALSO
AM VERY CONCERNED ABOUT AS A
PEDIATRICIAN ABOUT YOUNG
CHILDREN WHO BASICALLY BEING
TOLD -- THAT SOME YOU KNOW THAT --
STE -- THAT THERE ARE PEOPLE OUT
THERE WANT TO COME TO YOUR
SCHOOL AND KILL YOU NOW YOU KNOW
THERE MAY BE A CERTAIN TRUTH TO
THAT IT'S ACTUALLY THE GOOD NEWS
IS IN THE DOLLARS AS I
THOUGHTFULLY IT'S FAIRLY
INFREQUENT.
AND AND WHEN IT DOES HAPPEN THAT
WE HAVE PUT THINGS IN PLACE TO
PREVENT AY HARM.
BUT IT SAME TIME -- I THINK YOU
KNOW I DON'T WANT TO BE VERY.
SENSITIVE TO THAT I KNOW THE THE
SCHOOL PSYCHOLOGISTS HAVE SOME
GUIDELINES AND I WILL BE SURE
THAT.
ASIDE FROM IT AND IN ADDITION TO
SAYING THAT WE'RE GONNA DO
LOCKDOWN DRILLS THAT THE PROCESS
PROCESS THERE BE USED BY SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND THEIR PARTNERS AND
I KNOW THAT WE HAVE.
NO VERY GOOD PARTNERS IN LAW
ENFORCEMENT OTHERS -- THAT ARE
DONE IN A WAY THAT DOES NOT
CREATE -- SITUATIONS WHERE THERE
COULD BE TRAUMA TO THE STUDENTS --
WHO MAY HAVE ACTUALLY THEMSELVES
EXPERIENCE VIOLENCE AT HOME ARE
INJURED COULDN'T COMMUNITIES
WELL SO CAN YOU PERHAPS PETER
THAT MAYBE I DON'T KNOW BUT I
I'M NOT I'M NOT A SPECIFIC
AMENDMENT BUT PERHAPS IT THAT I
THINK A ARE YOU WILL BE OPEN TO
WORKING TO PUT?
THAT AS PART THE GUIDELINES --
FOR IN TERMS OF IN THE BILL WHEN
YOU SAY WE DON'T REQUIRE
LOCKDOWN DRILLS.
BOTH LEON SENATOR HANNAH DOCTOR
POUND.
IN FACT I THINK THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SCHOOL
PSYCHOLOGISTS THERE ARE
GUIDELINES HERE IS PROBABLY
SOMETHING THAT SHOULD BE PART OF
ALL THE BILL I THAT THAT BE
INCLUDED IN BEST PRACTICES AS A
EMPLOYEE ALL.
FORWARD THEIR PLAN OF ACTION
LEAVE THAT TO THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN ASSESSING OB WITH
THEIR THEIR STUDENTS ARE
EMOTIONALLY READY FOR SOMETHING
LIKE A LOCKDOWN DRILL IT'S THE
WAY THEY PRESENTED ISSUE NOW.
IS NOT BAD WE'RE GOING TO COME
TO SCHOOL AND SHOOT YOU IS THAT
THERE CAN BE BAD PEOPLE OUT
THERE THAT WOULD CAUSE A LOT OF
PROBLEMS FOR YOU KNOW GOING OUT
ON THE PLAYGROUND ON THEIR SIDE.
THERE WAS SOMEONE NUMBER IF I
THINK THAT WAS AN LA A COUPLE
YEARS AGO WHERE SOMEONE IT CREE --
KID COMMITTED A BURGLARY AND
LOCALLY -- WAS SOMEWHERE IN
THERE IN THE REGION SO THEY
LOCKED DOWN THOUGH THE SCHOOL
DOWN AND SO IT'S THE WAY THEY
PERCENT.
DOWN JOB THESE ARE EXCELLENT
GUIDELINES IN FACT THERE'S TWO
TYPES OF LOCKDOWNS AND SOUNDS
THAT THEY'RE RECOMMENDING THE
PERIMETER ONE ASKED THE FIRST
APPROACH YOU KNOW HERE'S WHAT WE
GOT TO KEEP OUR SCHOOL COMMUNITY
SAFE AND THIS IS A PRIVATE AREA
WE'RE GOING TO CLOSE IT DOWN.
TYPE THING SO IT'S THE WAY THEY
DO IT BUT THIS IS EXCELLENT I
THINK AND I DID NOT SEE THAT BY
THE WAY.
INTO WE PUT JOB THE PRESENTATION
TOGETHER SO I REALLY APPRECIATE
THAT TO ACTUALLY PULL THE BILL
FROM CONSENT SO THAT WE CAN HAVE
IT ON THE RECORD DISCUSSION THAT
THIS SHOULD BE A PART OF THE OUR
APPROACH TO THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS
TAKE.
I REALLY APPRECIATE THAT SURVEYS
AND THAT REALLY APPRECIATE -- I
KNOW SOMETIMES ANNOYING WHEN
YOUR BILL AND CONSENT TO GET
FULL BLOWN OUT TO BRING EVERYONE
AND IT BY REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR
REGULAR WELL AS HAVE THIS
DIALOGUE AND FOR THAT WITH THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU.
WE APPRECIATE YOU DODGE PAN I
THINK WE ALL WISH WE WERE JUST
KIDS AGAIN HAVE HIM AS OUR
DOCTOR MAYBE.
OKAY SIR SENATOR BED DANNY WHAT
THE BILL FOR THAT.
ONE YOU SEE THE DOCTOR PAN ANY
OTHER COMMENTS AGREES CENTER
DRAWS SO -- THANK YOU A CENTER
BASE FOR FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD -- WHEN I WAS A KID I
NEVER IMAGINED THAT WE WERE
GOING TO BE HAVING TO HAVE
DRILLS ABOUT A POTENTIAL THIS
KIND OF GET INTO THE -- SO THANK
YOU FOR THAT -- I'D WANT TO GET
INTO TOO MUCH IN THE WEEDS BUT
MY CONCERN IS THAT AROUND
SHOOTINGS AND IN SCHOOLS --
THERE'S BEEN A BIGGER POLICY
ISSUES THAT HAVE BEEN.
BROUGHT IN -- AROUND THE USE OF
GUNS -- THERE'D BEEN PROPOSALS
AND SOME OF SCHOOLS IN SOME
STATES THAT TEACHERS SHOULD HAVE
GUNS THAT.
I MEAN YOU KNOW MAYBE
MAINTENANCE SHOULD HAVE GUNS AND
THE SORT OF STUFF SO.
I'M TRYING TO PICTURE.
MAKING SURE.
HOW OR HOW DO WE MAKE SURE THAT
WHILE THIS PREPARATION IS DONE
IN THE BEST WAY POSSIBLE FOR THE
CHILDREN PSYCHOLOGICALLY AND
EVERY WHERE ELSE?
IS THAT IT DOESN'T BECOME AN
OPPORTUNITY. TO TALK ABOUT.
OTHER POLICY ISSUES AND
INCORPORATE THEM IN THAT AND NOT
SOME I'M CONCERNED ABOUT THAT --
HOW DO HOW DO WE?
A AND IF IT DOESN'T NECESSARILY
HAVE TO BE HERE BUT HOW DO YOU
THINK WE SHOULD PROCEED WITH
THAT SO THAT IT DIDN'T AND
BECOME AN OPENING FOR ANOTHER
POLICY DISCUSSION AROUND GUNS.
THAT CERTAINLY WOULDN'T BE MY
MOTIVATION WITH THIS BILL IT
STRICTLY ON IT TO INSURE THAT MY
CHILD YOUR CHILD.
ANY CHILD WHO'S IN OUR AUDIENCE
SCHOOL OFFENDING IS TOTALLY SAFE
AND I THINK THAT OUR HEARTS YOU
KNOW ACHE BLEED -- WHEN
SOMETHING LIKE THIS HAPPENS I
DON'T WANT A RECOUNT SOME OF
THOSE THAT STILL GIVE ME A LUMP
IN MY THROAT?
SO THAT'S THE ONLY SINGLE INTENT
OF THIS BILL THE THE LARGER
DISCUSSION REGARDING HOW WE KEEP
SCHOOLS SAFER.
I THINK CARL WE'VE TALKED ABOUT
NEEDLE ARMING SCHOOLS ARE YOU
KNOW PUTTING FENCES AROUND EVERY
ONE OF MANY MANY THOUGHTS COME
FORWARD.
BUT PROBABLY THE MOST IMPORTANT
THING AND I THINK WE ALL KNOW
THAT INDIVIDUAL YOU HAVE TO BE
PREPARD.
TO SURVIVE AND THE ONLY WAY WE
CAN PREPARE TO SURVIVE WHETHER
IT'S IN THE WILDERNESS OR IT'S
ON A SCHOOL CAMPUS IS TO KNOW
WHAT TO DO.
AND THAT IS TO CERTAINLY KNOW
HOW TO PROTECT YOURSELF AND
THOSE WHO ARE.
IN WE ARE IN THEIR KEEPING KNOW
HOW TO HELP US PROTECT OURSELVES
THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL IS ABOUT.
THANK YOU SENATOR ALSO CENTER
BATES WHICH LIKE CLOSE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR THE
DISCUSSION AGAIN TO SENATOR PAN
AND TO THE CONSULTANTS ON THIS
COMMITTEE FOR ANA LOOKING AT
THESE.
THINGS COSTA THE PRECIOUS LIVES
OF OUR PRECIOUS CHILDREN OR
SOMETHING I THINK IS THE FIRST
PRIORITY FOR ALL OF US SO OUR
THAT IS MICHAEL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SENATOR
BATES THE BILL HAS BEEN MOVED BY
A DOCTOR PAN SENATOR PAN MA'AM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ITEM SIXTEEN SB FIVE FORTY ONE
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS LEYVA.
LEYVA AYE WILK WILK I CHIANG
CHIANG I'D WOULD ASAL WITH US SO
I GLAZER [inaudible]
FIRE.
WHERE I PAN?
CAN I HAS ENOUGH VOTES TO GET
OUT BUT WE WILL LEAVE IT ON CALL
THANK YOU SENATOR BATES AREN'T
MEMBERS WE HAVE COME TO THAT
POINT ON OUR AGENDA WHERE WE ARE
DOWN TO BILLS FROM MEMBERS.
WE HAVE THREE LEFT WE'RE GOING
TO GO ON FILE ORDER STARTING
WITH SENATOR TORONTO.
SB.
THREE FIFTY FOUR SENATOR DRAWS A
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE --
TODAY I'M HERE TO ASK YOU TO
VOTE -- SUPPORT.
SB THREE FIFTY FOUR WHICH WILL
EXPAND THE CALIFORNIA DREAM LOAN
PROGRAM TO UC AND CSU GRADUATE
STUDENTS.
THE CURRENT EXISTING LAW --
CREATED -- THE CALIFORNIA DREAM
LOAN PROGRAM.
WHICH PROVIDES UNDOCUMENTED
STUDENTS ENTER ATTENDING A CSU
OR YOU SEE YOU AS A RESOURCE TO
FUND THEIR UNDERGRADUATE
EDUCATION.
IF THEY MADE AB FIVE FORTY
REQUIREMENTS.
IN THE SAME YEAR THAT WAS PASSED
THE STATE ALSO ENACTED.
SB ELEVEN FIFTY NINE THAT ALLOWS
UNDOCUMENTED CALIFORNIANS TO
OBTAIN PROFESSIONAL LICENSES AND
OVER FORTY PROFESSIONS.
THE MEDICAL LEGAL AND
EDUCATIONAL FIELD SO IN DOING SO
THE PASSAGE OF THESE TWO BILLS
REMOVE BARRIERS FOR UNDOCUMENTED
STUDENTS TO ADVANCE THEIR
EDUCATIONAL GOALS.
ENTER THEIR PROFESSIONAL FEELS
AND REALLY SET FOR SERVE THE
STATE'S DIVERSE COMMUNITIES SO
TODAY I PROPOSE.
SB THREE FIFTY FOUR TO ALLOW
THOSE -- CSU AND YOU SEE
INSTITUTIONS TO USE EXISTING
DREAM LOAN PROGRAM FUNDS. TO
OFFER LOANS TO GRADUATE STUDENTS
PURSUING THEIR PROFESSIONAL
DEGREE.
WE BELIEVE THERE'S AN ESTIMATED
SIX HUNDRED STUDENTS IN BOTH THE
UC AND CSU SYSTEMS COMBINED --
THAT COULD BENEFIT FROM
EXTENDING -- THIS PROGRAM TO
GRADUATE STUDENTS WE ARE NOT
ASKING FOR ADDITIONAL ALLOCATION
OF FUNDS WE'RE SIMPLY ASKING
THAT THE LEGISLATURE ALLOW UC
AND CSU INSTITUTIONS. TO OFFER A
CALIFORNIA DREAM GRADUATE
STUDENTS ACCESS TO THESE LOANS
ARE IN VOTING AYE ON SB THREE
FIFTY FOUR WE'RE GONNA MOVE
CLOSER TO ENSURING THAT ALL
CALIFORNIANS STUDENTS HAVE THE
SAME.
CHANCE AT ACADEMIC SUCCESS.
WITH THAT SAID I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE WITH THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENT AND HANDED
OVER TO OUR WITNESSES WHO ARE
HERE -- ON HELICON SALAS WILL
START AHEAD BECAUSE SALAS
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF CHIRLA.
OKAY START TO WRITE WITH BRENDA
TWO WITNESSES TWO MINUTES EACH
PLEASE FOR SEED.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS BRENDA WHAT
THE SO DON'T I'M FROM IS LOS
ANGELES AND I'M CURRENTLY A FOUR
YEAR AND STUDENT I UC RIVERSIDE.
I WILL BE GRADUATING IN LESS
THAN THREE MONTHS WITH A DOUBLE
MAJOR IN ENGLISH AND SPANISH
LITERATURE.
AS OF REGENERATION LOW INCOME
STUDENTS I HAVE EXPERIENCE MANY
OBSTACLES THAT ALMOST PREVENTED
ME FROM GRADUATING THIS YEAR.
ONE OF THEM WAS MY MOM WHO
ALMOST LOST HER LIFE THAT THE
DUE TO THE LACK OF ACCESS TO
HEALTH CARE FOR UNDOCUMENTED
INDIVIDUALS.
ALTHOUGH I QUALIFY FOR EIGHTY
FIVE FORTY AND I'M A CALL GRANT
RECIPIENTS I DO NOT QUALIFY FOR
DOT COM.
WHICH MEANS THAT JOBS
INTERNSHIPS AND SCHOLARSHIPS ARE
VERY LIMITED TO STUDENTS LIKE
MYSELF.
WHEN THEY JEAN WAS IMPLEMENTED
DURING MY THIRTY YEAR OF COLLEGE
HE HELPED ME TO PAY MY TUITION
FEES?
THAT I WAS BEING OUT OF POCKET
DURING MY FIRST TWO YEARS OF
COLLEGE.
THROUGH IN THAT TIME I HAD TO
WORK FULL TIME TO PAY MY TUITION
FEES RENT BOOKS FOOD AND
TRANSPORTATION.
EVEN WITH MY PARENTS SUPPORT.
IT WAS DIFFICULT TO PLAY THIS
COURSE DESPITE THE OBSTACLES I
WILL BE ABLE TO GRADUATE ON TIME
THANKS TO THE GENOME PROGRAM AND
MY OTHER THE MIXES.
NAM ABLE TO FOCUS ON MY
ACADEMICS IN MY WORK AS A
STUDENT EITHER AND THAT WOULD BE
ON THE CAMPUS.
INSTEAD OF WORKING A FULL TIME
JOB AND I AM BEING A FULL TIME
STUDENT AT THE SAME TIME.
MY DREAM WAS TO ATTEND A
GRADUATE SCHOOL TO OBTAIN A
MASTERS ON PUBLIC POLICY.
IMMEDIATELY AFTER GRADUATING
FROM UC RIVERSIDE.
HOWEVER DUE TO FINANCIAL
CIRCUMSTANCES AND THE COST OF
ATTENDANCE.
I WILL BE DELAY IN MY EDUCATION
I WANT TO BECOME A PROFESSOR AT
A PUBLIC UNIVERSITY TO PUT
PROVIDE GREATER SERVICE TO MY
COMMUNITY.
AND SHARE KNOWLEDGE WITH
STUDENTS ON WHY IT'S IMPORTANT
TO IMPLEMENT.
PROGRESSIVE POLICIES THAT WILL
HELP THE IMMIGRANT COMMUNITY AT
THE STATE AND FEDERAL LEVEL.
THIS IS WHAT TODAY I WANT TO AS
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE TO
PLEASE CONSIDER SUPPORTING SB.
THREE FIFTY FOUR THESE WE WILL A
LOT THIS BILL WILL ALLOW
UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS TO ATTEND
GRADUATE SCHOOL MEDICAL SCHOOL
OR LAW SCHOOL.
DESERVE BETTER OF THE
COMMUNITIES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT WITNESS.
GOOD AFTERNOON -- MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME SAID HE GOT
SALAS EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
CHIRLA THE COALITION. FOR HUMANE
IMMIGRANT RIGHTS AND A PROUD
SPONSOR OF THIS BEEF -- THREE
FIFTY FOUR THE TESTIMONY OF
BRENDA SHOWS THE NEED FOR
CALIFORNIA TO BE BOLD AND
CONTINUE TO BE PROACTIVE IN
PROTECTING AND ENSURING
IMMIGRANT YOU'D HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO ATTAIN HIGHER
EDUCATION.
AND TO CONTRIBUTE TO OUR SOCIETY
AND OUR GREAT STATE.
BY TWENTY THIRTY THE STATE WILL
FALL SHORT ABOUT ONE POINT ONE
MILLION COLLEGE GRADUATES AND OF
THE IT'LL FALL SHORT OF THE
ECONOMIC DEMAND IN THE WORK
FORCE NEEDS.
AS A MATTER OF FACT TODAY OUR
STATE IS FACING A SHORTAGE OF
HEALTHCARE PROFESSIONALS WHICH
REQUIRE POST SECONDARY DEGREES.
SB THREE FIFTY FOUR CONTINUES TO
BUILD ON THE PROGRESS THAT WE
HAVE MADE SINCE THE ENACTMENT OF
AB FIVE FORTY WHICH RECOGNIZES
UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS -- FOR
PURPOSES OF A RESIDENTS FOR
PURPOSES OF TUITION -- THIS BILL
WAS PASSED IN TWO THOUSAND AND
ONE AND INCREDIBLE THINGS HAVE
HAPPENED INCREDIBLE LIVES AN
INCREDIBLE CONTRIBUTE
CONTRIBUTORS IN OUR STATE HAVE
COME OUT OF THAT AND SO TODAY WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT [inaudible]
YOU.
MEMBERS IN SUPPORT OR EXCUSE ME
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT PLEASE
STATE YOUR NAME.
CHRISTOPHER SCIENCE THE TURN OF
THE COALITION FOR HUMANE
IMMIGRANT RIGHTS HERE TO ANSWER
ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS
INSTRUCTS APART THANK YOU SIR.
STATE YOUR NAME YOUR
ORGANIZATION AND THAT YOU
SUPPORT PLEASE.
HELLO MONIES BY SOME OF THE UC
STUDENT ASSOCIATION WE WANT TO
GIVE A SHOUT OUT TO CHIRLA AND
CENTER DRAWS -- FOR CHOPPING
THISIMPORTANT ISSUE WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
TOLERATE ARMY OF THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA WE ARE IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
JAKE BREMNER ON BEHALF OF THE
CAMPAIGN FOR COLLEGE OPPORTUNITY
AND THE CALIFORNIA UNDOCUMENTED
HIGHER EDUCATION COALITION BUT
WE HELP CONVENE WE'RE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS EFFORT AND THANK
THE SPONSORING AUTHOR.
HELLO MAGGIE RIGHT WITH
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY ARE
VERY PROUD TO BE IN SUPPORT OF
THE SPELL THANK YOU.
HELLO JOHN UNDER LAWS WOMEN'S
SIDE CAL STATE LONG BEACH
STUDENT IN SUPPORT.
THE TERMINUS ISRAEL'S OF HIMSELF
THE STATIONS ARE SOON TO BE
SOCIAL WORKER ON STRONG SUPPORT
FOR THIS BILL THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON RENTALS OF THE
FROM CORE CITY HIGH SCHOOL AND
I'M STRONG SUPPORT WHICH Là.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY DON'T BUY AS
HOMEOWNERS WHO THEN OF PASADENA
I'M WITH COMMUNITY CHANGE IN I'M
IN A STRONG SUPPORTER OF THIS
BILL.
THANK YOU RUSSELL.
HELLO I'M RESALABLE IN THIS
GONZALEZ AND I GOT SO I GOT THEM
OUT ONCE A CHARTER HIGH SCHOOL
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS MELODY CLING IN
FIRST AND ON THE STATE WHAT
ORGANIZER FOR THE CALIFORNIA JIM
NETWORK CHIEF LES COLLEGE
COMPONENT AND I AM IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
HELLO MY NAME IS AMY MARTINEZ
HERNANDEZ I'M FROM ANTELOPE
VALLEY COLLEGE AND I'M ALSO FROM
CALIFORNIA DREAM NETWORK AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT SB.
THREE FIFTY FOUR MY NAME IS GEAR
MARKEDNESS.
NINETY I FROM CHIRLA IN WRITING.
WE UNDERMINE.
THE EMPATH.
JANET THAT OPPOSE HE'LL RESIDENT
A PASADENA ORANGE COUNTY
ORGANIZER FOR THE CALIFORNIA
DREAM NETWORK AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS.
BETTER HERE WITH TEALA ALSO
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB THIRTY FOUR
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CHAMPION ON
THIS ISSUE.
THE SYLLABUS FROM PORTAL
CALIFORNIA A MEMBER OF CHEN ON
THE CALIFORNIA DREAM THAT WORK
AND I'M IN SUPPORT.
GABRIELLE HERNANDEZ FROM IRVINE
VALLEY COLLEGE I AM WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DREAM NETWORK AND I'M
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS ANAHITA BUT NOT
THE THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
REFUGEE ORGANIZER PARTNERED WITH
CHIRLA AND I'M IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME STARTED AND SALAS ON
FROM UC RIVERSIDE AND A STRONG
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS GET THEIR TO SEE
OUR HIGH SCHOOL ORGANIZER WHICH
YOU LINE I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
HI MY NAME IS HAS SINCE AND I AM
FROM AND ABOUT A COLLEGE AND I
STRONG SUPPORT THIS BILL.
I'M IN NJ I AM FOR MY QUE ON TO
HIGH SCHOOL AND A STRONG SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
HELLO I'M JACQUELINE LEASE I GO
TO HAMILTON HIGH SCHOOL IN LOS
ANGELES AND PART OF THE HIGH
SCHOOL COMPONENT AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT AS BE.
THREE FIFTY FOUR HELLO MY NAME'S
HONORING TO RE I'M A COUPLE THE
STUDENT AND A MEMBER OF CHI Là
I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
ALEX BEFORE YOU SEE STUDENTS SO
TO A STUDENT ASSOCIATION AS WELL
AS A UC DAVIS STUDENT STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
HELLO MY NAME IS COLONEL MILES
I'M A RESIDENT FROM VICTORVILLE
AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
JANET THIS COLOR FRONT IS BAY
AREA AND I SUPPORT THE BILL. ONE
OF THE SOMETHING OF A LOCAL THIS
YEAR TO MAKE THE REMAINING TWO
LESS SUPPORT.
HI MY NAME'S MERELY RIVERA AND
I'M FROM IS VERY HIGH SCHOOL A
STRONG SUPPORT THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME'S FUNNY LE HARKIS ARM
FROM HIS BREA HI DOES ORGANIZER
AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
HI MY AND I WITH MY AMATEUR THAN
STRONG SUPPORT.
A NURSING HOME A UCLA
UNDERGRADUATES IN ASSOCIATION ON
BEHALF FOR GRADUATE STUDENTS
ASSOCIATION COULDN'T BE HERE
BOTH ORGANIZATIONS ARE STRONG
SUPPORT.
OR ONE EARLIER ON A USUALLY
UNDERGRADUATE STUDENTS
ASSOCIATION AND YOU FEEL SAFE.
COMAIR PHASE UCLA UNDERGRAD
ASSOCIATION AND YOU SEE ESSAY ON
STRONG SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THEY REALLY DAYDREAMER NETWORK
STRONGLY SUPPORTS THIS BILL.
HELLO MY NAME IS LORI L. AUDIO
SUMMIT ABC STUDENT AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
MARIO GUERRERO ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION
SUPPORT.
MY NAY SUMMARIES I LEAVING HIM
IN PALMDALE ANTELOPE VALLEY.
THANK YOU MRS RUSSELL A NIECE OF
A SPARE OKAY.
MISTER MIKE THAT'S ANOTHER MIGHT
MCCARTY SUPPORT THESE BILLS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. THIRTY
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
ALL RIGHT LET'S TAKE IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS OR CONCERNS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR
MCGUIRE SENATOR DRAWS A WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
YES I RESPECTFULLY RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE WITH THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENT THANK YOU
CHAIR THANK YOU VERY MUCH THE
BILL'S REMOVED BY SENATOR
MCGUIRE MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
ITEM SEVEN SB FIVE ANSWER SB
THREE FIFTY FOR THE MOTION IS DO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS LEYVA AYE LEYVA
AYE WILK.
GET CHIANG.
CHIANG I WOULD ASSUME HI RUSSEL
AYE GLAZER MCGUIRE MCGUIRE AYE
PAN.
BELIEVE THAT BILL ON CALL THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
THANK.
ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOING TO MOVE.
TO SENATOR MCGUIRE ARE YOU READY.
SB.
FOR NINETY NINE THE REQUIRE
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
GOOD AFTERNOON IN MEMBERS I WANT
TO START OFF MADAM CHAIR BY
SAYING THANK YOU TO YOU IN HERE.
FANTASTIC TEAM UP FOR THEIR WORK
ON THIS BILL AND OF COURSE WILL
ACCEPT THE COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS.
HI AND I WANNA ALSO SITTING IN
THE CHAIR FOR HER WORK ON
CHILDHOOD HUNGER.
PRIOR TO YOUR TIME IN THIS
LEGISLATURE NOW.
AND WE ALL KNOW THAT STUDENTS
ARE CHALLENGED TO THRIVE IN THE
CLASSROOM WHEN THEY'RE RUNNING
ON AN EMPTY STOMACH.
IN CHILDHOOD HUNGER IS AN
EPIDEMIC IN OUR STATE WITH MORE
CHILDREN IN POVERTY HERE IN
CALIFORNIA THAN ANY OTHER STATE
IN AMERICA.
NEARLY TWO MILLION CHILDREN ARE
FOOD INSECURE.
PATRICIA SCHOOL MEALS
ACCOMPANIED WITH LOCAL
CALIFORNIA GROWN FRESH FRUIT AND
VEGGIES ARE ESSENTIAL WAY TO
ENSURE STUDENTS ARE GETTING THE
FOOD THEY NEED TO LEARN AND GROW.
THROUGH TEN CENT PER BREAKFAST
REIMBURSEMENT SB FOUR NINETY
NINE IS WHAT WE CALL A WIN WIN
WIN. FIFTY FOUR NINETY NINE
INCENTIVIZE THE SCHOOLS TO
PURCHASE CALIFORNIA GROWN
PRODUCE -- BY PROVIDING THEM
ENHANCE MEAL REIMBURSEMENT FOR
THE STATE TO SUPPORT LOCAL
FARMERS.
THIS SMALL INCENTIVE WILL HAVE
BIG IMPACTS THIS DIME WILL
PROVIDE STUDENTS BETTER ACCESS
TO LOCALLY GROWN HEALTHY
UNIVERSAL MEALS CAN SUPPORT OUR
LOCAL CALIFORNIA FARMERS.
IN TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN WE
AUTHORED THE SUCCESSFUL SB. ONE
THIRTY EIGHT EIGHT REQUIRED
SCHOOL DISTRICTS WITH HIGH
POVERTY SCHOOL POPULATIONS TO
PROVIDE BREAKFAST AND LUNCH FREE
OF CHARGE TO ALL THEIR STUDENTS.
THIS IS A MUCH NEEDED STEP
TOWARD ADDRESSING CHILDHOOD
HUNGER IMPROVING OUTCOMES IN THE
CLASSROOMS.
RESEARCH TIME AND TIME AGAIN IS
SHOWN US THAT BREAKFAST IS
IMPORTANT FOR STUDENTS HEALTH IN
ACADEMIC SUCCESS.
AFFECTED SCHOOL BREAKFAST
PROGRAMS ARE ASSOCIATED WITH
HIGHER TEST SCORES BETTER GRADES
IN POSITIVE LEARNING
ENVIRONMENTS.
IN TO A STUDY PUBLISHED IN THE
JOURNAL OF ECONOMICS.
STUDENTS IN SCHOOLS THAT OFFERED
FREE BREAKFAST BEFORE CLASS
SCORED ABOUT 25% HIGHER ON MATH
AND READING AS WELL SCIENCE TEST.
HOWEVER AS STUDENTS ACCESS TO
HELP THE SCHOOL MEALS IS NOT
JUST A MATTER OF FOOD
AVAILABILITY.
IT'S ALSO ABOUT OUTSTANDING
BARRIERS TO STUDENTS BENEFITING
FROM SCHOOL MEALS AND THAT'S
ALSO QUALITY FOOD.
CALIFORNIA'S BETTER UTILIZE THE
RESOURCES OUR OWN BACKYARD
INCLUDING HEALTHY FRESH PRODUCE
GROWN IN OUR STATE TO SUPPORT
STUDENT HEALTH.
IN LEARNING IN ONLY ABOUT 55% OF
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL DISTRICTS
PARTICIPATE IN FARM TO SCHOOL
ACTIVITIES SUCH AS SERVING
LOCALLY GROWN FOODS AN EXTRA
COSTS THAT IT TAKES TO BE ABLE
TO BUY DIRECTLY FROM A LOCAL
FARMER PURCHASE LOCAL.
FOOD LOCAL FOODS.
EVEN THOUGH IT'S JUST A DIE MORE
PER MEAL IS ONE OF THE BIGGEST
HURDLES FOR SCHOOLS TO PURCHASE
CALIFORNIA GROUND.
AS BEFORE NINETY NINE IS MODELED
AFTER A PREVIOUS SUCCESSFUL
PILOT PROGRAM IT PROVIDES A TEN
CENT PER BREAKFAST REIMBURSEMENT
FOR CALIFORNIA AROUND FRESH
FRUITS AND VEGGIES TO ELIMINATE
BARRIERS.
IN BACK TO BETTER NUTRITION AND
IT PROMOTES PURCHASING BY
PURCHASING LOCALLY.
VENTURE ISLAND IT RIGHT HERE AND
SAY WE'RE GRATEFUL TO MISS
PATTERSON USE HERE TO OFFER A
TWO MINUTE TESTIMONY SHE'S A
DIRECTOR OF THAT LEGISLATION AT
THE CALIFORNIA FOOD -- POLICY
ADVOCATES AND WE ALSO HAVE DAVID
RUDENSTINE HE'S POLICY DIRECTOR
AT THE COMMITTEE LINES WITH
FAMILY FARMERS AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME WOULD ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU SO MUCH
MANAGER.
THANK YOU CENTER MCGUIRE
WITNESSES AND SUPPOSE SUPPORT
PLEASE PROCEED.
THANK YOU TO THE CHAIR AND THE
COMMITTEE I'M TRACY PATTERSON
WITH CALIFORNIA FOOD POLICY
ADVOCATES WERE A STATEWIDE ANTI
HUNGER ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION.
OVER REALLY GRATEFUL FOR CENTER
REQUIRES LEADERSHIP ON AS BEFORE
NINETY NINE WHICH WOULD CREATE
AND SUSTAIN.
EQUITABLE HEALTHY HUNGER FREE
SCHOOLS IN CALIFORNIA -- SO ASSN
REQUIRE SAID CHILD HUNGER IS A
REAL PROBLEM IN OUR STATE I'M
PARTICULARLY FOR LOW INCOME
WORKING FOR FAMILIES WHO MIGHT
MOVE IN AND OVER THE LINE OF
ELIGIBILITY FOR DIFFERENT SAFETY
NET PROGRAMS.
SCHOOL MEALS THAT ARE FREE FOR
ALL IN HIGH NEED COMMUNITIES CAN
REALLY HELP FILL THE GP -- IN
OVER THE LAST FEW YEARS WE'VE
SEEN SOME REAL IMPROVEMENTS
THEIR STATE POLICY AT THE
FEDERAL OPTIONS CALLED COMMUNITY
ELIGIBILITY WHICH PROVIDE
FORMULA FUNDING THAT GIVE
SCHOOLS REVENUE TO FEED.
OUR MEALS FREE OF CHARGE TO ALL
STUDENTS -- THIS REMOVE SOME OF
THAT UNPAID KNEELED THAT CYCLE
THAT YOU HEARD ABOUT EARLIER AND
MAKE SURE THAT SCHOOLS GET
FUNDING SO THAT THEY CAN BROUGHT
PROVIDE THOSE MEALS FREE OF
CHARGE TO EVERYONE.
AND SO AS BEFORE NINETY NINE SIX
TO BUILD UPON THAT PROGRESS AND
THEN ALSO ADDRESS SOME OF THE
REMAINING BARRIERS THE STIGMA
AND QUALITY OF FOOD -- AND SO
WHEN WE TALK DIRECTLY WITH YOUTH
FAMILY IN SCHOOLS -- THE SAME
KINDS OF THINGS COME UP OVER AND
OVER STUDENTS WANT MEALS THAT
ARE FRESH TASTE GOOD AND THAT
DOESN'T MAKE THEM FEEL
EMBARRASSED AMONG THEIR PEERS
ESPECIALLY WITH MIDDLE HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENTS.
ARE FAMILIES WANT SCHOOL TO
PROVIDE FRESH FRUITS AND
VEGETABLES THAT ARE OFTEN
FINANCIALLY OUT OF REACH AT HOME.
AND SCHOOLS WANT TO FEED KIDS
GOOD FOOD AND THEY ALSO WANT TO
REDUCE ADMINISTRATIVE BURDENS
AND PAPERWORK THAT SLOWS THEM
DOWN -- SO WE'RE THRILLED FOR A
CENTER REQUIRES EFFORTS ON AS
BEFORE NINETY NINE AND WE URGE
YOU FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU PLEASE PROCEED.
YES MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS THE
COMMITTEE -- OUR ORGANIZATION
CALF WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON FARMS
SCHOOL PROGRAMS FOR ABOUT TWENTY
YEARS IN CALIFORNIA.
AND I'M SORRY TO HEAR THAT ONLY
55% OF THE SCHOOLS ARE
PARTICIPATING WE'RE GONNA HAVE
TO WORK HARDER ON THAT -- WE'VE
BEEN FOCUSED IN PARTICULAR IN
RECENT YEARS ON A HELPING SCHOOL
SOURCE LOCAL PRODUCE WE RUN A
PROGRAM.
IT KIND OF ACTING AS AN
INTERMEDIARY BETWEEN THE SCHOOLS
AND FARMERS IN CALIFORNIA.
AND IN WE HELP THE SCHOOLS --
EVERY RIGHT THEIR CONTRACTS --
AND SO -- THEY CAN REQUIRE.
THE THE DISTRIBUTORS SAID TO
BRING THEM LOCAL PRODUCE THAT IS
WORK QUITE WELL -- THE SCHOOLS
ALWAYS LACK FUNDING THIS BILL
WILL HELP -- IT'S ALWAYS A
PROBLEM -- AND THEN OF COURSE
THE SHAMING OF THE STUDENTS -- I
THINK THIS BILL -- YOU KNOW
BECAUSE IT REQUIRES UNIVERSAL
FREE BREAKFAST AND LUNCH -- I
THINK THAT WILL HELP ON THAT AD
WE HEARD FROM SENATOR HERTZBERG
ABOUT THAT AND I READ AN ARTICLE --
JUST YESTERDAY THAT IN NORTHERN
EUROPE THEY HAVE THE SAME
PROBLEM IN PLACES LIKE NORWAY
AND THE UNITED KINGDOM.
OF THE SHAMING OF STUDENTS --
AND I I NEVER I NEVER REALLY
UNDERSTAND THAT.
YOU KNOW CHILDREN NEED TO ADD TO
BE ABLE TO LEARN AND THEY NEED
TO GOOD FOOD AND SO MANY OF
THESE POOR CHILDREN MOST OF
THEIR NUTRITION COMES AT SCHOOL.
AND SO I THINK ANYTHING THAT WE
CAN DO.
TO HOPE THAT -- IS IS A STEP IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION -- YOU KNOW
AT FARMERS IN CALIFORNIA ARE
READY TO HELP WE ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
RON RAPIDLY HALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS AND SUPPORT.
MUST WORK ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF FOOD
BANKS IN SUPPORT.
LYDIA BORN REPRESENTING AMERICAN
ACADEMY OF PEDIATRICS AND
SUPPORT.
LAURIE DAVIS FROM SANDY MATT THE
CENTER FELL CITY SCHOOLS AND
MARIN FOOD POLICY COUNCIL IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANY OTHERS IN SUPPORT
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEING HEARING THAT WILL COME
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE THE BILL
HAS BEEN MOVED WAS A CENTER WILK.
DOCTOR CAN'T SORRY [inaudible]
IT.
ANY COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE
NONE -- CENTER WHERE I WOULD
CHECK CLOSE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU THANK YOU
THE BILLS MOVED BY SENATOR PAM
BAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
ITEM FIFTEEN AS BEFORE NINETY
NINE THE MOTION IS DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS LEYVA.
LEAVE THE AYE WILK WILK I CHIANG
CHANG I WOULD ASSUME.
WITH US SO I GLAZER MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE AYE PAN PAN AYE.
BILLS ENOUGH TO GET OUT BUT WE
WILL KEEP IT ON CALL WE ARE DOWN
TO OUR LAST BILL THANK YOU TO
ALL OF YOU BEEN HERE ALL MORNING
WITH US.
LAST BUT DEFINITELY NOT LEAST SB
SIX SEVENTY FIVE BY SENATOR
CHIANG.
IN WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MADAM
CHAIRWOMAN COMMITTEE MEMBERS I
AM HERE TODAY TO PRESENT SB SIX
SOME FIVE OR THE CODE ACT.
UNDER CURRENT LAW THE DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION STATE BOARD OF
EDUCATION IS CARD TO ASSEMBLE A
CALIFORNIA COMPUTER SCIENCE
STRATEGIC IMPLEMENTATION PLAN.
A PANEL OF EXPERTS FROM ACROSS
THE STATE HAVE WORK TO PUT THE
STRATEGIC PLAN TOGETHER.
LATE LAST YEAR THE PANEL PUT
FORTH A DRAFT OF RECOMMENDATIONS
ONE OF THOSE KEY RECOMMENDATIONS
IS TO PROVIDE SUSTAIN.
DEDICATED FUNDING AND STAFF AT
THE STATE LEVEL LOCAL LEVEL TO
SUPPORT.
COMPUTER SCIENCE EDUCATION
EFFORTS IN THE NEXT ONE TO TWO
YEARS THIS BILL STAR SET UP FOR
BY CALLING FOR THE ESTABLISHMENT
OF A GRANT PROGRAM. TO SUPPORT
COMPUTER SCIENCE IN PUBLIC
SCHOOLS ACROSS THE STATE THROUGH
NEW LOTTERY FUNDS.
CALIFORNIA MAY BE HOMES SILICON
VALLEY BUT THOUSANDS OF JOBS IN
THE COMPUTING AND TECHNOLOGY
FIELDS WILL GO ON FIELD.
BECAUSE TODAY'S STUDENTS ARE NOT
PREPARED FOR THESE INDUSTRIES.
ONLY 12% OF CALIFORNIA HIGH
SCHOOLS OFFER COMPUTER SCIENCE
COURSES YET OVER 90% OF PARENTS
WANT THEIR CHILD TO LEARN
COMPUTER SCIENCE IN SCHOOL.
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN THERE ONLY
SIX THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED AND
THIRTY SIX GRADUATES WITH
DEGREES IN COMPUTER SCIENCE.
IN TWENTY SIXTEEN CALIFORNIA
UNIVERSITIES DID NOT PRODUCE A
SINGLE NEW TEACHER PREPARED TO
TEACH COMPUTER SCIENCE DESPITE
THE FACT THAT COMPUTER
OCCUPATIONS MAKE UP OVER.
HALF OF ALL PROJECTED NEW JOBS
IN THE STEM FIELDS.
BETWEEN TWENTY SIXTEEN AND PUT
TWENTY TWENTY SIX THE BUREAU OF
LABOR STATISTICS ESTIMATES THAT.
JOBS IN THE COMPUTER AND
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY INDUSTRY
WILL OUTPACE JOB GROWTH IN OTHER
INDUSTRIES.
IT IS PROJECTED THAT DURING THAT
TIME FIVE HUNDRED FIFTY SEVEN
THOUSAND NEW JOBS WILL BE
CREATED WITH.
AN ANNUAL MEDIAN WAGE OF EIGHTY
FOUR THOUSAND DOLLARS.
UNFORTUNATELY CALIFORNIA DOES
NOT PROVIDE DEDICATED FUNDING
FOR RIGOROUS COMPUTER SCIENCE
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT AND
COURSE SUPPORT.
THIS BILL WOULD INCREASE THE
AMOUNT OF STATE LOTTERY FUNDS
THAT MUST BE MADE AVAILABLE TO
PUBLIC SCHOOLS AND COMMIT THOSE
ADDITIONAL DOLLARS TO COMPUTER
SCIENCE EDUCATION.
IN OTHER WORDS THESE ARE NEW
FUNDS FOR SCHOOLS NOT TAKEN AWAY
FROM EXISTING FUNDS WERE ADDING
NOT SUBTRACTING.
THIS IS A SMALL FOR STEP TO
ENSURE STUDENTS ARE GETTING
APPROPRIATE COMPUTER SCIENCE
SKILLS WE NEED TO PROVIDE KIDS
WITH THE TOOLS TO SUCCEED IN A
DRASTICALLY CHANGING WORLD THAT
REVOLVES AROUND CáC. TO QUOTE
APPLE CO FOUNDER AND TECH
VISIONARY STEVE JOBS.
SCIENCE IN COMPUTER SCIENCE OF
THE IS A LIBERAL ARTS IT'S
SOMETHING EVERYONE SHOULD KNOW
HOW TO USE AT LEAST.
AND HARNESS IN THEIR LIFE.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN SUPPORTING
COMPUTER SCIENCE EDUCATION OUR
PUBLIC SCHOOLS.
THIS IS OUR CHANCE TO HELP
PREPARE CALIFORNIA STUDENTS TO
BE COMPETITIVE IN THE WORK FORCE
AND BECOME LEADERS AND THE
TECHNOLOGY AND COMPUTING
INDUSTRY.
AND WITH ME I HAVE AND WE HAD TO
VOTE WITH CO DOT ORG.
THANK YOU CENTER CHAN PLEASE
PROCEED THANK YOU SENATOR FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP ON THIS EFFORT
GOOD AFTERNOON I HAD MORNING IN
HERE BUT NOW IT'S GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
MY NAME IS ANDREA DIVO I'M HERE
REPRESENTING CO DOT ORG TODAY --
CO DOT ORG IS A NONPROFIT I
DEDICATED TO EXPANDING THE AXIS
OF COMPUTER SCIENCE IN SCHOOLS
AND INCREASING PARTICIPER
DISSIPATION BY WOMEN AND
UNDERREPRESENTED MINORITIES WE
BELIEVE EVERY CHILD IN
CALIFORNIA SHOULD HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO LEARN COMPUTER
SCIENCE.
WE HAVE SEEN A RECORD NUMBER OF
COMPUTER SCIENCE BILLS
INTRODUCED THIS YEAR AND THE
STATE BOARD OF EDUCATION IS ALSO
MAKING SIGNIFICANT PROGRESS TO
EXPAND.
ACCESS -- WITH THE ADOPTION OF
THE K.THROUGH TWELVE COMPUTER
SCIENCE STANDARDS AND THE SOON
TO BE ADOPTED COMPUTER SCIENCE
STRATEGIC IMPLEMENTATION PLAN WE
ARE ENCOURAGED BY THIS PROGRESS
AND ARE HOPEFUL THAT CALIFORNIA
CAN SOON BE SOON BECOME.
THE LEADING STATE FOR COMPUTER
SCIENCE EDUCATION LEAVING
CALIFORNIA TO BECOME THE LEADING
STATE WITH THE TALENT TO FEEL
OUR FUTURE WORKFORCE. ONE
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT AND
CRITICAL FACTOR FOR THIS TO BE
ACHIEVED IS TRAIN TEACHERS --
WITHOUT TEACHERS -- BEING ABLE
TO TEACH COMPUTER SCIENCE WE DO
THAT IS NEEDED.
TODAY VERY FEW HIGH SCHOOLS
OFFER COMPUTER SCIENCE COURSES A
RECENT ANALYSIS OF SECONDARY
COMPUTER SCIENCE COURSE
OFFERINGS IN CALIFORNIA.
CONDUCTED BY THE LEVEL PLAYING
FIELD INSTITUTE REVEALED THAT
TEN OF THE TWENTY LARGEST
DISTRICTS IN THE STATE DID NOT
OFFER ADVANCED PLACEMENT CAN BE --
SCIENCE AND FIVE OF THESE
DISTRICT DID NOT OFFER ANY
COMPUTER SCIENCE COURSES AT ALL.
IN THE DECADE ENDING IN 202473%
OF STEM JOB GROWTH WILL BE IN
COMPUTER OCCUPATIONS BUT ONLY 3%
WILL BE -- IN THE PHYSICAL
SCIENCES AND 3% AND LIFE
SCIENCES THE GREATEST BARRIER
SCHOOLS HAD TO OFFER COMPUTER
SCIENCE IS A LACK OF TEACHERS
TRAINED TO DO IT.
SB SIX SEVENTY FIVE SUPPORTS
INCREASE THE MUCH NEEDED
MECHANISM TO SUPPORT OUR
TEACHERS TO PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT -- AND PROVIDING THE
TOOLS THAT ARE NAY ARE NEEDED TO
DEVELOP OUR CURRENT TEACHING
WORKFORCE TO TEACH COMPUTER
SCIENCE THANK YOU ONCE AGAIN FOR
YOUR TIME TODAY RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH BEFORE WE GO
TO ADDITIONAL SUPPORT CENTER
CHAIN DO YOU TAKE THE AMENDMENTS
OF THE COMMITTEE RECOMMENDED.
YES YES OKAY VERY GOOD THANK YOU.
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
LEIGH ANGELA READ ON BEHALF OF
PROJECT LEAD THE WAY IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL PLEASE COME FORWARD.
PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON
JENNIFER BAKER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
FIRST WANT TO SAY LOVE CODING WE
ACTUALLY HAVE A COATING
CATERPILLAR FOR OUR DAUGHTER SO --
VERY MUCH -- LOVE THE CONCEPT
WITH THE OF WITH THE MEASURES
TRYING TO ACHIEVE UNFORTUNATELY
CTA DOES OPPOSE THE MEASURE FOR
TWO REASONS FIRST OF ALL THE
BILL DOES CREATE A CATEGORICAL
SO YOU'RE ESSENTIALLY TELLING
SCHOOL DISTRICTS YOU CAN'T SPEND
THIS THE MONEY THAT YOU'RE
RECEIVING FROM LOTTERY FUNDS.
ON ANYTHING THAT YOU PRIORITIZE
TO YOUR LOCAL COMMUNITY IN YOUR
EL CAP PROCESS YOU HAVE TO
ACTUALLY DIVERT FUNDS IN
SPECIFICALLY PUT THEM INTO THIS
AREA SO WE DO OPPOSED TO AYE
CATEGORICAL IS ESPECIALLY SINCE
IT WOULD ELIMINATE LOCAL CONTROL --
BUT EDITION ONLY WHAT YOU'RE
DOING IS DIVERTING LOTTERY FUNDS
I AND SO WE WE DO -- OPPOSE THAT
DIRECTION WE'RE CONCERNED ABOUT
THE DIRECTION THAT THIS WOULD
ACTUALLY SHIP LOTTERYFUNDING.
WE HAVE ASKED FOR SOME EVIDENCE
THAT WOULD ACTUALLY SHOW THAT IF
YOU CHANGE THE PRICES OF
LOTTERIES IT WOULD REDUCE AN
OVERALL SYSTEMIC INCREASE IN
FUNDING THAT.
RECEIVED A NUMBER OF YEARS AGO
IT WAS SEEN THAT EDUCATION
FUNDING THROUGH LOTTERY WHICH WE
KNOW IT'S A BIT SMALL DID THIS
THIS IS A VERY VERY SMALL
PORTION VERY VERY SMALL PORTION
OF SCHOOLS BUDGETS.
BUT NEVER THE LESS THERE WAS A
TREND WERE A LOTTERY SALES WERE
DECLINING THEREFORE IT THE
REVENUE THAT WOULD GO TO SCHOOL
DISTRICTS WAS DECLINING AS WELL
THERE WAS AN ATTEMPT A NUMBER OF
YEARS AGO. TO INCREASE THE
LOTTERY PRIZES IN EVEN THOUGH
SCHOOLS WOULD RECEIVE LESS
OVERALL BECAUSE THERE WOULD BE
MORE SALES CUMULATIVELY SCHOOLS
WOULD SEE INCREASED AMOUNTS OF
FUNDING.
AND SO IT BEFORE IT THOSE
CALCULATIONS ARE SHIFTED WE WANT
TO HAVE SOME ASSURANCE THAT
NUMBERS HAVE BEEN CRUNCHED AND
THAT WE WOULD SEE AN OVERALL
INCREASE.
IN THE TOTAL AMOUNT OF FUNDS
THAT ARE GOING TO EDUCATION
OTHERWISE THIS IT COULD ACTUALLY
LEAD TO AN OVERALL DECLINE IN
THE TOTAL AMOUNT OF LOTTERY
FUNDS THAT WE RECEIVED.
SO THIS COULD HAVE THE ON AND
CHAU IMPACT OF LOWER RANGE OF
TOTAL LOTTERY FUNDS OF SCHOOL
DISTRICTS GET IN THE LONG RUN SO
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT --
THAT THE NUMBERS HAVE BEEN
CRUNCHED IT WE'VE WE HAD AN
ACTUARIAL ANALYSIS TO SHOW THE
SCHOOLS WILL INDEED RECEIVE
INCREASE FUNDING -- IF THAT CAN
HAPPEN THAT'S A TOTALLY
DIFFERENT CONVERSATION HOWEVER
WE WOULD NOT SUPPORT ACTUALLY
CREATING A CATEGORICAL WITH A
LOTTERY FUNDS BECAUSE YOU ARE
DIVERTING FUNDS.
THAT WOULD HAVE OTHERWISE GONE
TO SCHOOL SO WE DO APPRECIATE
THE FACT THAT CENTER CHIANG IS
TRYING TO HAVE A CREATIVE
APPROACH.
AND WE DO WE DO LIKE CREATIVE
APPROACHES BUT UNFORTUNATELY WE
DON'T WANT TO HAVE -- SHIFTS IN
LOTTERY FUNDS AND WE
UNFORTUNATELY DON'T SUPPORT
CATEGORICAL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY OTHERS
IN OPPOSITION.
OUR WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE CENTER PAN.
I THINK THANK YOU -- SEARCHING
AND I'D APPRECIATE WHAT YOU'RE
WHAT YOU'RE TRYING -- TO ADDRESS
THIS ISSUE ABOUT -- FREE EQUITY
THERE SO THAT MORE STUDENTS
WOULD HAVE -- EXPERIENCE WITH --
CODING AND SO FORTH BUT I THINK --
PROPOSED TO THE OPPOSITION'S
QUESTIONS I GUESS ASIDE FROM THE
CATEGORICAL ISSUE BUT IN TERMS
OF THE LOTTERY FUNDING OVERALL I
UNDERSTAND THAT YOU SHARED WITH
ME THAT THIS IS -- IN IT THIS
THIS WITHOUT DIVERT ANY EXISTING
LOTTERY FUNDING FROM -- WHERE
IT'S CURRENTLY GOING TO
EDUCATION SO THIS IS ADDITIONAL
BUT I GUESS I'D HAVE TO ASK
QUESTION WE DO THIS AND
INITIATIVES ALL TIME?
ARE YOU WILLING TO PUT IN A BACK
FILLED TO ENSURE THAT THAT
AMOUNT BECAUSE OF IT ACTUALLY
DOES SUPPRESS DIRECT LAW RETURNS.
THAT THERE'S THAT WE PROTECT THE
AMOUNT OF MONEY THAT CURRENTLY
GOES EDUCATION THE LOTTERY SO
WE'RE CHANGING THE FORMAL
WHATEVER.
WE PUT IT BACK FILL AND TO BE
SURE THAT THAT THE PEOPLE WHO
DEPEND FIRST OFF I GUESS THE THE
THE REGIONAL FUNDS THEREFORE
DON'T.
KNOW SHRINK AS WE'RE TRYING TO
TO I GUESS GOING TO THAT WELL
FOR ANOTHER PURPOSE IS IS THAT
IT IS. TO TO MEET INTENT OF WHAT
YOU SAID IN TERMS OF FOR THE
FUNDING COMING FROM ABSOLUTELY
SO SO THE BILL JUST INCREASES
THE AMOUNT THAT THE STATE
LOTTERY FUNDS -- THAT MUST BE
MADE PUBLIC SCHOOLS TO THE TO AT
LEAST IN MY ALLOCATE ON THE
AVERAGE OF PRIOR FIVE FISCAL
YEARS OR AT LEAST AS MUCH
WITHOUT LOOKING FOR TWENTY
EIGHTEEN TWENTY NINETEEN FISCAL
YEAR AND ALSO THIS IS JUST FOR
THREE YEARS FOR THE STATE.
THE SCHOOL YEARS OF 202-020-2120
TWO TWENTY ONE OR TWENTY TWO
TWENTY TWO TO TWENTY THREE SO
IT'S IT'S IT'S IT'S NOT GOING IT
IS DEFINITELY NOT GOING TO TO
TAKE FROM.
THE EXISTING FUNDS AND THAT'S
ALREADY A STATED IN THE BILL
OKAY ALL RIGHT WELL I I JUST AND
I HOPE THAT YOU'LL HAVE A
FURTHER CONVERSATION OF THE
OPPOSITION I I'M JUST ALSO
SAYING THAT.
WE SHOULD THINK ABOUT IT BACK TO
BILL PROVISION TO GUARANTEE THAT
THAT DOESN'T HAPPEN SO IN OTHER
WORDS I WILL GET.
DEFINITELY OPEN TO THAT OKAY ALL
RIGHT AND AND I MEAN THERE'S
ANOTHER WHOLE ISSUE CATEGORICAL
BUT I DO WANT THE CONVERSATION
CONTINUES I THINK YOU HAVE SOME
IDEAS THAT THE LIKE BUT BUT AT
LEAST ON THE FUNDING SIDE I
WANNA BE SURE WE ACTUALLY TRULY
DO PROTECT.
BLOODY FUNNY THAT CURRENTLY GOES
TO EDUCATION AND THAT WE'RE NOT
CUTTING THAT'S DIMINISH BECAUSE
WE GOT FEWER PEOPLE DOING THE
LOTTERY OR WHATEVER ELSE AND
THAT THAT THERE'S A BACK FILL.
THAT LEASE IN PLACE AS WELL TO
BE SURE THAT THAT FUNDING
DOESN'T GO DOWN.
THANK YOU AND I I DO WANT TO
NOTE YOU KNOW AND I BELIEVE YOU
GUYS HAVE PROBABLY GONE THIS
CHART A FIFTY IF MY STAFF HAS
ENOUGH.
YES SO.
THE FUNDING THE REVENUES ARE
GOING UP SKYROCKETING AND
FUNDING TO EDUCATION IS FLAT
LINED I'M NOT SOMETHING THAT WE
DEFINITELY SHOULD BE LOOKING
INTO.
AND I JUST WANT TO KIND OF
ANSWER THE QUESTION OF OF THE
YOU KNOW CATEGORICAL BUT IF WE
DON'T ESTABLISH DEDICATED
FUNDING LEAVE IT TO L. CFF WE
MAY ACTUALLY EXACERBATE THE
ISSUES.
AROUND EQUITY IN LOW INCOME
DISTRICTS AND I THINK THIS IS
SUCH AS THE CREDIBLE IMPORTANT --
A POINT TO MAKE IN MAKING SURE
OUR KIDS ARE GETTING THE
COMPUTER SCIENCE EDUCATION
BECAUSE THIS IS THIS IS AS WE
ALL KNOW THE FUTURE SO.
THANK YOU IN THIS BILL IS
REFERRED TO GEO AFTER THIS SO
MAYBE YOU CAN TALK ABOUT SOME OF
THE ELEMENTS THAT ANYTHING ELSE
ON THE COMMITTEE.
SENATOR DRAWS A YES -- I TO
THANK YOU -- REALLY AGREE WITH
THAT WITH THE POLICY SIDE OF IT
I I THINK IT'S MY GRANDDAUGHTER
JUST GOT.
INTO A SHE'S TEN AND SHE JUST
GOT INTO A A STEM YOU KNOW.
KIND OF I GUESS THAT'S THE BEST
WAY TO DESCRIBE IT AND ALL THAT --
AND SHE'S REALLY EXCITED AND
THAT'S THE WAY TO GO IT'S NOT
JUST HOW TO USE AN IPAD BUT IT'S
REALLY TO LEARN.
WHAT'S INSIDE THAT COMPUTER HOW
DO YOU MAKE IT WORK FOR US SO --
ON THE OTHER HAND I I'M NOT YET
COMFORTABLE WITH THE TAKING THE
FUNDING FROM THE LOTTERY -- HOW
WOULD THAT IMPACT I THINK
THERE'S JUST A LOT MORE THAT I
NEED TO UNDERSTAND BECAUSE I'M?
I'M WORRIED.
THAT WITH A THE GOOD INTENTION
ON THE POLICY SIDE THAT THERE'S
GONNA BE A IMPACT THAT HASN'T
YET BEEN.
FIGURED OUT SO -- THAT'S THE
PART THAT I'M MOST CONCERNED
ABOUT WHILE STILL SUPPORTING
THIS AND I DO BELIEVE THAT FROM
THE STATE WE HAVE TO PUSH.
THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS THEY HAVE A
LOT OF MANDATES THAT COST A LOT
OF MONEY.
BUT I DO THINK THAT WE HAVE TO
PUSH THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO
ADOPT OF THESE KINDS OF PROGRAMS
OTHERWISE.
IT'S JUST GONNA BE LEFT OUT
THERE HANG IN AND ESPECIALLY
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR GIRLS.
ARE NOT GETTING ACCESS TO THIS
SO I'M REALLY CAUGHT BETWEEN THE
TWO BUT I DON'T WANNA
[inaudible]
IMPACT OUR OF FUNDING FOR PUBLIC
EDUCATION BY DOING THIS IN A WAY
THAT I'M I'M STILL NOT FULLY
COMFORTABLE WITH.
SO -- AGAIN WE ARE NOT TAKING
FROM EXISTING FUNDING WE'RE
ASKING WE'RE ACTUALLY TAKING
MORE MONEY FROM THE PAY OUT --
TO CONTRIBUTE -- TO THIS
PARTICULAR PROGRAM SO WE ARE NOT
DEFINITELY NOT TOUCHING WHAT IS.
AS A CURRENTLY THERE.
THE CENTER DRAWS OF THANK YOU
CENTER CHANNEL CENTER GLAZER.
YEAH I CERTAINLY AGREE WITH THE
GOALS THAT YOU SET FOR WHAT WHY
WE WANT TO DIRECT MONEY IN THAT
WAY AND BUT THERE IS SOME
COMPLEXITY TO THIS I KNOW I'M
GONNA HEAR THE BILL AGAIN IN GEO
AND AND A FEW DAYS -- HAPPY TO
MOVE THE BILL FORWARD TODAY BUT
UNDERSTANDING I I STILL HAVE
SOME HESITATION ABOUT IT.
THANK YOU CENTER GLAZER AKANE
TAKE THAT AS A MOTION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANYTHING
ELSE ON THE COMMITTEE.
CENTER CHANNEL JUDGE CLOSE.
THIS WANTED.
TO MENTION THAT AS THE FIFTH
LARGEST ECONOMY IN THE WORLD
MOST POPULOUS THE NATION
CALIFORNIA IS AT RISK.
OF LOSING ITS COMPETITIVE EDGE
IF WE DON'T ACT NOW AND BY
CREATING THIS GRANT PROGRAM --
DEDICATED TO FINDING COMPUTER
SCIENCE COURSES IN PUBLIC
SCHOOLS WE CAN GIVE CALIFORNIA
STUDENT GREATER ADVANTAGE TO
LEAD IN THE TWENTY FIRST CENTURY
IN WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR MY VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER CHAIN THE
BILL'S BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR
GLAZER MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
I AM TWENTY SB SIX SEVENTY FIVE
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION
LEYVA.
LEAVE THE I WILL WILK I CHIANG I
CHIANG I'D LASSELL.
GLAZER GLAZER AYE MCGUIRE
MCGUIRE AYE PAN.
PAN HI.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT THE BILLS
OUT SIX ZERO MEMBERS WHAT A
PRODUCTIVE DAY WE ARE NOW GOING
TO DO THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
ARE THERE ANY ITEMS.
WHAT'S THAT YOU'RE MOVING IT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SO KNOWN WAS
ONE THING OFF CONSENT EXCELLENT
THE MOTION -- TO ACCEPT THE
CONSENT SET CALENDAR WHICH IS
ITEM SIX SB THREE FORTY SIX BY
JACKSON ITEM EIGHT SB THREE
SIXTY SIX BY CHIANG.
AND ITEM NINETEEN SB FIVE EIGHTY
SIX AS AMENDED BY SENATOR ROTH.
A MOTION WAS MADE BY SENATOR PAN
MA'AM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL LEYVA AYE LEYVA AYE WILK HI
WILK I CHIANG.
CHIANG I'D LASSELL WHO HAS SO
I'D GLAZER GLAZER AYE MCGUIRE
MCGUIRE AYE PAN.
PAN AYE.
THAT IS OUT SEVEN ZERO WE ARE
NOW GOING TO LIFT THE CALL ON
BILLS WE'RE GOING TO START WITH.
FILE ITEM NUMBER SEVEN SENATOR
TO ROSS SO PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
ITEM SEVEN SB THREE FIFTY FOR
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I VICE CHAIR HASN'T VOTED.
FOUR ZERO WILK HI WILK I GLAZER.
GLAZER I'D PAN PAN ONLINE.
THE BILL IS OUT SEVEN ZERO WE
WANT TO GIVE THE MISTER CHAIR AN
OPPORTUNITY TO GET READY FOR
HEALTH COMMITTEE.
NOW WE WILL GO AND FILE ORDER
STARTING WITH FILE ITEM NUMBER.
ONE PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS.
ITEM ONE AS TO THE MOTION IS DO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I VICE CHAIR VOTING I SIX
ZERO MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE I DOUBT THAT BILLS OUT
SEVEN ZERO WILL NOW MOVE TO FILE
ITEM NUMBER.
TWO PLEASE CALL ABSENT MEMBERS
ITEM TO SB THREE THE MOTION IS
DO YOU PASSED TO GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATION WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING AYE MEISTER VOTING I FIVE
ZERO CHIANG.
CHAIN AYE MCGUIRE MCGUIRE AYE.
THAT BILLS OUT SEVEN ZERO FILE
ITEM NUMBER.
THREE ITEM THREE SB TWO OH SIX
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I ADVISED HER VOTING I'VE.
FIVE ZERO GLAZER.
GLAZER AYE MCGUIRE MCGUIRE AYE.
SEVEN ZERO THAT BOTH VOTED BILL
IS OUT AS WELL FILE ITEM NUMBER.
FOUR ITEM FOR SB TWO SIXTY FIVE
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I ADVISED HER VOTING AYE.
THREE ZERO CHIANG.
CHIANG I'D WOULD ASAL LUNA SO I
GLAZER.
GLAZER AYE MCGUIRE MCGUIRE AYE.
THAT BILLS ALSO OUT SEVEN ZERO
FILE ITEM NUMBER FIVE ITEM FIVE
SB TWO NINETY SIX THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I VICE CHAIR VOTING I
FIVE ZERO GLAZER.
GLAZER AYE MCGUIRE MCGUIRE AYE.
THE BILLS ALSO OUT. SEVEN ZERO
TWO THREE TWO FIVE TWO SIX THE
RECORD.
WE ARE NOW.
FILE ITEM NUMBER SEVEN WHICH WE
JUST DID FILE ITEM NUMBER. EIGHT
OR THE NINE EIGHT WAS A WEIGHT
WAS ON CASSETTE RECORDER NOTS
FILE ITEM NUMBER FILE ITEM
NUMBER.
NINE ITEM NINE SB FOUR TWENTY
SIX THE MOTION IS DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS WITH
THE CHAIR VOTING I VICE CHAIR
HASN'T VOTED THREE ZERO WILK
[inaudible]
CHIANG.
RUSSELL.
RUSSELL I'D MCGUIRE MCGUIRE AYE.
THE BILL IS OUT.
FIVE ZERO FILE ITEM NUMBER.
TEN ITEM TEN AS BEFORE FORTY
THREE THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I VICE CHAIR HASN'T VOTED
FOR ZERO WILK.
GLAZER.
GLAZER AYE MCGUIRE MCGUIRE AYE.
SIX SIX ZERO THAT BILLS OUT FILE
ITEM.
ELEVEN ITEM ELEVEN AS BEFORE
SIXTY ONE THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS WITH
THE CHAIR VOTING I'VE I SURE
HASN'T VOTED THREE ZERO WILK HI
WILK I CHIANG.
CHIANG I'D TO ASAL LUDA SO I
MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE AYE.
THE BILL IS OUT.
SEVEN ZERO WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
FILE ITEM NUMBER TWELVE ITEM
TWELVE AS BEFORE SIXTY SEVEN THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I VICE CHAIR VOTING I
FOUR ZERO CHIANG.
THE CHAIN HIGH TO WRESTLE WITH
US SO I IT MCGUIRE [inaudible]
MCGUIRE EIN.
BUT BILLS OUT SEVEN ZERO FILE
ITEM.
THIRTEEN ITEM THIRTEEN SB FOUR
EIGHTY FOUR THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS WITH
THE CHAIR VOTING I'VE I SURE
VOTING I'VE FOUR ZERO CHIANG.
CHIANG I'D WOULD ASSUME.
WOULD ALSO AYE MCGUIRE MCGUIRE
AYE.
VERY GOOD FILE ITEM. FOURTEEN TO
UP SEVEN ZERO THAT BILLS OUT
FILE ITEM.
FOURTEEN ITEM FOURTEEN SB FOUR
NINETY THREE THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO JUDICIARY WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING I ADVISED HER
VOTING I SIX ZERO GLAZER.
THAT PULLS OUT SIX ZERO FILE
ITEM.
FIFTEEN ITEM FIFTEEN AS BEFORE
NINETY NINE THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I VICE CHAIR VOTING I SIX
ERO GLAZER.
GLAZER AYE THE BILL IS OUT SEVEN
ZERO FILE ITEM SIXTEEN ITEMS
SIXTEEN SB FIVE FORTY ONE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I VICE CHAIR VOTING I SIX
ZERO GLAZER.
CAN SIX BILLS OUT SIX ZERO FILE
ITEM SEVENTEEN ITEM SEVENTEEN SB
FIVE FIFTY FOR THE MOTION IS DO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS OF THE CHAIR
VOTING I VICE CHAIR HASN'T VOTED
THREE ZERO WILK.
WILK I CHIANG CHIANG I'D TO
WRESTLE.
WITH US SO I MCGUIRE MCGUIRE AYE.
THE BILL IS OUT SEVEN ZERO FILE
ITEM EIGHTEEN ITEM EIGHTEEN SB
FIVE SIXTY THREE THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I'VE I SURE HASN'T VOTED.
THREE ZERO WILK WILK I CHANGE
CHIANG I'D RUSSELL RUSSELL AYE
MCGUIRE MCGUIRE AYE.
THE BILL IS OUT [inaudible]
SEVEN ZERO WE CAN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IT WAS A
LONG HEARING THANK YOU FOR ALL
OF YOUR TIME AND ATTENTION.
GO ON AND HAVE A REST FOR THE A
GREAT DAY AND THANK YOU TO
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR ALL OF YOUR
HARD WORK